um ladies and gentlemen uh can I before
we get started which will be in a few
minutes can I just uh ask you please I
know a number of you have signs you're
going to really need you're going to
need to take the signs uh can't be in
the room that's just our rule so please
if you have signs please take those
signs it's not it's not enough to just
put them down please take them outside
the room okay thank
you
ladies and gentlemen again before we get
started can I just note for your
information we have I know that that
some people who uh either support or
oppose this bill and um but do not wish
to testify have signed the blue sheets I
think it's it's important that you un
that you understand that the blue sheets
that are up there are are that are out
there are not just for this bill there
are blue sheets out there for all the
bills we're going to be hearing today
which includes some that we're going to
be hearing this afternoon that have
nothing to do with this so my only point
is if you thought that all the blue
sheets were for this bill and you signed
up to support or or object you if you
didn't look carefully you may have
signed the wrong blue sheet so uh please
be sure that if you if you wanted to you
know voice your view on hp1 1283 that's
this bill that that's the form you
signed and not a bill that has nothing
to do with this okay
thanks 90 proba yeah pretty close 88 87
all
right one minute to
go one
from all right
yeah
all right it is 10:00 a.m. I'm going to
call the house Judiciary Committee to
order and I first will recognize
representative Paige to lead us in the
pledge of
allegiance to the flag the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all so um ladies and gentlemen before we
get started I just want to kind of uh
set just a couple of ground rules um we
want to give everybody we know that
there are people have strong views on on
this issue on whatever side you may be
on and we want to have every every body
have an opportunity to be heard I have
about 90 people who've signed up to
testify um in light of that I'm going to
impose except for the the first witness
who is the Prime sponsor in in in
accordance with our Traditions I'm going
to impose on other Witnesses a
limitation of two minutes uh for your
testimony and we're going to have to
enforce that fairly strictly the other
thing I would say please is this um I
know I I understand that people may be
nervous if you're testing toine that's
completely understandable um please
understand though if you have written
testimony we want to receive that and we
will receive just you all you have to do
is hand it in us and we will you know
we'll be happy to receive it we will
read it um and uh and and your you know
what you've had to say will be
considered by us it really is not
helpful I think to us if you have
written testimony if you just come up
and spend your two minutes reading it
that is not particularly helpful to us
it would be much better to have you sort
of speak extemporaneously tell us you
know what you want to tell us so to
speak I think we would all find that
much much uh more helpful um so I hope
that you'll please do that um uh and
with that I'm going to recognize the uh
Prime sponsor representative
Smith thank you Mr
chairman my name is margerie Smith I
represent Durham in the New Hampshire
house and I am honored to be the prime
sponsor of this bill joined by many
people who cover the broad spectrum of
philosophical and political views in the
legislature in a desperate world we all
have two things in
common we were
born and we will die in 1990 my family
returned to New Hampshire so that my
husband could work for the disability
rights Center to address the inequities
facing the disability
Community a goal that Peter and I
shared at about the same time my beloved
niece Deborah at age 23 suffered a
debilitating stroke that affected her
for the rest of her too short life but
she spent those years educating those of
us who were
temporarily abled bodied in her words
about the challenges facing those with
disabilities and working and earning
honors as an effective
advocate in my earliest years in the
legislature Bob guest and Marian
copenhaver along with others sponsored a
bill on this very subject and it came to
the Judiciary Committee that was more
than 25 years ago but the shock I
experienced in that hearing has stayed
with me caring competent committed
Physicians spoke of how they felt
powerless to help their patients who
were nearing the end of their lives and
experiencing unbearable
pain they were concerned that if they
used drugs to minimize the pain they
could be charged with a crime that same
concern was expressed by dedicated
concerned members of the burgeoning
hospice community and by patients
nearing the end of their lives and their
families since then at regular intervals
bills addressing this issue of end of
life appeared some to form study
committees some to take specific action
some passed one house or another some
pass both only to die on the governor's
desk the opposition tended to come
primarily from three groups some members
of the disability Community afraid that
there would be pressure for them to end
their
lives some representatives of the
hospital Community for reasons that I
can't explain and the leaders but not
necessarily a majority of the
parishioners of one particular religious
denomination believing as I do in the
constitutionally established separation
of church and state I respect and
protect the rights of the individuals to
make religious-based choices for
themselves but not to use that power of
the government to apply those choices to
others this bill supported and sponsored
by legislators across party and policy
lines requires an expectation of death
within six months
absolute mental
competency the testimony of two
independent medical professionals and a
short waiting period it would provide no
relief to those suffering from
long-standing debilitating diseases
without an expectation of death within
six months as compared with legislation
in other states this is a very narrow
and conservative
Bill and it was designed find that way
deliberately to give New Hampshire a
chance to put its toe in the waters the
independent UNH poll demonstrates the
widespread support for adding medical
Aid and dying to the options available
to a small specifically defined group of
New Hampshire
citizens the time is now for New
Hampshire to join its sister States in
providing this option to our
citizens rather than answering any any
of your questions since there will be
ample time for you to ask questions of
me later I will return to my seat on the
committee now so that all of us might
hear from our constituents about an
issue that affects every one of them and
of us thank you for listening thank you
representative
Smith the chair now calls Representative
Steve Woodcock
please
good morning and uh thank you Mr chair
and thank you to for the opportunity to
speak about Medical Aid and dying HP
1283 for the record the bill called end
of life options in New Hampshire I will
leave this document with the clerk to
save some time for us so she can have my
testimony when I'm done my name is Steve
Woodcock and I am a representative from
Conway but I'm here today on behalf of
all the citizens of New
Hampshire first let me say that there
are very few rights in New Hampshire as
right to choose your body your choice
that can I just can I just ask you to
push the push the that's it thank you
thank you uh that said the Medical Aid
and dying bill is very limited option
bill with a host of Highly specific
criteria representative Smith has done a
wonderful job introducing the bill and
I'm confident that honorable Brown when
she speaks will be able to answer any
and all of your questions regarding the
fin and points of the bill so for those
two reasons I'll ommit the duplication
of information and speak for my reason
for support of this bill years ago a guy
waterman one of New England's leading
conservation environmentalists and the
author of The well- read book in New
Hampshire backwood ethics hiked to the
top of the mountains and the whites in
midwinter and purposely froze to death
his wife knew the impending death and at
the appointed time notified the local
conservation officers so that they could
retrieve his body this shouldn't have to
happen in this country's livefree or die
state New Hampshire and this legislature
has multiple Libertarians that spous
limited government intervention I hope
they stand up and support their words
when this bill comes to the floor I have
had many family members who have had a
much greater quality of life and R
respectful passing in their law
more
recently just a few months ago as a
matter of fact my brother had to be
moved by ambulance from One hospital to
another two states away so that he would
be allowed and I would be allowed as his
provider to assist his medical Aid and
dying I won't go in the details of his
decline but it was horrific and
devastating to observe the best I could
do was abide by his final wishes and
thank goodness he had made the proper
legal medical preparation for that
moment this did not make the pain for
his passing any easier but for me I
trust it did for him members of the
committee this bill is not about your
religious beliefs no mine it's not about
your political beliefs no mine but
rather it's our friends neighbors and
families who have to deal with terms and
phrases like metastized inoperable
throughout your body stage four this is
their reality there are no Health
decisions here that ship has long left
the dock the only remaining is final
care options Medical Aid and dying and
of Life options should not be seen
through the lens of religious or
political movement of position it is
simply the right of a terminally ill
person to choose the best process for a
dignified life and equally dignified
passing I thank you for your attention
and ask that you pass HB 1283 onto the
house with an OTP recommendation thank
you representative questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
represent here the party omitted is in
the testimony safe time thank you I'm
next going to call Representative Glenn
Cordell cordelli
please uh thank you Mr chairman
honorable committee members for the
record Glenn cordelli representing
Tuftonboro wolf bro and O and the
Beautiful Lakes Region um I felt called
last night to be here to tell the sister
my sister Susan's story
um we had a special relationship I was
adopted from an orphanage in New York
City when I was a few months old two
years later my parents took me back to
that orphanage and I picked out my
sister decades later after a messy
divorce um my uh sister was left with
two young Sons to
raise a couple of years later she was
diagnosed with stage four ovarian cancer
she for 10 years the papers dubbed her
the miracle Lady of Western
Massachusetts the doctors were not sure
how she survived I
know she started an ovarian support
group she wrote a book a poetry called
eggless wisdom let me just read one poem
from that how to live with a terminal
illness do not die respect your body
respect your emotions more practice
denial indulge your Terror and sadness
but only in specific time allotments
take care of those you love allow those
who love you to take care of you be a
real when the situation demands
advocacy always choose living over dying
peace over
pain new over old and above all humor
over tragedy and always leave room for
the
future she lived on pain medicine for
the a last number of years of her life
you named the pain medicine she had it
morphine
Etc um it was when her youngest son
finally told her it's okay Mom I'll be
all right that the end started to happen
um I will never forget the scene in the
hospital when she was
dying the window
thunder and lightning outside and we
held hands and said the Lord's Prayer as
she passed away it was it was um a
beautiful moment um and I know God was
in the room at that
point natural death can be beautiful and
meaningful and it's something
I never forget thank you
thank you representative questions for
this
witness let's let's keep that none of
that okay please all right thank you
very much representative um
representative uh our former
representative Kurt wper
please well and you know you know I'm
just so that people please take a seat
representative um just what I'm going to
do is announce the next witness um so
that I know there are people in the
Overflow room so that they uh so that if
they're there they can make arrangements
to come up and the next witness after
this one will be representative Linda um
uh hassink please all right yes
representative wer good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee uh
it's good to be I can put ah got the mic
on okay great thank you it's uh good to
be back with you again uh I will be as
brief as I reasonably can be and I and
expect it I'll go over so please tell me
and I'll just stop okay so first of all
you have a handout from New Hampshire
right I'm here representing New
Hampshire right to life and all our
supports across the
state secondly you have written
testimony from New Hampshire right to
life there's a little packet from in
front of each of you has four documents
one is that written testimony one is a
table of suicide deaths from Canada for
the last 10 or 12 year from Oregon for
the last 10 or 12 years one is a handout
about Canada and the timeline that took
get get to where they are and uh one is
uh we asked our friends at New National
right to life to analyze this bill in
light of national laws and they did that
and there's a several page analysis of
that as part of that
packet what I want to say today is
suicide is not Health Care it never will
be Health Care at the last
minute it's a voluntary choice on the
part of the individual
which is the very definition of
suicide it's a slippery
slope a very slippery
slope the Netherlands started with
assisted suicide 50 odd years
ago over
time it expanded it expanded without any
changes to the law their law started out
narrow like ours did is but expanded
without changes to the law why because
it State sanctions suicide and when the
state gives it sanction when we call it
Medical Care medical professionals are
influenced by
that they want care for their clients
patients and so the person is close to
death we all know it and isn't it better
to just increase the medic ation just
whatever and so but that just became
accepted as medical practices there was
no change to the
law and it
took 40 plus years for them to actually
change the law but suicide expand
Medical Aid expanded
anyway
why because the there were court cases
every restriction in this law every
single one can be challenged in the
court of law why do you have to have a
terminal illness why does it have to be
six months why can't it be something
else and you know what courts can't
decide these things and so the courts
always ruled you could expand you could
expand you could expand and so it did
this is again without any changes to the
law and eventually they did legalize
euthanasia and now it's worse than it
was
before but it's spreading around the
world so we'll talk about Canada just
for a minute it took Canada seven years
to get to the place where Canada took 50
years and now Canada along with the
Netherlands are leading the world in how
many people can commit suicide and they
they wanted to extend it to the mental e
last week last week they were going to
going to expand it to me the mental eill
you could you can commit suicide just
because you're mental ill right Wolford
you're you're uh I think you're beyond
your two minutes uh okay so I ask you to
consider this who benefits from this now
who benefits from it as time goes on and
can we live with State sanctions
assisted suicide I say the answer is no
and I ask you iail this Bill thank you
thank you questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much uh
representative uh uh hassink uh please
and the next witness after that will be
representative
uh William pal
Palmer Palmer yes okay yes hi good
morning colleagues and friends for the
record my name is Linda H Haskins I
represent sorry about that I represent
Rockingham 11
exer I'm a co-sponsor on this bill
because I believe it is a common sense
solution to a
heartache that has caused many families
to regret how their loved one died I
want this not only for myself but for
all my loved ones and for all of you
many of us know someone who has died a
painful death
although we may be living
longer than previous generations for
many terminal patience the end of life
is filled with needless
suffering and pain for them and their
loved
ones we can do
better dying a slow painful
death an inevitable death is not what we
want for our ourselves or those we love
but sadly that is the reality for many
families we will all experience grief in
losing a loved one what this bill does
is to eliminate suffering for terminal
patients the bill has been carefully
crafted with the guidelines and guard
rails to ensure that adults with a
terminal
illness can choose to die in peace
rather than connected to tubes and
machines in a hospital
setting my own mother was transferred
from a local facility to Mass
General where she Lay Dying For weeks
tended by well-meaning
strangers while her children were kept
outside her room and only allowed to
visit visit at designated times
representative you're you're uh getting
close to your limit thank you there was
no dignity in her death it was not what
she would have chosen and it was not
what we would have chosen for her I urge
you to support this bill and send it to
the full house for a vote thank you
thank you questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much now I I
hope that I'm reading this correctly
representative William Palmer and the
next uh representative after that to be
called will be representative David uh
rord
please
hi hi thank you Mr
chairman I'm Bill Palmer I represent
Sullivan District 2 which is Cornish in
planfield and I'm here testifying today
because I've been a hospice medical
director for 28 years and am now still a
hospitalist delivering significant
amounts of hospice
care
um I think you'll hear a lot about
um rationale for this bill my experience
working in Vermont most of the time over
the last uh 10 years when act 39 has
been in
effect has been that this is a rarely
accessed
um uh option but a very vital one um
quite a number of patients will ask
about it um very few end up pursuing it
one of the most important things is that
just having access gives people a lot of
relief in my written testimony I've
outlined a case of exactly that um I
think the other thing that I'll say
today is that there are certainly times
when we've run through every possible
option uh medical
option spiritual option um getting
families to visit people who are dying
and who are in distress that this is one
option that in Vermont really has made a
vital difference in how people can relax
and and
really their sufferings alleviated just
knowing that this is an option um I
personally have only had one patient go
all the way through the steps and take
the medication out of hundreds and
hundreds of of patients but many of them
have experienced a great deal of relief
just knowing that's that's the option so
I hope you will support this bill and
pass OTP out of this committee thank you
questions for this
witness thank you yes representative
pess thank you thank you for taking my
question uh you as a hospice physician
is it my understanding if you go into
Hospice Care um that you have to
terminate all your opt all your care all
your treatments so so this is always the
problem with with the word hospice is
there is a a Medicare benefit benef
which is hospice medical benefit and
other insurance companies recognize that
and that is true of that but a lot of
the patients like the patient in this um
story that I'm I'll pass around um were
on were obtaining pallative care they
were on hospice and so basically their
whole Focus was on Comfort not on any
further treatment but they weren't part
of the
Medicare official hospice program
followup yes it's my understanding
I was a nurse for 42 years I watched
people die I worked intensive care I
worked
cardiac it's my understanding that Pala
of care and hospice care are very
different hospice
care technically according to your your
insurance and and Medicaid you no longer
can receive treatment for your ailment
paliative Care on the other hand which
can start way before the six months you
can receive all kinds of care you
treatments for your um for your illness
or condition along with um uh mental
health and so all kinds of care so
that's my understanding has that
changed I think the way we talk about
it's changed and I think there are
people behind me who are um certified
pallative and hospice care physicians
who can probably talk to the details I'm
probably a little bit oldfashioned and I
sort of consider it hospice but I think
most people now talk about paliative
care which usually starts right with a
diagnosis say of cancer or end stage
long or heart disease and that and and
the two things proceed in parallel so
you're getting pallative care along with
your chemotherapy and radiation therapy
right and but the hospice medic Medicare
bu does not allow that right it's it's
right it's underused and it's a very
specific thing my mother-in-law my
mother was on it my mother-in-law's on
it because they wanted to stay home and
not go back to the hospital anymore and
so that's where that one more quick
followup yep you don't have to be in the
hospital to receive Hospice Care is that
care true right the whole a lot of the
point of of the hospice benefit is to
try and keep people at home or or where
they want to be whether it's in at home
or in a nursing home okay thank you very
much thanks for taking my question other
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much sir uh next uh
representative David rord and next uh
the next one after that will be
represent ative Gary
Merchant presentative
roord thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee uh my name is
David Rochford I represent Grafton 1 I'm
from Littleton uh I'm one of two
pharmacists in the legislature here in
conquer and I come here um not to take a
position per se but to to point out a
fairly uh obvious I assume unintentional
Omission in the legislation and uh the
Omission it if you could follow along
with me begins on page six lines 6
through 10 when it talks about the
indemnification of uh health care and
I'm going to use the quotes health care
providers who are participating in this
uh
activity um and it talks about no
healthc care providers who you know
there can be a conscientious objection
as well uh and if you go to
page one um line 15 where defines Health
Care Providers talks about Physicians
osteopathic Physicians advanced practice
registered nurses Physicians assistants
and talks about those who are authorized
to prescribe medications and I would ask
because pharmacists are going to play a
role in this that we add on line 16
prescribe or dispense
medications and then on line make a new
line 21 where 20 is and add uh a
pharmacist licensed pursuant to RSA
318 I would also suggest on within the
definitions is defining a dispensing
health care provider means and add that
to the uh um to to the bill
um and of course in and you know when I
first thought of that I thought maybe
far weren't included in this but they
clearly are on page four and
understanding how the mechanics of this
works and familiar with how it works in
Vermont U the pharmacist will be
participating in this so I think before
the committee if anything happens at
this committee before it goes across the
street um we just take into
consideration that dispensing is the
first half or prescribing is the first
half but dispensing is the second half
of this uh and that's all I had is just
those requests for for fix it yes
questions representative Perez thank you
as a pharmacist I had a concern about
the fact that I'll give you an example
when we were
um having people um the death sentence
okay we found that things were cruel and
abusive and we couldn't do them and that
when they had Lethal Injections they
found that those Lethal Injections were
cruel and abusive my con concern is that
there is no definition in here not
saying what the drugs are but stating
that um current um practice medications
because what people are using today may
be entirely different than what they're
using three years from now do you
understand what I'm saying yeah I
understand that and so but there's
nothing in here that says anything about
what is being prescribed and um that
that's a concern do you see that as a
pharmacist being a concern well I think
that
uh if I may uh um and and and I'm not
you know this is not a endorsing or or
or otherwise of the legislation I think
anytime you get so granular and so
specific in the legislation as about
what agent has to be used what drug has
to be us that's not what I'm asking okay
all right May I'm asking that it say
something about uh not current but um
well oh I see what you're saying Medical
current medical according to current
medical practice or whatever um that's
not the term I want to use um um so that
it can
change it can change and be updated
without there being an issue to the
pharmacist or to the physician sure and
I think I I think that's a that's a good
point um that you bring up and uh that
may be you know something to consider uh
as you as the committee works works
through the details of this thank you
other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you all right uh representative
Gary Merchant and the next uh witness
after that will be representative uh
Katherine prome
O'Brien good morning Mr chairman and
also the committee uh for the record my
name is Gary Merchant representing
selvan County district 6 which is the
proud towns of Claremont and
I won't um repeat what representative
roord said he's also a pharmacist like
myself I think he spoke to the issues we
have as far as the pharmacy community
that somehow the bill does include
reference for the dispenser as well as
the prescriber so I want to be sure that
that's taken care if we can within the
bill or some sort of an amendment I do
come in support of the bill um I have
worked as a hospice pharmacist I have
seen like a lot of folks around this
table patients die um and it's it's a
lot of of agne particular in the family
and a lot of times there are family
members like the patient who really want
to put the
person in the place they're going to go
in a timely way and a kind way and not
through a lot of agne to watch as the
nurse said Mr perz represent Perez it's
hard it's harder on the family sometimes
and the patient and I think one of the
things to think about is that when you
are looking at this from the patient's
point of view it's really an option it's
not something that they have to do and I
can share with you having been involved
with hospice in going into a patient's
home to clean out the med
cabinet there are drugs in the med
cabinet that are completely
empty no one prescribed it that way but
it happens because the ones who are of
the know understand how to use the drugs
as a professor said to me once upon a
time every single drug is a poison with
therapeutic side effects the only thing
that separates the poison from a drug
with beneficial benefits is the dose so
patients who understand that aspect have
it available per se to them today but
they don't have the opportunity to talk
to a healthcare provider about that
option unless you're like I said have
somebody in the family who understands
that so therefore if you can correct the
bill
so the dispensers are actually included
and also think about the patients
themselves and the family members and
the acting they go through when they're
dying thank you questions for this
witness seeing none representa I wonder
if I could uh press you and maybe the
prior witness because of your expertise
into service and just ask you if you
could perhaps uh think about exactly the
language that you think should go in
there and maybe then send me send me an
email with that language
uh uh so that we I mean obviously we're
going to discuss it in the committee but
it it sounds like that might you know
make some sense to put that what you
what the two of you have suggested into
the bill chairman Lyn I'd be more than
glad to do that I will Circle back with
my colleague on the other side of the
aisle and work with him on language to
get it to you folks to look at and
review thank you that'd be great thank
you very much um next representative
prol O'Brien and um the next witness
after that will be Shan
Rogers
good morning thank you for taking my
testimony
um couple things I want to talk about
this summer I had the honor of and I'm
going to try not to get upset but I had
the honor of caring for
my for a relative of mine who was
terminally ill
and she uh she had a difficult life up
to that point um she was in a women's
commune that fell apart and she lost her
entire
Community
um we had the opportunity to um to
shower her with love and tell her how
much we loved her appreciated her how
she was uh an Irreplaceable member of
our family and she moved in with with
arthritis soon as she got the diagnosis
and um it wasn't just about my being
able to tell her all of those
things she's one of my closest friends
ever but it was also about the rest of
the family being able to tell her that
and other people in our family seeing
that that how much we loved her and
valued her
um and this is healthy this is healthy
for Society for children to see
this I I uh I read a book a long time
ago by Cheryl sanberg about leaning in
she talked about the concept of leaning
in and um taking advantage of
opportunities
professionally for women and it was a
really interesting concept but I see I
see the larger picture of our society we
should we have two choices we can lean
in towards life or we can lean away from
it and all the steps that we take and I
felt like uh we were leaning in to life
even though she was she was passing
away and I think that as a society we
should take every opportunity to keep
leaning into life I know that um another
uh witness here came and and talked
about his work in the hospice industry
and he didn't have many requests for it
when you legalize something you uh
approve of it as a society and you get
more of it so it's rare now but I don't
know that that would be the case I'm
very concerned about what's happening in
Canada where people with minor illnesses
are are offered made Medical Aid and
dying and that's unconscionable and
although I think that people have the
best intentions with this
bill I think that it it could creep to
what the situation is in Canada what we
see in the Netherlands which is really
unconscionable to to to um offer Aid and
dying to a 28-year-old woman for
fibromyalgia who's autistic that that's
unconscionable those are those are other
issues that could be solved that we
could keep solving we don't need to tell
these people they they they should leave
that they should be killed un those are
my concerns thank you so much thank you
so much questions for this witness say
none thank you very much thank you uh
Shan Rogers and next will be Dr John
Edinger you it with me
sorry about that he's uh he was I tried
to have my friend watch him and it
didn't work out very well if you could
hear so turn your microphone off oh
there you go thank you okay sorry about
that um so excuse my son I apologize uh
but I've been a doctor for about 12
years um I uh often work with people who
are unfortunately at the end of their
lives and I wasn't really sure how I
felt about this bill until you know I
thought about it some and then I uh and
then I um uh talked to a several of my
friends who also work in paliative care
so they see many more patients than I do
who are unfortunately at the end of
their lives
and I don't think that this bill is
going to accomplish what it sets out to
do because patients who who are
diagnosed as terminal already are at the
end of are are already uh sorry are
already paliative uh are already hospice
candidates and so if they are hospice
candidates then often times they already
have the means to you know if they
wanted to to commit suicide they often
have access to the sedatives the
analgesics and the anti Medics oh thank
you
B and and to and so they could if they
wanted to but uh it is a fairly rare
thing for patients to want to kill
themselves I've never had a patient ask
me about it I asked my paliative care
doctor friends about it and they said
that it was also
somewhat rare but they could usually
work through it because
suicidality is not a disease in of
itself it is a symptom of the disease
Christopher
come and uh and it can usually be worked
through because there's usually
causative factors there's things such as
uh uncontrolled pain uncontrolled
discomfort things uh uh uh uncontrolled
uh psychiatric diseases and just a lack
of social and emotional support and
doctors can can treat those things
and and an even greater concern and so
it undermines the medical of uh medical
ethic of non-maleficence which is to do
no harm and then furthermore I think
that this bill might uh actually be a
trojan horse perhaps unintentionally uh
which representative Smith did sort of
allude to when she said it was a toe in
the water because when you legalize
physician assisted suicide then you know
the the topic of euthanasia comes to
bear as well and the Netherlands is is
doing it children of all ages babies can
be considered candidates for youth in
Asia and that's in many places in Europe
and in
Canada
and and um and Canada leads the world in
in organ donations and it's not
surprising that they have uh been caught
inappropriately offering euthanasia to
patients and China is another example
where where they have been accused of
selling
the of selling their the the organs and
the and the bodies of of of um of their
political dissidents and so I think that
the world is less safe and less secure
by opening the Pandora's Box um all
right and so I apologize uh I couldn't
find any sitter for my apologize but
that's pretty much what I had to say
questions for this witness
representative Perez thank you thanks
for I'll make it brief what type of
physician are you uh I'm I'm a internal
medicine and I work as a hospitalist
okay and one more question are you
limited because of what we have done
with opioids are you Limited in your
practice of how much pain medication you
are allowed to prescribe for your p uh
many uh as a point of my practice I
usually just prescribe uh one week of
opioids in many states it's becoming
more common for that to happen and uh uh
for them to limit that and I think if
there is a limitation on paliative
paliative doctors they should probably
be allowed to prescribe a longer period
of time so follow up quick y so
basically when we went after all the
pharmaceutical companies for op opioids
perhaps we should have taken into
consideration people with chronic pain
terminal illnesses and that type of
thing to be exempt from from that I
think that would solve a lot of the
problems and we wouldn't have the
controversy thank you other questions
for this witness seeing none thank you
very much sorry about that folks no
problem Dr John Edinger and then the
next witness after that will be Ed
Butler
and no it's okay and you know before you
begin doctor can I uh I know Mr Dunn is
in the audience Mr Dunn is this the
witness that you were talking thank you
very much all right Dr please go ahead
hi there I'm dealing with a little bit
of a throat issue this morning so I
apologize I'm a problem cardiologist
Catholic Medical Center I'm here on
behalf of myself um I also am president
of the Board of Medicine and um I am in
no way representing the board today I
just want to make sure people are aware
of that I'm simply here as a um
concerned physician I'm in opposition to
the bill I have a couple quick points I
deal with a lot of patients who are at
the end of life death and dying mostly
through congestive heart failure I hate
the the stories that have been um told
today because it's just you know it's
really not what we want as a medical
society for people to die in pain and
suffering we're both coming at this from
both sides of the coin have that as a
common as a have that as a common goal
we don't want people to die with pain we
don't want people to die with suffering
and I think similar to the uh
representative's Point going towards the
representatives point I think um using
the opiate epidemic as a uh as an
example we could have done a much better
job there in terms of how we prescribe
we were part of that problem the
prescribers themselves were part of that
problem and in terms of palea of care we
get very little training in medical
school in terms of how to pale how to
deal with dying I get a 99% of my
training is how to how to cure disease
how to help people how to get them
better we get very little at the end of
life so I see a bill like this and I say
to myself wow we're just going to create
an option where we're now going to um
move people right towards the end of
life very quickly we're not going to
focus on pil of care at all what I'd
like to see is the state Focus
significantly more effort and more funds
on palean on the end of life on dealing
with death and dying in this manner as
opposed to just prescribing a pill where
I can off somebody this is suicide it's
not it's just a it's the the terminology
in the bill they can't even really begin
to speak to it it's just you're
prescribing a drug which will kill you
I'm prescribing that drug um I see that
as changing our culture I see that that
is moving the needle and as another me
as another speaker just mentioned you
start to change the culture of the
discussion you start to change the
discussion you start to change society's
opinion as to what it's acceptable you
start moving into marginalized
populations and telling them it's more
acceptable for them to off themselves
you start to move towards more suicides
in society we have very little empiric
data on this but the data we have shows
that in states that have allowed Medical
Aid and dying we see the needle tick
towards more suicide I want to avoid
that it's very difficult to safe
this process the intent is there but I'm
very good at knowing when somebody's
going to die within a week if somebody's
going to die within 6 months very very
challenging to know that okay somebody
else gave an example about 10 years with
a terminal diagnosis I don't want to
make you a statistic I want to look at
you as an individual and give you the
care that you deserve but just calling
it six months and saying that's a sa
Safeguard it's very soft um it puts a
lot of burdens on the patient well you
know I could save $10,000 and if if I
take the pill my family doesn't go
through this burden but then your
family's left with the burden afterwards
did I make the right decision um doctor
you're uh you're kind of over your time
all I appreciate it so um I think we
start we have to start talking about
dying and not the cult not death I think
we need to do a better job with um being
compassionate supportive caring at the
end of life it doesn't come through a
pill it comes through caring I think we
can fund that better I think we can
train Physicians better um I'd like to
see legislative efforts towards that and
finally every day I have to battle
insurance companies on what I think is
the most effective um therapy it comes
down to cost in their mind we are all a
cost when it comes to insurance and a
payment model I don't want that to be an
option at the end of life for people I
want to be able to choose the best
option for them I don't want an
insurance company saying to me you know
what the pill's a great option and have
to question their incentives at the end
of life thank you very much thank you
questions for representative Perez thank
you thanks I actually managed your off
office 20 years ago oh I'm sorry it's
still a
mess um my concern with this and you
mentioned um uh congestive heart failure
sure um my concern with this is that
there are a lot of things left out of
this bill one of them being liver
disease that's not a terminal illness
it's a death sentence but it's not a
terminal illness um people who have um
um chronic pain with um an injury
perhaps um degenerative St injuries um
by accident kidney disease multiple
sclerosis spinal diseases none of these
are covered by this because this is
saying terminal
illness what's to say that we pass this
and we do like Canada did and have a
timeline and keep including all of these
things um do you see that as a problem
where none of these other things are
covered yeah I absolutely do see it as
is a problem the last attempt at at a
bill of this sort and um I think it was
maybe two years ago now um even within
the committee discussions we started to
see this being added on as a possibility
where neurodegenerative diseases were
going to be added it's a it's the
natural um point of discussion to keep
moving towards this as somebody has a
diagnosis which might be a terminal
illness but it might not be within six
months so it's going to be the natural
sort of progression of this I think
Canada is a great example in fact in
Canada right now next month when this is
enacted you don't have to have any
treatments you can be offered the
treatment I can be offered by any
depressive I can be offered my
counseling I can be offered ECT but I
don't have to take it I can just take
the pill and it gets us very slippery
slope thank you other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you all right um Ed
Butler and then um former representative
Ed Butler I guess and then the next will
be
uh uh Steven uh mot Dr Steven mot from
Dunbar thank you Mr
chair my name is Ed Butler I'm the chair
of New Hampshire Alliance For endof Life
options a Grassroots
organization I fervently believe in that
last word of our organization options
the bill before you provides an
important choice and additional option
for end of life care it's good to see
some familiar faces and friends and good
to meet those of you that I have not met
yet um I was a state rep for six terms
and I was the chair of the Commerce
Committee when the Democrats were in the
majority I've lived in New Hampshire for
30 years and I'm an inkeeper in Crawford
notch in Hearts location the smallest
town before moving to New Hampshire I
worked as a nurse in New York City in
several practice areas and ultimately
became a nursing home administrator and
was the director of the first long-term
care program for people with AIDS at the
height of that epidemic throughout my
career in healthcare I saw the ravages
the disease and illness can bring and
what seemed to me that unnecessary
suffering for some at the end of their
lives as you likely know Medical Aid and
dying is the law in 10 states and in DC
the First Medical Aid and dying bill
made Bill uh passed in Oregon 24 years
ago and it has a proven and positive
track record in all jurisdictions where
it is under Force our organization has
worked diligently to learn about and
understand how the laws in those states
have functioned and we we have helped to
craft and they have helped to craft the
bill before you not only did we reach
out to uh legislators and other states
where this law is enforced but we talked
with and consulted local St stakeholders
as well as eth ethicists healthc Care
Professionals and legal experts across
the country though this legislature is
has considered other bills regarding Aid
and dying as you heard from
representative Smith this is the first
one presented in such a comprehensive
Manner and with years of Grassroots work
learning from citizens around the state
as with all the other existing laws this
bill requires the person requesting made
to be in hospice care or to be
determined within six months of their
death they must be determined to be of
sound mind and be able independently to
take the prescribed medications
safeguards are in place throughout this
end of life care and the first healthc
care provider must determine eligibility
and then a second Consulting
professional must concur the person
requesting made must sign a form
acknowledging that this is their choice
and they understand the consequences of
this request and two witnesses must sign
in support the requests for made can be
rescinded by the patient at any time and
of course the patient doesn't have to
take the
medication one story that illustrates
why this bill is so needed is about a
wonderful neighbor that we had a very
independent woman in her 80s who loved
the mountains and loved to work on
clearing and maintaining Trails
throughout the mountains near her home
she had a hip replacement and then a
second surgery because the first one
wasn't successful even after the second
surgery she wasn't able to take care I
don't mean to interrupt you but you
really are you're going over your time
she wasn't able take care of herself she
deteriorated rapidly she asked her M MD
for medications to help her end her life
but of course the doctor couldn't imply
then one day we received a note which
read by the time you read this I will be
dead Beth had taken her own life because
the state did not offer a more
compassionate and peaceful way to die
this is only one example of why the bill
before you is critically important I
look forward to your deliberations and
please reach out to us for any resources
that you might need we're happy to help
thank you questions for this
witness none thank you very much uh
Stephen michau Dr Steven Mich show and
next witness after that will be Melissa
Stacy
good morning thank you for allowing me
to testify my name is Dr step Misha I'm
a family
practitioner I work in gtown New
Hampshire native New Hampshire that's
where I grew up so I have the pr
privilege of serving the town that I
grew up with kind of a Marcus Welby type
situation
so so I'd like to
one I'm concerned about have I I I truly
love New Hampshire and my choice would
be not to follow the path that our
neighboring states have followed I am
concerned I didn't see a residency
status in this bill which is concerning
to me uh one of the things that happened
in Oregon is that was
totally looked the other way and decided
that you didn't have the the original
Bill had a residency status and now
that's no longer the case
I'd also like to uh quote some myths
this is a book called to die well which
we all hope to do written by a
neurosurgeon and he quoted some specific
myths regarding physician assisted
suicide number one physician assisted
suicide is universally successful
painless and peaceful so these myths are
related to published medical literature
so for instance doing the Journal of
Medicine uh
Journal American Medical Association
British medical journal so this isn't
just myths that are taken out of the air
I would say the New England Journal of
Medicine is on the wrong side of the
coin but regardless it's a a a a fairly
renowned Journal so physician of suicide
is universally stressful painless and
peaceful significant side effects in
many patients occur requiring a
physician to then administer a lethal
dose of the medication that's been
determined myth number two patients who
die by physician assisted suicide are
properly screened to rule out any and
treat psychiatric illness in the British
Med medical journal a study one out of
three patients in Oregon met criteria
for clinical depression and should have
been excluded myth number three adequate
oversight exists to prevent assisted
suicide abuses this is a letter to the
Journal of the American Medical
Association which documented Doctor
shopping to circumvent safeguards meds
administered by someone other than the
patient myth number four and this is the
one big concern and it's addressed by
others physician assisted suicide is
available only for terminally ill
patients Netherlands Canada since 2002
have seen this not to be the case and
the definition of unbearable suffering
has been Braden leading to physician
assisted suicide in many patients with
terminal disease I'd like to read just a
small short paragraph in this book again
written by a neurosur over your you're
over your time doctor I'm sorry one
paragraph the truth of physician
assisted suicide is far from the
Tranquil picture painted by death With
Dignity Advocates whether it is a matter
of Bart suicide attempts or lack of
compliance with established safeguards
history has shown that physician
assisted suicide is problematic at
multiple levels all right questions for
this witness representative Perez thank
you thanks for taking my question um
what do you think would happen under our
current statue when a physician over
prescribes a medication and it is used
by patients with to commit suicide I
mean we have
a statute that says you can't do this
but yet we're trying to ask you to do
this so I'm not aware of the statute but
I do know that the administration of
endo life pain medications is not driven
to commit suicide is to treat symptoms
and so if you use it in that respect I
don't see where that would be a problem
maybe you have other information but
these meds can be used to treat symptoms
and if the side if if the end result
adult is death that that's not a problem
by any by follow quick I'm saying that
we're asking
Physicians who are bound by law not to
overprescribe medications first for and
we're asking a physician to give a
cocktail that will kill someone what
what's the question my question is do
you see that as a problem for
positions I guess if if they're bound
not to overprescribe then that is a
problem but based on Integrity I don't
there is some Integrity in the whole
thing and I think that makes a
difference okay other questions for this
witness saying none thank you very much
sir um Melissa Stacy and the next
witness will be uh Bob
dun
good morning morning my name is Melissa
Stacy I'm the regional advocacy manager
for compassion and choices we are the
nation's oldest and largest nonprofit
organization working to improve health
care and expand options at the end of
life I'm here to testify in support of
this
legislation if passed hb1 1283 would
allow mentally capable terminally ill
adults with a 6 months or less to live
the option to request obtain and take
medication should they they choose to
die peacefully in their sleep if their
suffering becomes
unbearable this bill includes strict
eligibility criteria and practice
requirements to ensure the highest
standard of care patients can change
their mind about utilizing the option at
any time during a multi-step process
participation is voluntary for patients
and providers it is important to note
that individuals are not eligible for
Medical Aid and dying solely because of
Advanced age disability or chronic
health condition
the data from jurisdictions that have
authorized Medical Aid and dying and
subsequently published statistical
reports demonstrate that less than 1% of
people who die annually annually in an
authorized jurisdiction will decide to
use the law in fact up to 37% of people
who request the medication may never
actually take it however awareness of
the law relieves worry about end of life
suffering individuals report
experiencing enormous relief from the
moment they obtain the prescription ion
because it alleviated their fears of
suffering additionally in all of this
time there has never been a single
substantiated case of abuse or coercion
in the
laws decisions about death belong to the
dying and good public policy enables
them to engage in open conversations
with their doctors with their loved ones
their faith and spiritual leaders about
their physical and spiritual needs at
the end of life this legislation gives
terminally ill people peace of mind to
not worry about whether or not they are
going to die a horrible death and
instead focus on the present and the
time they have left terminally ill
individuals don't have the luxury of
endless deliberations they need the
relief that this law affords them right
now thank you uh you're you're really
over your time okay thank thank you very
much thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
uh Bob Dunn and the next witness after
that will be representative uh Emily
Phillips
welcome Mr
dun thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Bob Dunn the director of
public policy for the Roman Catholic
dasis of Manchester and on behalf of
Bishop Peter labashi and Catholic
Medical Center and Catholic Charities
New Hampshire I'm here today to
respectfully register our opposition to
house Bill
1283 assisted suicide invariably is
presented as an issue of individual
autonomy but we want to respectfully ask
you to look at this bill against the
backdrop of the principle that part one
article one of the New Hampshire
Constitution says is one of the
foundation stones of our body politic
and that is the principle of the common
good and despite the good intentions of
the bill sponsors we think that the
remarkable diversity of the Coalition
that has come together to oppose this
bill speaks to the breadth of the
dangers that an assisted suicide law
would pose not just to the people who
choose to end their own lives under the
bill but also to the many other people
whose lives will be placed at risk or
will be compromised in some way if a
bill like this is passed if we dip our
toes in this water and so I hope that uh
this committee will heed all of the
flashing red warning lights that are
going off all over this room today and
that at the end you will follow the
advice that the American Red Cross gives
to people about escaping from burning
buildings never open a a door that is
warm to the
touch thank you thank you questions for
this witness seeing none thank you uh
representative uh Emily Phillips and
next will be uh Brian
Lombardo good morning committee um thank
you for hearing me and and thank you for
everyone for coming today uh I'm
representative Emily Phillips Rockingham
7 Fremont New Hampshire I am a
co-sponsor on this bill I support it for
me it's a liberty issue um it's clear
that body autonomy and medical Freedom
are very important to Granite Staters as
they are to me um we need to give people
options and we should not becoming in
between a dying patient and their right
to a medication they
choose this bill has several safeguards
cards I feel like there's a lot of um
fear surrounding this bill but if you
read the bill I think it's very well
written there is nothing in the bill to
require a physician or a pharmacist to
participate if they choose not to um
this is a self- administered procedure
so I think all of the uh safeguards like
I said were are well written and I'm
happy to take questions but I just want
to say from a liberty perspective I've
been trying to talk to a lot of people
who um are misled or or or fear-based
response to this bill on what it might
become and I want us to look at the bill
as written
today um the slippery slope concept of
what this bill may become would bring it
right back to this room again for a
legislative process so we can stop it
from becoming something else that it is
not today so please support this Bill
thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
um uh Dr Brian Lombardo and the next
witness will be
Betsy w
kman thank you representative Lynn I
appreciate the opportunity to speak um
I'm Brian Lombardo I've been a family
practitioner at Lebanon in Lebanon New
Hampshire at Dallas P day hospital for
28 years um I'm licensed to practice in
New Hampshire and Vermont and uh I've
been integrally involved in delivering
end of life care to countless patients
over my career um I'm here to share my
personal experience with the maid law in
uh Vermont and help uh people understand
how I came to support that process um uh
several years ago I had a Vermont
patient come back to me with uh telling
me that he had metastatic uh colon
cancer and he wanted me to help him uh
unfortunately it became clear that his
uh uh his disease was was quite Advanced
and he had uh really a very poor
prognosis so I started doing home visits
because he became debilitated and uh at
one point I was sitting in his uh living
room and I looked over and I saw his gun
cabinet uh off to the side and having
had three uh elderly patients uh all of
them men who had committed suicide with
guns uh all of them with serious medical
problems I very bluntly asked my patient
if he had thought about hurting himself
or killing himself and he said of course
I have and I had this pause and I I
realized all of a sudden that I was in
Vermont and there was an maid law and
maybe I had an alternative for him and I
said he I see said tell me all about it
and that was my first experience in uh
in educating myself about the Vermont
aen dying law um since then um I have uh
personally been involved with nine
patients uh in uh under the Vermont
statue two of them have been New
Hampshire residents who have come across
the uh border to to receive care um none
of these patients had any interest at
all in allowing the disease to to
control their death each was extremely
grateful to be legally allowed some
control over an otherwise otherwise
uncontrollable process in 30 years of
medical practice I have rarely seen a
group of patients so appreciative of the
care they have received families are
also appreciative of the fact that there
was a legal option to help minimize
their suffering I have been involved in
mult at the end of your time please yes
so I have been involved in multiple
multiple end of life
issues sometimes as di Dr Bernard said
at the press conference this morning
sometimes we need other tools that we
don't currently have and when there are
completely uncontrollable symptoms or
patients see an inevitable progression
to a death without
dignity they find this in my personal
experience they have found this to be an
incred
incredible form of Solace to their soul
right questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
doctor thank you next be Betsy uh
walkerman and after that the next one
will be uh Diana
Barnard thank you Mr chairman committee
I'm Betsy walkerman and I'm president of
patient choices Vermont I'm also a
lawyer uh patient choices Vermont is a
nonprofit or organization that is
dedicated to education on end of life
options and especially Medical Aid and
dying and I'm here today to help bring
Vermont's factual experience before you
as you consider this
bill I have with me testimony from uh
two State officials Lieutenant Governor
David
Zuckerman and um and Virginia Lions who
is chair of the Senate Health and
Welfare Committee in Vermont and both
were early uh supporters and sponsors of
our act 39 and I will pass those
around in the words of Vermont's
lieutenant governor act 39 stands out as
one of the most positively positive
personally impactful bills for which his
con
constituents Express a great deal of
gratitude and I think you will find the
same if you move ahead with this bill
there's not been a single report of
abuse or even suspected abuse in Vermont
and that is a fact to which our
department of health testified before
our legislature last
year when I when you look at the data um
we now have some data about the number
of New Hampshire residents who are
interested in Medical Aid and dying
because there have been more than 600
people who have looked at the Vermont um
the patient choices Vermont website
since our law was amended to allow um
people from out of state to seek medical
Aid in dying in Vermont and these people
are your constituents many of them call
our helpline they describe their
illnesses and similar stories to what
you are hearing
today in the first 10 years of our act
39 203 people used Medical Aid in dying
in Vermont that's quite a small number
it's a minuscule point 5% of all the
deaths during that same
period And yet Vermont doctors report
that the number of people who are
comforted by the option of Medical Aid
and dying far exceeds the number who
actually use it my personal experience
with this I see you about to tell me
that I'm going go over um uh confirms
that as well one final thought um I
would caution you uh very much to um
research the Canada law before you
compare what you have in front of you to
Canada Canada has a very different
constitutional Foundation behind their
law than we do in the United States and
I'd be happy to discuss this with
anybody who is researching that on the
committee all right questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you next I'm going to call on
Diana barnhard uh and the next witness
after that will be Kevin gagan and again
I'm you know I apologize I don't mean to
be rude but I really am going to have to
insist that you stick to the two minutes
because these these the this stack is
not all the people that wish to testify
and we want to have everybody have an
opportunity to be heard so uh Dr Barner
thank you thank you for uh the
opportunity to speak to you and I am
mindful that I am a guest here um I am
here to speak for the Vermont experience
I'm board certified in both family
medicine and hospice and paliative
medicine I've been practicing for 30 30
years and for the past 15 years I've
been exclusively focused my Care on
those living with serious illness I have
a copy of my written testimony which I
will pass around I really want to make
two main points the first and most
important one is that this is about
patients this is not so much about
Physicians it's not even so much about
lawmakers it's about patients who are
suffering and who fear suffering and who
want to have the option of a measure of
freedom and control when they are facing
their own death we live longer than we
used to live which is wonderful but that
means in the Final Phase of life we're
more likely to have a heavy burden and
the truth is we need many tools to
address this suffering hospice is a
wonderful tool and it's essential for
everybody who is in the terminal phase
of illness but it's not always enough I
cannot emphasize enough the deeply
personal nature of suffering and the
importance of listening to everybody and
having many tools to address their
suffering the patients that I see want
to live it's only when they must accept
that they are dying that they want to
have a little bit of freedom and a
little bit of control about how they die
most patients tell me they want three
simple things to be at home to be
surrounded by loved ones and to be
comfortable however they Define that the
truth is that that's hard to achieve in
this state and in my state of Vermont
Medical Aid and dying offers those
patients that choice the second point I
want to make is that Medical Aid and
dying laws can work and they work well
and they are not being abused we have
more than 10 years of experience in
Vermont there's close to 25 years of
experience in Oregon I encourage you to
look at the data and understand that
this is not being abused that the rights
of patients and Physicians who choose
not to participate are fully protected
Ed Under This law it's an option and it
gives a measure of control for people
who desperately need it all right thank
you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
uh Kevin gagan and the next witness
after that will be Paul
hes good
morning thank you for this opportunity
um I was compelled to come here today um
hearing about this
legislation and you know I notice a lot
of talk or hear or see you know talk
about Live Free or Die um I guess the
way I see it as a granite stor it's Live
Free or Die not live free and die um and
you know I I'd like to see New Hampshire
uh represent a culture of life not
death um I happen to have at least three
or four close people in my life that
actually committed
suicide um so I just I simply don't
believe that suicide is a
solution so in in additionally I'm
shooting off the cfia as I believe you
had suggested um I don't have a written
speech I just woke up this morning and
wrote a bunch of notes here um
interestingly my my son who's in seventh
grade is going to currently be um
learning about suicide so I you know I I
felt compelled to you know discuss this
with his uh with his counselor and you
know just talk about it and uh I just
think it's a very sensitive matter and I
just uh you know my hope is that this
committee um you know will value life
life from the beginning to the end right
and we just you know again the live for
you die I'll finish on this I don't
think it was intended for suicide to be
the die principle I think it was was
intended for Patriots to stand up and do
what they need to thank you right thank
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much sir uh former
Congressman Paul hods please and next
will be uh darra
danini Mr
H good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee thank you uh for this
opportunity I will be brief um I'm here
on behalf of uh two people uh first uh
former representative Christine ham from
Hopkinton who now lives in Portland
Oregon um she's at the end of her life
uh dealing with her own Journey with
cancer uh uh she has uh presented uh she
sent me testimony I've made 21 copies
which I'm going to leave for the
committee uh to read it's it's very
eloquent um and I'll I'll give it to you
uh second I'm here on behalf of Lucy
Carl of Hopkinton my former law partner
uh Lucy I believe has already submitted
her full testimony to the committee so
I'm just going to be very brief because
I also have my own observations her son
Alexander known as xan had a fiveyear
battle with pancreatic cancer um he died
uh shortly before Thanksgiving in
2019 uh bedbound in his final day when
he entered hospice he and his family
made the decision to obtain a
prescription under Oregon's U Oregon's
law he had three reasons one
preservation of his dignity and autonomy
as the pain became insurmountable two
control over his disease so that he was
making the decisions not the cancer and
three and most important control over
how he would die peacefully and
comfortably and ensuring his beloved
wife and his then three-year-old son
were not traumatized by his last days I
just want to point up the importance to
Lucy to the family to the friends and to
xan that the opportunity for him to make
a choice about how he would die was
absolutely critical in the end he didn't
use the prescription but the peace of
mind that it gave him and those around
him is an invaluable lesson Lucy
supports the bill Christine ham supports
the bill I support the bill this is an
important step for New Hampshire thank
you very much thank you questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much thank you Mr good to see you again
nice to see you um darra denin and next
uh after that will be Mimi
White
Darcy Marie donini Kil thank you for
having
me good morning ladies and gentlemen sir
and madams I was going to begin by
saying to whom this may concern and then
I realize that This concerns everyone
everyone in this room is going to die
and most likely everyone knows someone
who is dying or someone who has died
imagine if you were dying and you had no
control over where you are
who is going to be there zero control
imagine if you had to vomit feal matter
imagine if you were in constant pain
imagine if you had people around you who
who you did not want to be there at that
time that is not a death that I want for
me my family my friends or anyone in
this room or in our state options
options are good options are for
everyone everyone should have the option
having an option does not mean that
you're going to act on it you it need it
having the option there knowing that you
have that control knowing you could
choose who you wanted by your bedside
who you wanted with you such comfort
that can bring to you me and your loved
one I and I believe you live in New
Hampshire because we love it we cherish
it we support it and we protect it why
should one leave our home at the second
most important event in our lives if New
Hampshire could speak I believe it would
say stay relax thank you it was good to
have you we die once that is it having
the option and the control I can think
of nothing more peaceful thank you for
your time thank you for your openness
Live Free Die Free thank you sincerely
Darcy Den cill right questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
man thank you next uh Mimi white and
then uh next witness after that will be
representative Jessica
lante
you won't be able can you hear me yeah
if you could get closer to the
microphone I'm not uh
not how's
that good thank you I'll be short first
good morning almost good afternoon and
excuse my
back my name is Miriam white I live in
exor New Hampshire I'll be speaking
briefly but I have a um prepared
statement for the for the um
Representatives my husband Steve died in
19 uh
2017 and he had a good death he died at
home one of our daughters was with us a
friend of hers who happened to be a
nurse Doula was with us he was talking
and up and about the day before and and
when Sunday came around around that's
the day he decided to die hospice didn't
call it they didn't see it
coming but he died well he died
consciously he actually squeezed my
hand
and we didn't have to give him a lot of
medicine except Mor a little bit of
morphine I'm here now to say the rest of
us need
this I'm thinking of the word
opportunity what if Steve had had the
opportunity to know how long he would
live what if he had experiences that I
can't even imagine he would be looking
forward to what if my daughters our
daughters had a chance to be with him
more because they knew he was going to
die it is really critical that we treat
death with the same sacredness that we
treat
life please pass this Bell and send it
along to the to the Senate it's time to
come thank you thank you questions for
this
witness seeing none representative
lontine and the next witness will be
Fran
chering hello I'm representative Jessica
Montaine from
do and I would like to read a letter
that um Dr Robert bar wrote last fall
and it was published in um the
Portsmouth haral or the SE Coast
newspaper how long is the letter it's
brief well actually and I apologize that
there is some angry lit uh words in this
letter um I actually redacted the letter
to remove some things were that weren't
really germine to the the subject but I
I do read it with permission of his
widow he died about 2 weeks after this
letter was written all
right an open letter to our
representatives in conquer in
Washington thanks to you at end of life
we treat our pets with more respect
dignity and love than we do our own
citizens over the past 10 years we have
put down two terminally ill beautiful
loving golden
retrievers at the vet we lay down on the
floor with them and snuggled by an IV
was introduced the first injection put
them to sleep and the second stop their
hearts all within five minutes without a
twitch or a
whimper you choose to deny me the same
death With Dignity at the end of my life
you forced me to live and die by your
Theocratic beliefs which I do not share
I don't believe in Immaculate
conceptions resurrections The Walking
Dead Angels Devils zombies burning
bushes Gods Miracles Heaven or Hell or
talking
snakes with beliefs like these no wonder
you can totally deny science and doom
your grandchildren to a rapidly
unlivable Planet so at this time at the
end of my life you force your religious
Dogma down my throat ruling out my
choice of a painless death With Dignity
forcing me to choose between your
benevolent religious option of starving
myself to death over one to two weeks
how loving how
kind in a few days for your glowing
satisfaction if able I will try to give
you an inspiring uplifting update on how
things are going as I slowly die by
starvation in front of my caring wife of
64 years herself in frail health and
your unbounded compassion be thinking of
us forget your Hollow thoughts and
prayers Robert bar MD of Lee New
Hampshire and he died about 10 days
later so I just wish to convey his dying
wish that we support this
legislation all right thank you
questions for this
witness yes representative Vine how long
ago was this death it was in um November
of this of
203 thank you other questions yes
representative Oran well more of a
comment I I knew Dr bar so he has missed
and actually
probably most of us in the committee
except maybe the new members um probably
know his daughter-in-law who is uh
justice Tina NATO who is until recently
the Chief Justice of the superior court
and a frequent visitor to this uh
committee so I'm sure um I'm I'm I'm
sure she she she's heartbroken although
she seemed very cheerful the last time I
saw her so like we keep her in our
thoughts or prayers or whatever we
whatever we choose to do so thanks other
questions for this witness thank you
very much you next Fran chering and the
next witness after that will be Gary
York uh of
Hopkin good morning thank you for
hearing me my name is Fran chiking I was
born and raised here in New Hampshire
we've raised our family in the granite
state I'm here to support hb1
1283 New Hampshire end of life options
like many of you I bet I have seen
people who have died of cancer in my
case the people that I know had
pancreatic cancer they had bone cancer
they had brain cancer speak into
the there were heroic efforts to try to
save those folks and try to alleviate
all the suffering but of course as many
of you know that isn't always possible
and so as a family member you're there
you see the suffering you see the
terrible pain and you would want to take
that away from them yourself but you
can't my folks did not have the option
of an end of life choice if they had
lived in Vermont or in Maine they would
have had that option and so I'm here to
support this bill because there's one of
those three people who would have chosen
this who would have made that decision
and they weren't able to I'm here in
support of that in memory of that person
who I loved but also for the other
people in New Hampshire who want this
choice and that includes
me I've had cancer I have had
chemotherapy I've had radiation I've had
surgery I know what that experience is
like and I don't know what's going to
happen other than I know death is a
certainty will the cancer occur I don't
know if it does if I'm in a terminal
state State and I have 6 months to live
I want this option I don't know if I'd
use it I don't know if I'd be brave
enough but as representative Palmer said
just to have that as a possibility would
bring me peace right so I'm here to
support this for the people that I love
but also for myself
selfishly and I hope that you folks will
look at this bill and consider the
people have spoken and support it and
find a way to pass this and give options
for the people in New Hampshire thank
you all right thank you questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much uh Gary York and the next witness
after that will be Arman
Susi good morning chair and members of
the committee I sit here and support
strongly hb1 1283
uh Gary York retired physician from
Hopkinson New
Hampshire our medical freedoms have been
eroded over the past few years as New
Hampshire citizens this bill bolsters
our inherent right to have control of
our bodies and
ourselves this bill is a bill for a
choice for New Hampshire
citizens I'd like to address the uh
acronym made Medical Aid or medical
assistance in dying and I emphasize
dying this is a process that has started
at least by the estimation of two
Advanced Care Medical
practitioners uh there's no Insight
that's definite but there is a start
point and vetting by two uh
practitioners that this is happening uh
this is a process so this is not called
m a TD Medical Aid to die this is
a acronym that explains the process of
an active
dying uh this bill allows the
individual the ability to make the
decision of how and when they leave this
world this is a bill of
compassion and a bill of choice and a
bill of medical Freedom so if someone
were to ask me if you had 6 months to
live what would you do my answer would
be I try my hardest to help pass a bill
in New Hampshire that guaranteed our
citizens their final Freedom of Choice
all right thank you Doctor questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much oh I'm sorry you did have a
question representative D Lorenzo I'm
sorry thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I'm wondering
how um this mad program or mad issue um
blends with your hypocritic oath thank
you my hypocritic oath uh the one phrase
that comes back to most people do no
harm the summary of hypocritic oath in
my
opinion and if you allow people to
suffer you're doing
harm simply
put any any other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you Arman Susi
and the next witness will be
Kevin Kevin Grady I
think Kevin Grady
from
Hit yes Mr I am Arman Susi I am the
chaplain for the state veterans advisory
committee which represents almost all
the veterans organizations in the state
I'm also chaplain for the state Disabled
American
Veterans and for acting chaplain for the
Catholic War veterans all these
organizations strongly oppose this why
they said it's not a veterans issue we
tell that to my nephew who after three
years of Iraq couldn't take it anymore
and end it his life suicide is a
oneperson thing assisted suicide is
technically murder if there was someone
standing on that ledge across the way at
a capital building who was ter really
ill and was going to die in a month and
I pushed him did I assist in his suicide
or did I murder him that's the question
suicide is very simple it is just me it
is my decision all of us have that
choice I can go home and down a bunch of
pills right now and I'll be dead by
tonight I can do it myself we do not the
state does not have to assist us we
suicide does not need help tell that to
my nephew tell that to my granddaughter
who died of a drug overdose suicide is
assisted is murder and to correct
something it was stated respectfully
from uh representative Smith that our
constitution said there's a separation
of church and state and it's not in the
Constitution it's not in the Bill of
Rights but it is in letters from Thomas
and Jefferson and yet we still say one
nation under God and our money still
says in God we
trust
people take it from a man who thousands
of years ago was in pain more than we
can ever understand and it was going to
be dead before the end of the
day and he said the day will come when
Mountains will want men will want
mountains to fall upon them and Hills to
cover them and if they can do that when
the wood is dry what are they going to
do with is green another when the red is
green what it's going to do with it is
dry if we can do this now if we can
start killing allowing people to kill
themselves I just dealt with a veteran
up in conquer dying suc of cancer stage
four pump full of morphine and yet still
was making plans to get his family
together to find a church here to to get
he wasn't planning on dying he was
suffering he was maxed out on
morphine but to say that we have a right
we have a the authority to help people
die that is very questionable the doctor
mentioned four if the first dose don't P
that the patient themselves pushed
that's suicide but if that first dose
doesn't work the doctor has to apply a
deadly solution at that point it is no
longer suicide the doctor commits murder
all right thank you very much questions
for this witness thank you very much sir
Kevin Grady I hope I I hope I got that
right and next will be Mark
Kaplan
thank you good morning Mr chairman
ladies and gentleman of the committee
for the record my name is Kevin Grady
I'm a 25- year Air Force veteran and I'm
a a 25 year resident of the town of
hookit New Hampshire I did speak to you
guys a couple weeks ago so you know um
what the state veterans advisory
committee is all about uh we had our our
meeting last night for about 30 minutes
and discussed this and there was a
rather animated discussion on it and I
want to tell you that this bill scares
our members right down to their
socks we've spent the better part of the
last decade trying to get our arms
around the fact that while veterans are
a relatively small portion of our
population we have a really really
outsized number when it comes to
suicides against the regular uh people
who are not veterans and our concern is
not with this bill as written we
understand the folks that put this in
have good intentions we understand that
this is a bipartisan Bill uh but our
concern is that places where this has
been uh in in the country uh you tend to
ultimately once it's been in place for a
little while get something that we would
call Mission creep and while it right
now it's a fairly narrow portion of the
population that qualifies for this our
concern is that mental health concerns
and other things may weigh into this at
some point and this pool could get
expanded so our are folks opposed this
bill uh and that's all I wanted to tell
you sir all right thank you questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you um Mark Kaplan and next will
be Ken
Norton good morning Mr chairman and
committee members thank you for hearing
my testimony
I'm here to advocate for passage of HB
1283 I'm Jewish and have a traditional
Jewish upbringing as an adult I spent
many years involved with my Jewish
Community Helping start a synagogue and
uh working on the Jewish Community
Center and Jewish
Federation I bring a Jewish influence to
my views of this option my Jewish
parents were also strong supporters of
end of life option going back decades
unfortunately my father who died a year
and a half ago did not have an option
for Medical Aid and dying instead he
chose to voluntarily stop eating and
drinking to bring an end to his
suffering it's not a great way to go he
was 93 and a half on the day he died by
that day he was sedated in
unconsciousness and we were unable to
have the kind of goodbyes that we would
have liked I'm here today because he
would want me to be here he was a great
role model for taking a stand and making
the effort to make make a difference for
others nothing can change how he ended
his life but we can change things for
others passage of this bill would
relieve suffering and provide Comfort to
those who qualify and wish to have
options at the end of their lives as a
Jew I believe this is an example of what
is called tun olum repairing and
improving the
world now that I've provided my Jewish
perspective I com feel compelled to say
that in enacting this bill should not be
should be about humanity and relieving
suffering not religion in fact it is
important to point out that despite the
vocalized opposition of some organized
religious institutions the granite state
survey conducted by UNH makes clear that
more than 60% of people identifying as
Jews Protestants and Catholics support
this support Medical Aid in dying I urge
you to listen to your constituents More
than 70% support Medical Aid in dying
only 177% are opposed I urge you to vote
this out of committee with strong
bipartisan support thank you thank you
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you uh Ken Norton and next will be
uh
margarite
Matthews
good morning chairman Lynn and honorable
committee members my name is Kenneth
Norton I'm from Tilton and I'm speaking
in strong support of House Bill uh 1283
I'm a social worker in the state I'm the
former executive director of Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness and for over 40 years I
focus my career on mental health and
suicide prevention including serving as
a subject matter expert for the
Department of Defense the Veterans
Administration and the federal Substance
Abuse and Mental Health Services
Administration and that presented in New
Hampshire nationally and internationally
on this topic and I'd like to First say
personally that my father was not
afforded the peaceful death he prayed
for and he begged to end his suffering
and at the end of his life I want to
focus my testimony on the difference
between suicide and Medical Aid and
dying first legally the death
certificate lists the cause of death is
the underlying terminal not
suicide with suicide people no longer
wish to live for whatever the reason
with Medical Aid and dying people
desperately want to live but have a
terminal illness that may cause intense
suffering and pain with suicide there's
a high correlation with mental illness
the person may or may not be rational or
even competent um in that moment and
they see no other option than death with
Medical Aid and dying they are assessed
by two medical professionals determined
to be mentally capable to have a
terminal illness they're informed of
available options and they give informed
consent suicide is often impulsive
although the person may have thought
about it for quite some time Research
indicates that it's often only minutes
before they decide to act on it with
Medical Aid and dying there's a
mandatory waiting period people who uh
choose suicide die alone and suicide
tends to be a violent death in New
Hampshire 75% of suicides involve a
firearm or hanging most happen at home
in their personal residence and that
causes trauma for the family friends and
loved ones who are the first ones on the
scene to find that their loved one has
died it may contribute to PTSD for First
Responders and it results in complicated
grief shock guilt anger and regret by
contrast Medical Aid and dying people
die surrounded by family and friends
it's a peace peaceful death in their own
home and they have often informed and
involved family and Friends there's a
reason people over your over your time
there's a reason people don't list
suicide as a cause of death and
obituaries because of Shame stigma and
blame directed at families after a
suicide whether you oppose Medical Aid
in dying or support it let's stop
contributing to that stigma and stop
calling Medical Aid and dying suicide
thank you thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you uh
Margaret Matthews and next will be uh
milin M
MCN
sandwich hello my name is Margaret
Matthews I live in Durham New Hampshire
and um I am here to support the passage
of the New Hampshire end of life options
act house bill number
283 I um have for the past 47 years
toured throughout our state doing
performances at libraries historical
societies at uh senior citizens centers
at residences for seniors I do work that
is all based on our history and our
culture here in New Hampshire and in New
England I have been uh appointed as a a
New Hampshire artist laurate for two
terms and I also in 2013 was awarded Ed
the l jacobe living treasure
award I'm about a year ago I received a
uh a diagnosis of a serious health issue
and uh I am devoting some of the
precious time I have left to support the
passage of this
bill I would like to be able to know
that this will be available for me at
the time to secure a painfree and
non-traumatic end of life experience
here in my home surrounded by friends
and
family a peaceful and passing surrounded
by our loved ones is an option that all
of us
deserve thank you thank you questions
for this witness saying none thank you
um uh milin mcnell or mcnell I hope I
got that right and the next witness
after that will be uh
Katherine nunlist nest from
Lebanon thank you thank you I sit here
alone to
die I eat a delicious meal and cannot
taste it I answer the phone it is a hoax
grandma I'm in
jail I cannot walk to the mailbox to get
my mail I cannot renew my license to
drive because of my
vision my children my family my loved
ones cannot legally be with me if I make
my choice unless you act to provide this
basic right I have lived a full life I'm
ready to take my
journey each of us must have the right
right to make our own individual choices
and not have them governed by strangers
when it comes to plan planning and
preparing for this journey this next
Journey our laws must allow us to make
these choices for
ourselves please each one of you will be
in this place someday to make your
choice it is a reality it is a truth it
is one of the absolutes in
life each one of you has the unique
opportunity of giving us this
right Thank you thank you questions for
this
witness yes representative Perez thank
you thanks for taking my question I
think I'm misunderstanding your
testimony it sounds to me like um you
are talking about getting old I have a
birthday coming up that's going to
bother me
not a terminal illness you're just
talking about you're older you can't do
this because of your vision and this and
that this bill doesn't does not address
that is that what you were talking
about death is a terminal illness
absolutely and each of us has many many
things that deteriorate our bodies
absolutely and all of those are now
affecting me with many issues that I
don't want want to medically go into but
it is a terminal
thing and to have you give us this
right is a basic right that we all
should have so that we can go and have
those
choices and not have to take care of it
ourselves yeah follow up so are you
advocating that our bill this bill
include
my being able to take you have assisted
medical uh suicide just because I'm old
and I can't see well no I'm not what I'm
doing is saying there are multiple
multiple reasons and and the time is
short the time is short okay and the be
to be able to be with my
family and have these choices if you
pass pass this right then we will have
those choices we don't know thank you
other questions thank you very much
ma'am uh Katherine N nunlist I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly and next will
be
uh
maranne Jackson I believe
MD uh from
Madison Mr chairman and members of the
Judiciary Committee thank you for this
opportunity to speak in favor of HB 1283
if I get it
right my name is Katherine nunlist you
did a great job I got it right all right
um often called Cappy I'm from Lebanon
and I am here in support of this bill
I'm completely dishing dissing my um
test plan testimony to say the the
following first a one of the Physicians
who testified um very well I thought was
asked um what does do not harm mean and
he said allowing people to suffer I am
very sure that he and my own physician
husband meant not permitting not
permitting patients to end their life
when they're suffering it's not the
doctor's decision it's the
patients second there's been an
assumption that suicide is evil a bad
thing a of course it often is extremely
tragic but it can also bring
peace suicide for some is a sin it is
not a sin for me and for many others sin
is a religious concept and under our
constitution people's religious beliefs
should not be a part of your
consideration another Point um several
people in opposition have talked about
the restrictions that are being lifted
in Canada and in the Netherlands and
perhaps in other places those are not in
this bill and as somebody mentioned they
will come back to this group or its
representative at that time if these are
needed but I would like to point out
that those restrictions are not evils
perpetuated by politicians or evil
people those restrictions are being
lifted because
individuals want them need them in order
to end their suffering it is not in this
bill I greatly admire the people who
have put this bill forward and and put
their thoughts into it but restrictions
being
removed are is happening because that's
what people are demanding all right
questions I think you're really over
your time ma'am I'm I had one final can
I just say one final it's quick just
it's quick all right
um uh let's see pain first of all
painfree is not enough and I that's what
the the testimony before it is what it
was painfree is not enough it means loss
of dignity and all sorts of things
people in opposition are wrong if they
say that all our ills can be alleviated
in other ways they can't be all right
thank you very much questions for this
witness saying none thank you um Maryann
uh Jackson and next will be
Jay
blowitz of
Lebanon Aran Jackson
all
right no I don't all right Miss Jackson
I guess is not here Jay uh blond dotz
and the next uh witness after that will
be Adam liser
ler I'm sorry it was Joy blond was I
didn't mean to I'm sorry
that's okay I figured it out yeah so
yeah my name is Joy blong ofic I live in
Lebanon um I am here to offer my
testimony and support of House Bill
1283 I have never testified like this
before but I decided that this bill was
so important that I needed to summon the
courage to do this
today my brother Chuck died from cancer
in May of 2022 he lived in in Colorado
which is one of the states where um
Medical Aid and dying is legal the day
after he was diagnosed with his cancer
he started a Blog to share his
experience with his friends and family
and I'm going to read what he wrote that
first
Day quote at some point in time this
cancer will overwhelm and kill me that's
just the way it is however in between
then and the Here and Now is a big
unknown with respect to the quality of
my life I've not been given any hint
from these doctors as to what this may
be like so I'm glad that Colorado has a
death With Dignity law I may never Avail
myself of it but there is a certain kind
of reassurance in knowing that it is
there because this option was available
for my brother during the year and a
little bit more that he had cancer he
had the Peace of Mind knowing that he
did have this option and that peace of
mind was also with his family and this
was a decision that he made that we all
fully supported
to be clear my brother did not want to
die he was diagnosed with cancer when he
was 68 he had been living a full life
and he still was and in that year that
he had cancer he continued to live a
full life as best he
could he took chemo chemotherapy
treatments trying to extend his life as
long as he could and that helped him for
a year at that point in time they were
no longer effective so he stopped taking
the chemotherapy treatments and then the
cancer grew rapidly and his pain
intensified at that point he enrolled in
hospice hospice was wonderful and was
able to provide medications that helped
to diminish his pain but it was never
eliminated and his pain increased as his
cancer
grew ultimately he was not able to use
uh Medical Aid and dying because he was
not able to find the required second
doctor that would support the first
doctor
decision all right um you're really over
your time oh man okay all right well
thank you for listening to me thank
thank you for coming as questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much uh Adam uh leiser and the uh next
witness after that will be uh Danielle
pimel hey good morning I got you by two
minutes I I said good afternoon uh
thanks for having me here today I am in
favor of this bill there's a couple
things I want to talk about and I'll do
it quickly um I've heard the people who
are against this bill say things like
quote their concern is not as the bill
is written well if you're not concerned
as the bill is written then we shouldn't
be
here my concern is it's a slippery slope
well if it's a slippery slope we worry
about that if the bill were to change
not as the bill is written we heard
someone say I I the natural progression
of the law is blah blah blah I think
that's not relevant like look I'm 48
years old my wife was diagnosed with
cancer at 36 with a newborn a
one-year-old and a 5-year-old she passed
away in at the age of 42 with a
5-year-old a 7-year-old and an
11-year-old she did not want to die and
leave us okay this was a 5 foot6 135 lb
woman who died at
lb okay think about what that was for me
and the kids as she sat in the maramman
house for 10 days asking the doctors why
they couldn't help her speed this along
with a feeding tube that had been in her
stomach for the prior three months she
couldn't eat she couldn't drink there
was zero chance of her surviving none
and she had to sit there begging the
doctors to make it go quicker and people
behind me are sitting here saying that
because the dollar bill says God on it
we shouldn't do this that's ridiculous I
I'll go to that meeting and say take God
off the dollar bill if that's where
we're at the reality is nobody should
die the way my wife died at
pounds all right thank you very much
question representative Divine sorry to
ask this but when how long ago did this
happen she passed away on March 30th
2019 thank you for your testimony other
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much sir
uh Danielle pimel and the next witness
will be Clarence
Gardner good morning my name is Danielle
pimel policy council at Americans United
for life and today I urge your
opposition of this bill the answer and
solution to people's hopelessness their
despair is not assisted suicide
physician assisted suicide is not
Healthcare and what it does it actually
strips vulnerable persons of authentic
Choice near the end of their lives
physician assisted suicide promotes
ableism it creates a two-tiered system
whereby those who are young and vital
are given the message of Suicide
Prevention but if someone has a serious
illness or a disability they're told
they should simply end their lives
therefore physici assistant suicide uh
lethally judges patients quality of life
based upon their disability or serious
illness which is discriminatory this
bill also under cut strong um are strong
policies of Suicide Prevention studies
show that when a State legalizes
physician assisted suicide the rates of
nonassisted suicide also increase that
means the rates of suicide are
increasing in the general
population um HB well 1283 would also
authorize the use of experimental drugs
on patients so these are drugs that have
not been FDA approved these are drugs
that are compound um drugs these are
drugs that have had no oversight no
clinical government approved trial
and the uh the bill does not require
patients to be informed of this so again
this raises serious in um informed
consent issues for patients um
ultimately today the legislature has the
opportunity to reject a bill that is
discriminatory to stand with those who
have disabilities to stand with those
who have serious illnesses and to seek
opportunities to promote legislation
that actually ensures that individuals
near the end of their life are treated
with dignity and are given proper Health
Care thank you so much for your time and
I will take any questions you have I
also submit written testimony thank you
thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank
you y no that's fine we'll take
absolutely we'll take it thank you thank
you very much uh Clarence Gardner and
the next witness after that will be
Bill Anton uh from North Conway I think
I've got that right hello Clarence
Gardner from we New Hampshire um I'll
submit my written testimony I won't read
any of it um I think everything here
today comes down to Choice we've heard
that word many times from various
Witnesses um I forgot to say I'm here in
in support of the bill um in fact a a
previous witness who was a doctor said
he didn't want his choices limited he
was talking about what the government
allowed him to do but it's not his
choice it's the patient's Choice uh
that's who we don't want to limit the
choices of um the whole purpose of a
legislative body is to choose for people
hopefully in New Hampshire we try to
keep that to a minimum and in fact the
the previous uh witness used the word
discrimination all legislation is
discrimination in some way
um so yeah that
um one example I have in my my testimon
is that we all hear stories sometimes
about
somebody diving into a raging River to
save a kid we all applaud him he's
heroic it's honorable sometimes he dies
sometimes he doesn't but everybody
agrees with his choice in that respect
but when it comes to the person's choice
about his own life no can't do that
that's our business we'll decide whether
you live or die in fact one editorial I
saw that was against the bill
actually in so many words said well if
you're suffering you just need to man up
I I would deal with it you have to deal
with it
um that's what I that's all I had and I
willon point out that uh somebody
mentioned Live Free or Die we always
forget about the second half of that
death is not the worst thing that can
happen to us sometimes it's the best
thank you thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
uh bill
Anton hope I've got that right and next
will be uh Joanne Tim house from North
Conway good morning um my name is Bill
Orton and I live in North
Conway
uh I've been a um hospice volunteer for
about 12 years probably more I'm I've
been an EMT in New Hampshire licens for
40 years I've been involved in Mountain
Rescue for probably 50 or 60 years and
I'm not going to tell you how old I am
however I've seen death in many forms
nasty things and quiet things but of all
the people that I have seen die from
accidents from
illnesses people that have got terminal
illnesses in in hospice none of them had
a
choice I would like to let everybody
that's in New Hampshire I would like to
see this this bill passed so they have a
choice all right just would like to um
speak of the importance of this bill in
looking after our community members who
have been given a terminal diagnosis
with no way out it will be interesting
to know how many of us
have spent time weeks months or so with
a hospital P with a hospice patient
someone who has nothing to look forward
to accept many months of lying in a bed
or sitting in a chair unable to go for a
walk maybe not even able to go to the
bathroom on their own in most cases
these people just want to have a
peaceful ending to a life that has been
well lived I find it very sad that if
these good people wish to end their Liv
lives peacefully and in their own time
they cannot do so in our great state
family members could drive them to
Vermont or other states that have end of
life options but that just doesn't seem
like a fair or a kind or a compassionate
option to give these good people from
New Hampshire all right I think you're
kind of at your end of your time sir six
seconds therefore I implore you to
support this bill which will enable
terminally ill patients in our state to
choose to end their lives peacefully and
comfortably when they are ready thank
you thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
Janine Tim house uh Jean Tim house and
then next will be Rod
Sims and to members of the committee um
as you there's as you know there's no
requirement for a quorum at uh at these
hearings so if people are starting to
get hungry I would suggest that we do it
in kind of you know not everybody go at
once but if somebody wants to take a
break to get some lunch that's fine yes
please go ahead so I just have to say
the last witness took longer because of
his British accent that's why he's my
husband um my name is Jean twe house um
also from North conw and former hospice
nurse um have been very disappointed and
sad in the past when this bill was voted
down um couldn't really understand why
um until one day it occurred to me that
people just were not seeing what I was
seeing people hear about dying assisted
dying people don't in most cases don't
see death over and over and over again
like I did they don't see people who who
yes they have their meds yes they have
their um symptom kit um they are still
in intractable pain they are incontinent
they are laying in their own feces and
urine until a loved one can come clean
them up this goes on for weeks and
months it is not a hospice can take care
of it hospice cannot do
everything we can do a lot but we can't
do everything and just to say let
hospice let health care take care of it
no that doesn't work I have been in so
many homes for so many months and people
were asking me how much morphine do I
need to take I'm sorry I can't tell you
that um I've seen mothers ask my son
can't keep going through this how much
morph do I need to give him if you've
never seen that I recommend that you do
what Bill did become a hospice volunteer
sit with patients sit with their
families for hours on end for many days
of the week for weeks and months and
then tell me how you can say this is not
a good thing that we all deserve right
thank you questions for this witness
saying none thank you uh Rod Sims and
the next witness will be Kristen
Baker good afternoon Representatives my
name is Rod SIM from Belmont uh I do not
uh I oppose this bill because in all the
countries uh and States this has started
out as there's been uh numerous
questions that a lot of people became
euthanized rather than committed suicide
and it's I listened to um Davos the
things that was spoken of there that
they're saying there's too many people
in the world um I've listened to um
insurance companies who's wanting to
have a a quicker cheaper remedy and I'm
afraid that if if this is passed that
euthanasia will become more uh common
than suicide because insurance companies
want to spend less money to take care of
us and there's a lot of people in this
world that thinks there's too many of us
so I've seen a huge change uh since co
uh I've been personally threatened in
the hospital um because of my my
personal beliefs and uh I do not feel
secure in having a bill like this pass
because I think it will morph into
euthanasia my wife sits behind me she's
a disabled veteran and I'm very
concerned that someday I could take her
into the hospital for a checkup and two
doctors go into the room come back out
and said you can take your wife home and
go and find out that they've euthanized
her all right questions thank you very
much questions for this
witness seeing none thank you sir
Kristen Baker and the next witness after
that will be J uh the Reverend James
Baker thank you Mr chair and uh members
of Representatives
uh for your time this morning my name is
Kristen Baker and I have a masters of
divinity in chaplaincy and served as an
endof life caregiver for over 5 years
often working closely with hospice I was
able to see the important impact
holistic care provides for those facing
death I'm addressing you this morning to
oppose the bill
1283 there's a psychological and
emotional response to a terminal
diagnosis that often includ includes
ways of shock apathy and despair that it
can impair their ability to make vital
decisions especially a decision with
such fatal consequences how however if
the individual is able to work through
that crisis they are able to use their
remaining time addressing endof life
tasks that often prove to be incredibly
meaning meaningful for the individual
and their loved ones when my mother was
diagnosed with terminal cancer she
endured ways of emotional turmoil that
Her diagnosis in
inspired by fighting through those ways
of depression fear and pain she was able
to use her remaining time accomplishing
tasks and goals that added to her
lasting Legacy more important to me and
those who knew her time spent with her
during her final M months was a
Priceless gift one my children my
husband and I will cherish so my serious
concern with this bill is that patients
will make an emotional decision In The
Heat Of Crisis and pain that will steal
from them and their loved ones the
possibilities that remaining moments and
days or even weeks might hold thank you
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much thank you uh
Reverend James Baker and next will be
Dennis
Pratt
thank you chair and members of the
committee my name is James Kimo Baker I
am the ordained pastor at the Bridge
Community Church in Milford New
Hampshire and I am also the vice
president of the American Baptist
Churches of Vermont New Hampshire I'm
here in opposition of this bill um
although I am not
a terminal I do have several chronic
illnesses which are at the bottom of my
written testimony
at age 12 in the early 90s I was
diagnosed with my first chronic
illness by the time I was 20 years old
um the disease had taken over so much of
of of who I was that I was questioning
life and at that time there wasn't much
U medicine that was available to me the
doctors were at that time even hinting
to um it would be better if I would be
be
dead a year later I met the love of my
life who Christian whom you just heard
and together we've had two
children and it's only because of the
hope that I was able to have in the
midst of fighting these
illnesses that I choose I chose to
continue to live and move forward you
see I believe that hope makes a
difference and when you have been told
that you've been given 3 to six months
to live that your body immediately
starts to react based off of the hope
that you have or do not have I watched
my mother-in-law be given 3 to six
months to live and yet defied those odds
and lived another 11
years because she had hope because she
had faith and I truly do believe that
one of the things that we need to
concentrate the most on in this in this
bill is really the mental health side of
it that if we can provide the support
that's needed to these patients who have
terminal illnesses that that will make
the most of the difference providing
hope for them to continue to fight to
allow their loved ones to be able to see
them live the full
life that somebody else may have had
planned for them all right thank you
very much questions for this witness
seeing none thank you Dennis Pratt and
next will be Douglas
Reed hello I'm Dennis Pratt I'm from
Dover um so two minutes uh let's let's
think about this about 20 years from now
we've uh in New Hampshire we've removed
all the victimless crimes but only if
you're almost dead so if you're almost
dead you can smoke a joint you can have
a full flow shower if you want um and
you can pick up some medicine that might
that that you could actually hold back
and you might want to injust if your
death becomes torturous if it becomes
too painful and you can instead die
easily in your sleep without pain in the
arms of your family but somebody doesn't
like this bill so they they they they
they they they introduce a new bill they
introduce a bill that says we should
take away this right of the almost dying
Granite Stater and they bring in
hundreds of people who say I don't like
this option this is a terrible option
and the Judiciary Committee listens to
this and they say well you know you
don't actually have to take the option
it's just an
option and so a bunch of healthcare
workers come in and say our healthc care
is just so fantastic nobody needs
another alternative to this we have no
need for
it no one well almost no one very few
people die with devastating pain
and of course the wise Judiciary
Committee says well you know I'm I'm I'm
very glad that that you're proud of this
great service that you
provide but you know we actually want to
support here consumer choice we want
some sort of competition allow people to
make their own own
decisions and finally one person says
well hey look when people are dying
they're
dumb they are in pain they can't think
well they're too emotional
I can think better than they can think
and I'm deciding that they ought to die
not as they choose but they should die
um uh uh through starvation or
dehydration or whatever it is you're
kind of over your time sir so I can ask
ask you to sum up please sure
um so I'm hoping that this Judiciary
Committee will today hold off on that
future and allow us to say let say we
want to give granted Staters the right
to live free and to Die free as free men
thank you questions for this witness
seeing none thank you Douglas Reed and
next will be uh Karen
lean good afternoon
everyone my name is Doug Reed I'm here
in supportive end of life options act I
was born and raised in New Hampshire and
currently live in
Raymond my motivation today for speaking
today is like everyone else in this room
I'm going to die someday death is a
topic very few of us want to think about
or discuss especially when associated
with our own
mortality disregard your personal
beliefs on the morality of Medical Aid
and dying for a moment and think about
what your idea of a dignified death
means to you if you were diagnosed with
a terminal illness
some would argue hospice exist to
fulfill the wishes of a dying person so
why do we need Medical Aid in dying yes
hospice provides an amazing service DET
terminally ill people however the dying
process may not necessarily be quick
painless or symptom
free when the disease in controlling
your body and mind when you've lost
pleasure in the things you once loved
when you're in pain when you're
suffering and you fear burdening those
around you there's nothing more to do
but wait for death having the power to
take or or not take life-ending drugs
can be a supreme Comfort to so many
people we've heard that a lot tonight
today
um and it's time for New Hampshire to
provide a painful uh sorry peaceful
painfree life-ending option for
terminally ill patients I know that's
something I'd like to have available to
me whether I use it or not is another
question but um I I would love to have
that option just to give myself peace of
mind and we've heard that a lot today um
from many people
good thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you you Karen
lean and next will be
uh
Patricia Al alang RN from Portsmouth and
if I've tortured that name I
apologize good afternoon thank you for
this opportunity my name is Karen lean I
live in the town of Hillsboro I support
this bill my father ended his life 3
months ago using a program similar to
the one being proposed here in New
Hampshire um he was diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer in 2018 he was given a
year to 18 months he lived for 5 years
he did not choose this option too early
he might have chosen it too late however
he was able to choose it and no one
forced him into it he was offered all
the health care that he needed did until
he decided he was
done my sister and I were able to read
eulogies to our eulogies to him before
he passed he was uh aware and he got to
express his
gratitude and it was peaceful he died
with a smile on his face um he was so
brave I watched him die I held his hand
it took a lot of Courage for him to do
that I'm not sure if I could make that
choice myself but I want that choice for
myself and for the other people in New
Hampshire I call it a complicated
blessing in a way um it's not easy um
but Health Care includes death care and
I think this is an important part of
that we use a lot of technology to keep
people alive for much longer than
perhaps nature intended and I think this
technology is just one tool in the
toolbox as others have said thank you
very much thank you questions for this
witness yes representative Perez thank
you thanks for taking my question your
father was diagnosed in 2018 that's
correct was he
given a life expectancy at that time I
think with pancreatic cancer they very
often do people often go quickly with
pancreatic cancer he was given a year to
18 months and he really defied the odds
so if he had chosen this option at six
months he would have
lost five years with you
all I think that from what I've observed
and you know he he only chose this
option four and a half years after he
was diagnosed I understand that but had
it been around and he chose it when he
was diagnosed he would have lost those
years with you all I I understand your
question I think that there's an
assumption that when someone receives a
prognosis okay often doctors do will
give prognosis and they're very
uncomfortable giving prognoses because
it's really unknown how long a person
will live so it really is up to the
patient and I think that in my father's
case he waited until he really couldn't
anymore and then he had that option
thank
you other questions for this witness
thank you very
much uh uh Patricia
alang alang I'm sorry all right and the
next witness will be Peter
Hogan
thank you Mr chair and committee members
my name is Patricia aland yeah can I
just ask you get a a little closer to
the microphone thank you thank youa Alid
and I'm here today to speak um solely as
a nurse based on my 45 year practice um
and of clinical practice 30 years of
which have been in the operating room
and 15 years in
oncology um pain management and and
integrative
care I am a strong um Advocate and
supporter of this bill
1283 I feel that it clearly
defines um very specific qualifications
of eligibility for someone to um have
this option and it also speaks to
um
the AL of speaking of really identifying
us as citizens of New Hampshire as
individuals and having a right to choose
I mean you've heard many stories today
of people's experiences I have many
myself but as a nurse as a nurse really
a symbol is of
compassion strong uh protector of a
patient's privacy dignity and
autonomy and to deliver compassion of
care which we do I um it's very
gut-wrenching in many situations and and
it does seem
inhumane I think that the passing of
this
legislation would provide options as it
was eloquently stated earlier just to
know the option is there is a comfort
whether you choose to Avail yourself of
that and also um it's a very
Humane dignified choice for a patient to
suffer for not to have to suffer so I
strongly support the passing of that
thank you questions for this witness
seeing none Peter Hogan uh and next will
be Claire uh
McManaman thank you honorable chairman
and members of the community for letting
me
speak House Bill 1283 seeks to make
life-ending medication available to
adults with a terminal
illness if this bill is made into law
New Hampshire will be taking its first
steps towards normalizing
suicide this normalization of suicide
would be crippling for teens in New
Hampshire in New Hampshire alone a
quarter of Youth have considered
attempting suicide 19% of Youth have
even made suicide plans and almost 10%
have attempted suicide at least
once if teams with depression and
Suicidal Thoughts start seeing family
members and friends or relatives of
friends committing suicide with the use
of these pills and they see that this is
being morally accepted by the people
around them they will see no issue with
attempting suicide or or in encouraging
friends to attempt suicide this bill
will start to deteriorate deteriorate
the moral compass of Youth and adults
alike in New Hampshire I have friends
who if this Bill had already been put
into law would not be here friends who
have
seen friends who would have seen the use
of this medical suicide as something
acceptable and would not have seen any
difference if they just ended their
suffering by killing
themselves I ask you to oppose this bill
in order to uphold the Dignity of human
life and to help preserve the moral
conscience of the people of of our great
state thank you questions for this
witness representative Perez may I ask
you your age I am 17 years old turning
18 in March thank you thank you other
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much next I'd like to
call on uh Claire McManaman and the next
witness will be the
Reverend uh
Andrew Nelson okay all right thank
you
um good morning and thank you honorable
chairman and committee members my name
is Claire McManaman and today I am here
to oppose hb1
1283 I'd like to begin by saying that
this bill is designed to give a person
who is suffering the option to end their
own life in order to end their suffering
by the administration of a lethal
substance one of the main issues at hand
which has caused the proposed bill is
the problem of patients who are in
severe pain without access to pain
relief through either hospice or palea
care this is a real problem and the
solution to this problem should be to
improve the hospice and palea of care
industry and its
accessibility or other Alternatives but
not to legalize physician assisted
suicide because to legalize this would
bring more problems and
solutions the truth is that every human
being is incredibly capable of finding
meaning in life therefore every life is
worth living even at the hardest times
our health care System should embody
this statement by striving to save lives
ensure an honorable death when it
naturally occurs and embrace hope even
in the most difficult
cases I would like to explain a couple
issues PA s brings to New
Hampshire first it promotes a lie which
forsakes the idea that life is
inherently valuable and all people can
find happiness and it reduces a person's
life to
hopelessness death by Pas would not be
death With Dignity but it would be more
so a life with no more meaning put to an
end however no human life is meaningless
you're you're at the end of your time so
can I ask you to sum up please yes
therefore no life should be put to an
end uh I would just like to say
that our health care System should
strive for Hope
and people who are dying and sick and in
loss of pain want to be lifted up by
their Health Care system not told that
they should just end it all right thank
you questions for this
Witness seeing none thank you thank
you no no no no
sorry um next Reverend Andrew Nelson and
the next witness will be uh Melinda
Sims thank you Mr chairman my name is
Father Andrew Nelson I'm from
summersworth and I'm speaking here as a
citizen today uh I'm not going to make
the argument on a religious or moral
ground because I don't think we need
that I can make it on a rational ground
and I'm here to speak against this bill
I've personally attended at the bedside
of thousands of deaths chaplain at eight
hospitals including the number one
Hospital in the world and chaplain and
and attended the the bedsides at some of
the most complicated cases there as well
there's many cases that have been made
here today many have talked about my
state of birth Vermont where uh this is
legal but we haven't talked about our
neighbor directly to the north Quebec if
you look at the statistics coming out of
Quebec between 7 8% of all deaths are
physician assisted that is current the
most recent um information from the top
top doctor on the end of Life Commission
in Quebec is Raising major Flags because
number one they're finding a disregard
to the law by medical professionals in
Quebec to our North 100 miles to our
North they're finding that the the
regulations being set are being largely
ignored some will argue that this cannot
happen here that that cultural
shift and pressure that comes with
youthanasia will not happen here but to
to all who are gathered here I would say
if you asked me 10 years ago if I
thought our country could shift so much
to a place where Republicans and
Democrats and people of all sides of all
issues were so divided that violence
could happen in the streets I would say
that is impossible yet it is something
we have seen if you ask me when I was in
high school if I could have imagined a
future when kids would be afraid for
their own safety in schools I would say
that cultural shift could never happen
yet we've watched it and if you look
seriously at Quebec at Canada at Belgium
at Oregon you look at places where this
has been legalized that shift happens
every suicide that I've ever attended to
was chosen by the person who did it but
I can say every person that ended their
life with suicide felt pressure inside
and out
this is not the answer accompanyment is
providing the resources to families who
are struggling
is you cannot underestimate the pressure
that happens to people in these
circumstances I have sat at bedsides
with people who believe in God who
people who do not believe in God the
number one worry people say is not their
pain and well that is real the number
one worry people have is for their
families and those they leave behind
kind don't tell anyone here that that
pressure financially or worrying that
they're over biring their relatives
doesn't way into the conversation just
look at the one of the top reasons that
people in Oregon have cited for
euthanasia is the burden they are to
their families pressure is real
everyone's saying choice but I would beg
you to consider the pressure that this
legalization will bring and the societal
shift that will happen I am horrified at
the societal shifts left and right that
have happened in our country in the last
20 years it can happen we've watched it
happen in 10 other places that I suspect
not most of us here would have never
dreamed could have happened whether it
be schools and safety whether it be
politics and violence in streets and
places like this please don't think that
those shifts don't happen they do
questions for this
witness
sorry
yes representative Perez thank you I
apologize if in the doorway eating okay
I missed where you were from sir and who
you s I'm from summersworth so Father
Andrew Nelson thank you thank you thank
you other questions for this wit no
seeing none thank you um Melinda Sims
please
chairman and members of the committee
thank you for uh having allowing me to
speak today uh my name is Melinda Sims
and I'm the chapter Advocate coordinator
for United spinal Association New
Hampshire chapter and the United States
Air Force veteran I have uh a c 4
through 7 uh in um a C4 through 7
incomplete
quadriplegic and I know chronic pain
every day
um I talked to you today about I oppose
HB
1283 um because I believe that this uh
bill
will Prey Upon High people highly
susceptible to
Suicide um the VA the white house and
New Hampshire have made Suicide
Prevention a
priority but this is going to um create
double standards to
that this um the Danish Council of
Ethics they did an extensive study on
the Oregon and Dutch models of assisted
suicide and they say no members could
find the Oregon or Dutch model
sufficiently clear in their delineations
to be fair and their justification
ations for Access sounding terms or
control
mechanisms this this bill lacks
safeguards it's full of euphemisms
ambiguous and obscure language it makes
it easy for insurance companies to take
the easy way out our veterans and
disabled Community don't need youth in
Asia as their first solution to their
problem instead let's give access to
robust Mental Health Services rehab
programs and compassionate Health Care
Systems let's provide comprehensive care
that respects the dignity and worth of
every person in a manner consistent with
the dignity they deserve all right thank
you questions representative Perez thank
you thanks for taking my question so you
live in chronic pain absolutely are you
limited on the um amount of pain
medication you are allowed I choose not
to take opioids I try to go towards uh
more natural route okay so this bill
would not help you because you do not
have a terminal illness correct well
actually um it is terminal because uh I
have a degenerative spine and unstable
spine so they told me to enjoy each and
every day because any moment I could be
dead okay but just quick followup yep
but the way this bill is written it's my
understanding that you would not be
eligible for this under this bill is
that correct well yeah how you see they
say terminal yeah yeah okay thank you
you wel other questions seeing none
thank you very much next is George
uh
oh CR Cramer from do I if I've apologize
if I've screwed up the name and the next
witness after that will
be okay all right next w will be Beverly
cotton yes
sir good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee thank you for the time
and the opportunity to speak to you
today and I am speaking to you in
opposition of House Bill
1283 my name is George kramlinger and I
am a resident of Dober New Hampshire I
oppose House Bill 1283 from my
perspective as a 26-year active duty
military veteran in and after 15 year
years in the fire service in the course
of my service I have experienced the
after effects of suicide on family and
friends firsthand military personnel and
firefighters facing ever increasing
levels of stress from high-intensity
operations and the ever increasing
levels of cumulative exposure to
trauma which can create an increased
level of psychological
fragility in addition the ever
increasing stress anxiety and pressure
within our society create psychological
fragility and a higher incidence of
Behavioral emergencies among people who
might not otherwise be vulnerable this
increased vulnerability is particularly
prevalent among teens and those in their
Middle Ages leading to an increased
incident of suicide and suicidal
ideations those Among Us who fall into
hopelessness and contemplate suicide are
often brought back from the brink by a
caring voice on the other end of a phone
a family member or friend friend who
reaches out or a voice from the depth of
their intellect reminding them that our
society is based on a tremendous respect
for life and a desire to live legalizing
suicide in any form including physician
assist a suicide for any reason even if
well-intentioned will have the
unintended consequence of increasing the
acceptance of suicide in a subtle but
dangerous way within our culture thereby
lowering the threshold for many to
commit suicide
who might otherwise be helped back from
the brink all right you're over your
time sir so can I just ask you to sum up
please quickly our societal Norms are
under assault from many directions I
urge you to help us hold the line and
help maintain a society where life is
valued including the lives of those who
sacrifice for our freedom and our safety
unlike what is happening in other
countries I really need you to sum up
Sir our culture needs a strong hand to
pull a suicidal person back from the
brink instead of creating a culture that
recognizes and encourages suicide thank
you for your time thank you questions
for this witness being none next Bev
cotton and then
uh uh
Betsy uh
McConnell oh that's okay all right uh so
Bev cotton Bev cotton here
think she had to leave okay I don't see
a about cotton all right then Pat
Uh have I have Bev cotton from where
where have
cotton
so sorry is Bev cotton
here all right I don't see all right
next Pat Uh wilinski of
conquered and the next
person
okay I'm sorry which one I'm sorry who
yes Pat wichinsky okay of con cotton
here all
right okay thank you all
right oh Betsy McConnell
okay okay all right so that's fine go
ahead please his name was Ed
wilinski he was over six feet tall
strong a high school football player
saxophone player and offset cameraman
for the Lawrence Eagle Tribune he was
the father of six kids at age 47 my dad
was diagnosed with ALS commonly known as
L garg's disease it was about as
devastating a diagnosis as someone like
him could get a fatal motor neuron
disease characterized by a progressive
degeneration of nerve cells in the
spinal cord and the Brain it leaves
leads to Total inability of ability
total loss of ability to function and
affect speech and ability to swallow as
well Dad was not a re world-renowned
physicist like Steven Hawking who also
had ALS and who could carry on a full
intellectual Life Giving lectures and
writing books despite his illness dad
worked with his hands in between working
full-time plus any overtime he could get
he built a house from the ground up for
all of us to live in if our Jeep broke
down he rolled himself under it and
stayed there until he figured out how to
fix it this disease was torture for him
yes
torture dad couldn't bear what was
happening to him and how it affected mom
and the rest of us at one point he fell
down a flight of stairs
visiting him in the hospital he said to
me next time I'll be sure to put a
bullseye on my head when I asked my
brother Mike if he thought that Dad was
trying to kill himself by throwing
himself down the stairs he nodded and
told me that Dad had asked him to roll
him into the garage and start the car
and leave him there close to the
exhaust at that time my dad's only
option was to enure the Daily torture or
try to kill himself in these inhumane
and ultimately ineffective ways didn't
he and everyone else in his position
deserve better more Humane options like
those we offer our beloved
pets how can it be that someone with a
terminal illness is left to suffer so
horrifically I fervently urge you to
support House Bill
1283 because it gives options to people
whose suffering is simply
unbearable no solution we can come up
with here is perfect but we must have
the courage to do the best we can in
order to support our loved ones at their
Journey's End and this is not part of my
written testimony but I've heard a lot
today about concerns about suicide and I
am a newly
retired psychotherapist after 50 years
practicing and I have had my share of
family members crying in my office
because their loved one took them took
their lives life and I just think it's
really important that we separate those
two issues this really has nothing to do
with that we need this bill we need
better mental health care and support
for families and people struggling with
mental illness and we need better
paliative care train positions but we
need this Bill thank you very much
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you um I
should just I just want to uh note for
for people that are here we're as you
know we have or as you may know we have
other hearing schedule beginning at one
o'clock so what I'm going to do is at
one o'clock I'm going to recess the
hearing on this on this bill
1283 and open the hearing on the other
ones that we have hearings scheduled
until 3:15
at 3 3:15 the last hearing on another
bill when that hearing
concludes which I believe that bill at
least will be relatively short uh we
will then resume the hearing on this
bill um so you the at 1:00 those of you
who are here on
1283 uh you're going to have some time
uh before we resume the hearing on this
bill it'll probably be at least 3:30 uh
maybe more like uh 4 o'clock all right
uh thank you but next uh next witness
um Betsy McConnell I'm not sure miss
mccon did you say you were the one that
said you wanted to have somebody else
testify all right sure come on
up I am Reverend Mary James from Durham
an ordained minister in the United
Church of Christ and I've served in
Parish Hospital and hospice settings
it's been my privilege to walk with so
many dear folks through their end of
life Journeys and I thank you all for
hanging in here through this long
hearing on this important issue thank
you chairman Lynn and fellow committee
members I want to speak personally today
my beloved husband Bob James died in
2022 of
cancer he went through four group ruling
years of very difficult treatment his
surgeon said that he was heroic his
oncologist said that he endured
more life-altering treatments surgeries
infections side effects than almost
anyone he had ever worked with he wanted
to live finally it was time and Bob
enrolled in hospice we had wonderful
hospice care it was
fabulous however in hospice Bob had
unbearable breakthrough pain his
tracheostomy tube constantly clogged
threatening to choke him and he had
bouts of losing Consciousness falling
down without a moment's notice and
losing all control of his bodily
functions it was only at that point that
he desired Medical Aid in dying and as
his suffering increase knowing this was
not there for him he thought a lot about
overdosing on his Hospital this
medications in the end he decided not to
he was afraid it wouldn't work and he'd
end up worse off or that his family
would somehow suffer legal repercussions
a couple weeks before he died he wrote
in his journal about his desire for a
peaceful death and if only that could
have happened when he died he woke up in
the middle of the night bleeding from
his
tracheostomy a forceful stream of Blood
and Tissue issue ensued that we could
not stop all I could do was hold him and
tell him how loved he was my sweet
husband simultaneously bled to death and
drowned in his own blood because he
could not have the Medical Aid in dying
that he
desired in his situation as a wife this
breaks my heart again and again as a
minister I do not believe for one moment
that this death death or his disease
were the will of God God is found in
comfort and accompaniment not in
afflicting
trauma I've heard so many terminally ill
people beg for help in their last days
and weeks for relief from their
suffering as they face their inevitable
deaths thank you for hearing this
testimony I'm very emotional and I hope
it was coherent and I appreciate your
time so very much I have also the
testimony of a colleague who has Co and
couldn't be here today thank you very
much uh questions for this witness
seeing none uh Forest Bodwin
please
Forest thank
you I don't have topic I just have one
written Tas amount
sorry uh dear chairman Lynn and members
of the
committee I
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
you
today my name is Forest bwin
Frey I live in
coner I am
strongly in opposition
to House Bill
1283 and ask you to oppose this
bill my family taught me that wrong
thinking Le the wrong
actions assistance
suicide is a wrong idea it will lead to
wrong
actions
it already leads to wrong actions where
assisted suicide is
legal Oregon's law started out just like
the language in this
bill all states have loosened their
original
legislation history is the best teacher
so new haser will be no different in
loosening their safeg guards and limits
too now in Oregon the data is that
medical
professionals government officials and
assisted suicide proponents see no
problem in assisting the suicide of
people
those of
whose to reasons we wanting to commit
suicide or they feel that they are a
burden on
others or feel a loss of
autonomy or loss of
dignity these reasons are the exact
stigmas wrongly attached to life with a
disability I am here to tell you people
with
disabilities are not burdens we F hard
for dignity and autonomy and a
society that sees us and treat us by
children who deserve charity not with
did
and
autonomy disability is not a fate worse
than
death all other National
disability
organizations oppos assist suicide laws
among them are adapt the National
Council on develop the national Castle
on Independent Living the national spal
cord injury
Association of the disability right
education and defense fund The Arc of
the United States the American
Association of people with
disabilities and National Castle or
disability most
importantly as a young man let me remind
you suicide is the second leading cause
of death for people my age in New
Hampshire why are we fighting so hard to
stop the
epidemic of suicide in one hearing room
but saying in as and other that assisted
suicide will be
okay what kind of a message is that do
as I say not as I do please do not
support this ableist bill please oppose
House Bill
1283 I will take questions thank you
thank you sir questions for this
witness thank you very much seeing no
questions um at this point I am going to
uh uh recess the hearing on House Bill
1283 and the committee will take a brief
recess of about 10 minutes or so before
we uh open the hearing
on yeah we
will we will I'm sorry we will we're
going to recess the hearing on this bill
we will reconvene this hearing at 3:45
today um and at one o'clock I will open
the hearing on House Bill
10:20 yeah if anybody I realize this is
maybe an inconvenience for many people
um if you have written
testimony if you have written testimony
that you want to submit and you that you
can't hang around please do that um
otherwise we'll see you at 3:45 thank
you
all right um I'm going to call the uh
Judiciary Committee back into uh session
and uh we're going to turn to uh House
Bill
1020 and I'm going to recognize
representative Mark Pearson the prime
sponsor uh to testify representative
Pearson
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record I am Mark
Pearson Rockingham County District 34
the towns of Hamstead Kingston and East
Kingston I am chairman of Children and
Family Law Committee of the special
committee on the Family Division of the
circuit court and of the DHHS oversight
committee I was ordained in the
Episcopal Church in
1974 yes 50 years ago no comments
and simultaneously for two and a half
decades I have worked part-time as the
CEO of a whole person welness Center in
Kingston which employs two primary care
doctors and a nurse
practitioner two licensed Master's
degreed
counselors thus the issue of mental
health is something I have lived with
professionally all my adult life and I
hope out of compassion it is something
very important to me last September
attorney Holly Stevens of Nami and last
November Attorney eron krian General
counsil New Hampshire GLE Branch emailed
me about the importance of a bill they
wanted to be filed they and others such
as attorney Stevens can testify about
the technical specifics here but let me
just say something we all know mental
health issues are of course of import
importance and increased importance we
watch and lament a major increase in
suicides we watch and abhor the increase
in violent acts sometimes with mass
Carnage as the bill says in its
Preamble current New Hampshire statutes
for insanity and competency have not
evolved with changing Trends in the
frequency of those types of orders or
the improvements in mental health
treatment there's work to be done other
states have started we can learn from
them if this bill were to pass we would
not be establishing a commission that
would go on forever an interim report is
due this November with a final report a
year later the group will meet do its
work and then it will
sunset second in the bill before you
there is a large number number of people
to be appointed an amendment that will
be forthcoming will reduce that number
to something much more manageable and
the work that will be done will be a
little bit more narrowly focused than
what you see before
you the commission this bill seeks to
establish brings together stakeholder
groups in mental and Behavioral
Health Psychiatry medicine Justice law
enforcement the prison system and so on
we need
this and following the lead of other
states this commission can do good work
for the people of New Hampshire thank
you Mr
chairman questions for this
witness um yes representative Smith
please um thank you um giving me the
opportunity to speak to to my second
favorite
chairman um well tied for first perhaps
um chairman Pearson I couldn't agree
more with the purpose of
this
bill
however it is now
February this bill will work its way
through even if we act very quickly
through here across to the
Senate assume that the Senate moves with
it assume that the governor signs it
without uh a delay that happens very
very
frequently it will likely not be before
September that uh if we're lucky that
even a reduced commission is AA
established could I ask you why you
think you have to have all of those
participants
specified in
legislation rather than expecting that
the
importance of a legislative
request would be enough for all of those
organizations that want in fact to that
have a vested interest in this to come
and meet with a group of legislators to
come up with the best possible
plan well
representative from personal experience
every time you make a suggestion to me
to change something a I take it to heart
and B almost every time I wind up doing
it so why not and I would suggest that
the specifics of how and who be left to
um attorney Stevens and a few others
that perhaps an amendment could do
exactly that I'm quite open to it I just
want a commission to get going look at
the topic and make recommendations how
we can figure that out together thank
you very much other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very oh
I'm sorry yeah
thank you for taking my question um
representative Pearson I don't know if
you went to this um in-house um house
continuing education on study committees
and commissions but there's a lot of
information here um and there's sort of
like a um a cookbook
on what sort of um action you want to
take and it breaks down to do you want
to do a study commission do you want to
do um a standing committee subcommittee
uh retain subcommittee interim study ad
hoc subcommittee chapter study so there
are alternatives you know and with this
being the second year of a banum it
might be good to look at one of the
alternatives to answer your question
representative yes I did look at all of
that and I was asked to submit this bill
uh because they seem to think that might
be good for the bill so again I'm quite
happy to turn it over to the people
people who encouraged me to file the
bill to see if the same or better result
could occur from this or a very
different way of doing it oh thank you
and I I just want to say this isn't a
criticism I actually made the mistake of
um getting a a chaptered study
commission together and um after a while
I found out that I didn't really need it
that there were other methods to you
know take care of this I've made that
mistake too maybe I'm making it again
but I think they're going to bring an
amendment okay well thank you so much
thank you other questions yes
representative Stapleton thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question on page one uh line 22 I've
just caught this uh the current
statutory definition of insanity in New
Hampshire originating in 1871 is
outdated and not in keeping with today's
standards of the dignity afforded to
people with mental
illness uh instead of a commission could
there at least be a starting point with
a bill to redefine in better terms of
understanding uh insanity and and use
that as a starting point for further
bills and action thank you for your
question representative I think that um
1871 itself tells us we need to update
but the group of people enumerated in
the bill to be reduced by the amendment
is the group that would come up with
that definition
thank
you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much pear next I'm G to call on Holly
Stevens
please
good afternoon chairman ly members of
the committee my name is Holly Stevens
I'm the director of public policy at
Nami New Hampshire the National Alliance
on Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is
a nonprofit Grassroots organization
whose mission is to improve the lives of
all people impacted by mental illness
and suicide through support education
and advocacy on on behalf of Nami New
Hamshire I'm here today to speak in
support of House Bill 1020 as you heard
from representative Pearson uh Nami New
Hampshire was one of the uh
organizations that did request that he
file this bill um I'm uh saw him at a
training on the courts and mental health
over the summer um and during that um
training they did talk about competency
and the lack of the process that we have
in our state um we do lack any formal
restoration process or system to provide
treatment to individuals who are found
not competent to stand trial for these
individuals the mental health court
system isn't even an option because
those programs require consent which a
person deemed incompetent cannot
give they also require an understanding
of the criminal and judicial process
which a person who is deemed incompetent
does not have nationwide about 81% of
individuals found not competent to stand
trial have their competency restored and
are able to return to court um in New
Hampshire in 2019 only
44% of individuals found not competent
stand trial were restored and able to
actually um go back to court um if
people are not restored in a year those
charges are dropped and the court
process does not go forward which means
you've got a person who is not getting
treatment the treatment that they need
um because we don't have a process to
restore them but you also have somebody
who is potentially the victim of a crime
who does not receive um any kind of
closure
because their trial does not go
forward um and it's been our experience
um working with families of loved ones
who are found not compid to see in trial
that their loved ones see this as a
missed opportunity for them to receive
treatment because we do not have a
restoration process in this state and I
know that there were a lot of different
questions about whether this should be a
commission a committee how it could be
done um one of the reasons that we
looked at doing a commission is because
right now um the governor's Commission
on mental health and Injustice involved
individuals and I might have that um
commission wrong um but uh attorney gry
from the Attorney General's office is
here to answer any questions if you have
any of him um this is a there's a
subcommittee that's been working on
competency for a couple of years now and
there's a lot of expertise that's gone
into this there's a lot of work that's
already been done many of the members
that are named to this commission are
members that have been working on this
for two years and would bring their
expertise and their knowledge with them
um so rather than just coming in and
testifying on a half an hour of what
they know they would be sitting at the
table with all of their knowledge that
they've been that they have gained over
the last couple of years um so that's
one of the reasons that we thought that
this commission would be better suited
than a committee uh myself and our
executive director Susan Sterns met with
um speaker Packard um prior to the
session about this bill he asked us to
do a couple of things he asked us to
reduce the amount of work that the
commission would be doing and we looked
at it and determined that the Insanity
part of it could probably be done
somewhere else or could probably be done
at a different time the competency
portion of it is extremely important
especially with the forensic Hospital
opening um the uh New Hampshire hospital
I've been in touch with um Dr Jeffrey
feder who also feels that this is a very
important um that this work get done
before the forensic Hospital opens
um uh which is why it's important for
this commission to go forward the other
thing that um speaker Packard asked us
to do is look at the commission the
breadth of the commission and and reduce
the number of folks so I have um worked
with representative Pearson on a
potential amendment that would reduce
the number of folks on the commission
the other thing that I did was reached
out to most of them and asked them one
did they have an interest in serving and
two if they did would they attend in
person um because it's come to my
attention that these commissions get uh
formed and then nobody shows up and no
work can get done because there's not a
quorum so that was one of the things
that I asked was are you are you willing
to serve and are you willing to serve in
person anybody who was not willing to
serve in person and the folks that did
not get back to me I marked off and um
that that amendment can come forward for
your consideration if you have an
interest in it um I'll end my testimony
with that and I'll take any questions
but Nami no Hamshire is in support of
this Bill yes representative
Smith thank you you've been before us
and have done excellent work and and
bring a good perspective to this
committee and I appreciate it very much
but I think we might have done a
disservice um to you uh perhaps in some
of our hearings
um if in fact you were feeling rushed or
whatever I am not
suggesting that this be handled in a
hearing what I'm suggesting is that an
appropriate committee and it probably is
not this Comm it may be this committee
it may be uh children and family it may
be a combination of both but that it be
a legislative committee and that
we would convene or it would convene um
in effect in a work session where
sitting at the table would be members of
the legislative committee and those
people willing to come and
participate to take their place
literally at the table to share their
views and to help us come up with
something all of which can happen
immediately without having to wait for
disperate organizations to make
appointments for the governor's office
to make an appointment for whomever else
and not be able to have a committee
really function until the fall so
because I think the issue is very
important and I think we ought to do
something I wonder if you would consider
the possibility of completely changing
this in order to ask that it be studied
by the legis the a legislative committee
either created specially
or um a statutory legislative committee
um to do the work that could happen
almost
immediately I would not be opposed to
that um I do think that a
commission
um mainly because of the fact that it
would be hard to get notice out to it's
easier to get notice out to commission
members that are on an email list to say
you need to be some this place at this
time um and bring that knowledge
together but I am not we're certainly
not opposed to doing this as a committee
and having people come in and and
testify and work with the uh the
committee to get the work done well
thank you I'm I want to be very careful
not to debate this with you you know
because what I want to know is hear from
you because I look at you as the expert
thank you other questions for this
witness I guess I have a question to to
follow up on what representative Smith
said I'm I'm I
guess I I I agree with her proposal but
I guess I might wonder if we if it if we
shouldn't go a bit further and that and
that is this as you may know there was a
um there was apparently a
similar commission Bill uh presented in
2022 I guess and it passed the Senate
but was voted itl in the house and two
there were two criticisms if I
understand correctly which resulted in
the itl one was that the this as
representative Smith pointed out this
the the commission that was proposed
back then was to be you know 20 members
or 25 members and I think the the the
house sort of felt why do we have to
have a commission of that size but the
second thing and this is the one I want
to focus on is the the the flavor of the
report back in 2022 seemed to
be the look The the people that have the
expertise in this are kind of out there
there are people like you and people
from the Attorney General's office and
maybe the courts and whatever
um why are we sort of starting this
commission why doesn't it make sense
for those of you who sort of are the
experts to get together and give us a
proposal give us a proposed Bill saying
we should change the you know we should
change the definition of insanity like
in this way and we should change the
definition of of or the procedures for
restoring sanity in restoring competency
in this way and we would then consider
them I'm I'm just I'm just wondering if
that wouldn't be a more efficient way to
get what you want to get accomplished
done more quickly now it's obviously
it's too late to introduce new bill this
year but um you know
the we could certainly do it next year
and if we had all that work done in
advance um I'm I'm just you know
wondering what your reaction would be to
proceeding in that fashion well the as I
mentioned the governor's commission
subcommittee has been doing a lot of
this work and and um I think attorney
gry could answer questions about the
work that they have done um I'm not a
member of the committee Susan Stern sits
on it for our
organization um
and I think the thought is that we
really need buyin from legislators which
is why we need them involved and sitting
around the table discussing these ideas
as well rather than just being handed a
proposal and saying can you go forward
with this um it really is important for
us to have these discussions with the
legislature um as well as behind closed
doors with just the stakeholders all
right other questions for this witness
yes representative gson thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your testimony
when is the forensic Hospital supposed
to either break ground and then
eventually open they've already broken
ground on it and I believe it's supposed
to open next
summer other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you uh Jim B uh bom bombers
back Jim bombers back if I pronounce
that correctly of course enough all
right good
thanks good
afternoon uh chairman Lyn commit members
thank you very much for taking my time
or taking the time today to talk to me
uh my name is Jim bomersbach I am a
licensed psychologist here in New
Hampshire I am currently the chair of
the legislative committee for the New
Hampshire Psychological Association
which is the uh affiliate of the
American Psychological Association here
in New Hampshire we represent
professional psychologists uh in the
state of New Hampshire um I'm also want
to say at the front I'm a forensic
psychologist I work at the State Office
of the forensic examiner which conducts
competency evaluations which conducts uh
uh evaluations for Insanity I want to be
clear here though I am here today not
advocating in my role as a professional
forensic psychologist uh as part of that
office I not here representing that
office or Department of Corrections I
here today on behalf of the
psychologists of my organization and of
the State of New Hampshire uh I will be
happy to answer questions as much as I
can uh with my knowledge and position
but I'm not here representing their
interest uh I'm uh here to say that the
New Hampshire Psychological Association
is in favor of House Bill
1020 um I have been listening to the
commentary from this committee and I
very much appreciate the thoughtful and
insightful nature of that commentary I
defer to the experience of this
Committee in understanding how best to
get this work done my real Point here is
to Advocate that this work needs to be
done uh that the issues of Competency
I've been working uh doing competency
evaluations uh for eight and a half
almost nine years now and this needed to
get done when I first got here when I
first got here it needed to get done 10
years before that and it still needs to
get done today uh the work here is
urgent and I think part of the reason
why I see that this bill is still
forward and why I'm I'm advocating for
it and my organization is advocating for
it is because this bill will have
realterm con consequences in terms of
how competency gets handled in the state
and how competency gets handled in the
state will have real-term consequences
for the thousands of individuals who U
are put through the judicial system and
who have mental health difficulties um
specifically I I I also want to say I
appreciate the the comment so far on
this what I originally came here to
advocate for was to add a name to the
list and I realized given what you guys
have said that that list me to get
paired down the reason why I'm here
advocating for adding one more name to
this list is that the work in competency
and in Insanity these evaluations are
largely conducted by psychologists in
New Hampshire and so when I look at this
list I see uh half a dozen attorneys I
see administrators I see legislators I
see one potential psychiatrist and no
psychologists and so to me having
somebody in the room for my profession
that's why I'm here advocating today is
to make sure that there are um Mental
Health Providers and specifically a
psychologist in the room for these
discussions um I agree with uh attorney
Stevens that it's important for there to
be a lot of dialogue between legislative
members and Professionals in this
because uh these issues are difficult to
understand there are a lot of confusions
I can tell you that right now if you
look at the statutes for competency
which RSA 171 and RSA 171a I can point
to you that as long as I've been here
there has been competing language in the
statutes where one statute says that the
state has a burden and the other statute
says that the defense has a burden and I
have listened to judges listen listen to
attorneys going back and forth about how
these things should handle and those
kinds of mistakes happen because there
isn't this overall dialogue where all of
the parties are in the room and so from
my point of view that is the perspective
of why a commission would be helpful in
this case because it gets legislators in
the room with the professionals who know
about this information who have the
solutions for this are not complicated
or
not um difficult to understand they are
simply the solutions that exist
that require everybody to be in the room
at the same time and understand the
stakes and understand uh what needs to
happen uh with that said again I'm fully
in favor of however you guys in your
wisdom decide to have this process done
I'll be in favor of it but my goal is
one make sure that there is a
psychologist preferably a forensic
psychologist in the room when these
things are being discussed and to that
those discussions happen and that there
is real change because we do need real
change in our competency and Insanity uh
statute for this time I will thank you
very much for your time and I'm happy to
answer
questions questions for this
witness oh yes represent Lorenzo one
quick one sure thank you uh thank you
for taking my question so you were left
off the list as a um forensic
psychologist do you think that was just
an oversight or do you think that
conditions have changed like over the
years to show that we really need a
forensic um site person thank you uh I I
I would attribute to oversight again I
found that um you know I work with uh
Folks at New Hampshire hospital I work
with Folks at corrections I work with uh
um uh folks in the
Judiciary it's often difficult to
understand the specifics of how this
process occurs and and who's involved uh
so I didn't I just assumed it was an
oversight thank you other questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
you um Aaron
KGAN
hi hello again Representatives I hope
you're all doing well uh just appearing
uh very briefly um from the judicial
branch to say that I think that uh
chairman Pearson gives us far too much
credit on on his excellent work that he
was doing with nami uh but it is a
particular passion project for this
chief justice and for those of us that
are in leadership positions in the
judicial branch to modernize our
approach to mental health um the the
form the participation the the scope of
what's covered uh we would only offer
that we are happy to be active and
involved participants um in the limited
role that the court has in this area
there are many others to hear from uh
but I wanted to express our our interest
always in being Partners in modernizing
the Court's approach to mental health
regrettably the Chief Justice could not
be here today but uh he did want me to
convey that sentiment
great question yes representative gson
thank you for your testimony given that
this is not a new issue evidently it's
been around for at least nine years
according to the previous uh person that
testified what has been the greatest
obstacle to getting this done to this
point that here we are again with
another bill another
opportunity what what's been the
greatest obstacle up to this point
that's a great question and I I'm afraid
I don't know the answer to it I think
that some of the challenges in terms of
the Court's application are receiving
directive from the legislature on on
what if anything you think should be
done differently in the competency area
we do have restorability hearings but
there is room for more clarity uh
instruction in terms of clinical
approach I'm I'm sure that there are
constantly more information that's being
learned about the best way to handle
these issues and to to ensure that the
legislation is always reflecting those
changes in science and medicine I think
it's a challenge um the courts implement
the laws that are written um so if the
legislature wants to give us uh more
updated Direction more specific
direction we're always happy to receive
that representative BR thank you in
followup to that it seems like that
whatever gets done needs to be able to
adapt with time if definitions we have
to be careful not changing them on a
whim but to be able to uh make sure that
the legislation can withstand some time
and allow some flexibility in time time
or whatever is necessary so that it
doesn't become stale the moment it
passes
so is there a is there a way
of accomplishing that through this
commission is is I I don't see where
that is uh a a part of this an objective
of this commission or an objective of
this legislation is to have a bill that
does perpetuate in through time so I I I
guess guess it's more of a statement
than a a question but um is there any
way that can actually be done legally or
uh whatever I not sure how to formulate
that in a question so I'll just punt for
the rest of it Alex for $500 it's a it's
a great question in some areas of law
that's I think that's achieved very well
and in others particularly ones dealing
with science and technology that can be
a tremendous challenge that it does have
to be updated with more specific
definitions as more is
learned other
questions yes representative Smith Mr
chair it's up to you and I I don't have
a question for the judicial branch this
time but I wonder if it would be all
right if I if with you if Miss Stevens
could come back so that I could ask her
a question oh of course yes of course
absolutely thank you any any other
questions for this witness before I
excuse great thank you very much and
miss Stevens could you come back
thank you the you know the wheels grind
slowly but they grind fine slowly is my
brain I I knew I've been here done that
and I thought I remembered but I did
need to confer with the chair to help my
memory so in
2022 um when
a similar bill was before this committee
um the majority everybody agrees about
the need that's no question but the
majority of the committee does not
believe that a commission with over 20
members is necessary to accomplish these
tasks um first insanity and standards of
Competency are two very different
subjects the expertise needed to
accomplish these studies is already
available in the state agencies which
address them
the majority of the committee does not
see the need for the commission when
what may be needed is a
departmental
proposal tell me what has changed in the
two years since then so that here we are
back
again not having collected
$200 um on the Monopoly board but we're
back
nonetheless at the same place has that
group that had been meeting or not as
the case may be not made any progress in
the two years since the legislature
asked the experts to solve the
problem I know that the subcommittee
looking at competency has been meeting
regularly um and again
I defer to attorney gry um around the
work that's been done but there has been
drafts of of bills that have been
floated around
um but again um with the work that has
been done and there's been a lot of work
that has been done which is why the
decision to make this commission be the
first report done in November and then
the the final report done um a year from
November that the commission could get
the work done in that time because of
the leg work that has been done thus far
by the subcommittee of the governor's
Commission of Mental Health and Justice
thank you very much
any other questions seeing none thank
you then uh I don't yeah I don't have
another pink card but I have a feeling
there's somebody else that wants to
testify so is there somebody else that
wants to be heard on uh House Bill
1020 yes please come on up did did you I
take it you didn't fill out a pink card
I I didn't Mr chair and good afternoon
members um I'm Assistant Attorney
General Mike Grandy I'm I'm happy to
answer question questions our office
isn't taking a position on this but I am
happy to speak to so the the first thing
we need to do is have you before you
leave please fill out a pin card okay
we'll do so you know I guess I do have a
qu really to follow up on on
representative Smith's question I you
know I'm not I'm not opposed
particularly with with in the way
representative Smith suggested of a
smaller legislative committee I'm not at
all opposed to that but I'm just
wondering if that really even that is
the most efficient way wouldn't it
make more sense for for example the
Attorney General's office to just to
draft you know proposed bills saying
here's what and I understand it might
this might be this is what the Attorney
General's office think should happen now
Nami and maybe the defense bar and all
those other people may have you know may
be ready to pick at that and say no it's
got you got to change this you got to
change that but my my thinking is that
it would be
better to have a document even if it's
going to be changed because it can be
you know it'll be criticized and could
be changed
then for this committee to sort of you
know be formed and start from scratch
and everybody will be sitting around
saying one you know well we should do
this and we should do this and we should
do
this it just having been on these kind
of commissions for a long time I uh I'm
concerned that it'll take a lot longer
to get to the point we want to get to
than if we did it just by having your
office submit a draft that can be you
know
changed um thank you Mr chair I'm not
I'm not sure that's the sort of thing
that our office would necessarily do but
I I will just sort of speak to some of
the work that has happened on on the
subcommittee that's been mentioned um so
the governor's advisory Commission on uh
mental illness in the correction system
formed a subcommittee um to study uh
competency regime in New Hampshire and
potential uh updates or changes to it
I'm the Attorney General's office
designate on the governor's advisory
commission and I chair the subcommittee
um so in the last couple
years um since the last similar bill um
that subcommittee has been meeting uh
mostly regularly um and has generated a
lot of different concepts that are still
internal to the subcommittee in the
sense that they haven't been presented
to the governor's advisory commission um
it has included some draft legislative
language um
and the subcommittee uh within the last
several months took a vote to support
the uh this bill or or or a proposal by
Nami to put forward a bill of this
nature um because some of the
intricacies uh that exist really
necessitated having something that that
um would be formal uh formally formed by
this body and have kind of the you know
the formal imprint to get all of the
necessary stakeholders to truly get
together and hash out the final details
and that that work is difficult um for
or has been difficult for the
subcommittee to to run down so I would
put it this way a lot of progress has
been made from the perspective of the
subcommittee there are some issues that
that the subcommittee feels
necessitate uh formal meetings with
final stakeholders um that can't or
haven't been able to have been hashed
out at the subcommittee meeting so far
and it from from the perspective of the
subcommittee I think it it wouldn't be
starting from scratch there is it would
be starting much closer to the finish
line but but really just needing to
finalize
aspects okay all right other other
questions for this witness and I'm and I
you know I'm sorry I know I I started
off really by asking you a question if
there's other things I didn't want to in
any way preclude your testimony if
there's more things you want to tell us
please please do I'm I'm happy just to
answer uh questions that anybody has
okay all right um I don't see any other
thank you very much thank you Mr anyone
else that wishes to testify on House
Bill
1020 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that uh bill out of oh yeah
thank
you and give me one
second I think I think it's a little we
early I think we are oh no we're not
we're not
early
all right um so I'm uh now going to open
the hearing on House Bill
1082 um relative to professional limited
liability company assistant
manager uh status let me find the bill
first
right and uh representative
tur first first I want to congratulate
you on given the hearings we've had
today this is a short
bill I
Endeavor um and hopefully it's short for
a good reason thank you chairman Lynn
thank you members of the committee for
the record um I'm Eric representative
Eric tur representing um Rockingham 6
Brentwood um I'm here today to introduce
House Bill
1082 um uh which I will say I I I say
with always with trepidation which I
think is a simple change to the law um
uh I it was prompted uh by a constituent
in my town who is here and will follow
me with the testimony and can fill in
the specifics about the impact of the
law the way it is today um it what it is
is a technical fix to the uh
professional limited liability
corporation uh law that exists today um
just to clarify professional limited
liability corporations are
organizations uh where the members must
be licensed in the profession to which
the uh limited liability Corporation um
uh operates uh all managers of the
organiz gation directors of the
organization must be under current
license in order to serve um
so excuse me so the um I just wanted to
clarify this really doesn't impact lure
or anything to do with lure uh the
licensure is only a requirement to serve
uh as a director a member of the of the
corporation itself um and the the reason
that this uh uh change is
proposed is primarily due to solo
practice um organizations which um are
you know increasingly few but still
exist and are still very much of a a
valued part of the um the landscape of
of New Hampshire um the uh the
difficulty with being a solo practice
and I should say there's a whole range
of professional practices that are
covered by pcc's um uh my my um
constituent here is part of the
veterinary um Community um but there are
others uh if the person if the solo
person in the organization um that is
licensed uh somehow becomes not what's
called a qualified person um then they
are no longer eligible to direct that
organization pretty much immediately um
and that can be something irreconcilable
like they pass away um or they become
mentally incapacitated or they could
lose their lure in any of those
instances they lose their ability to
serve uh as the director of that
organization um the in order to do any
sort of corporate uh planning this
requires that
um that individual form some sort of
relationship with another professional
within their field that is not um not
technically part of their organization
um to be able to be listed as as you
know a a manager um in the event of this
the circum so what we're proposing is um
a change to the
law that would allow there to be an
assistant manager named who is just one
individual that is not a member of the
licensed um profession and the purpose
of this would not be that they could
carry on business of the organization in
a professional capacity um but more that
they could manage the the business
either the sale the dissolution the
conversion of that Corporation um in the
event that the that the um qualified
person is no longer able to to do that
um It's Time limited it allows them only
to serve in that capacity for a year um
and again it doesn't uh they could they
could exercise all the rights corporate
rights that the manager had but they
could not exercise the professional
rights that the manager had um so it's
really uh just avoids anyone in that
situation from having to operate you
know with someone hopefully there you
know people in their profession that
they trust but it's an awkward
relationship it requires a lot of trust
and it's a it's a fairly significant ask
for somebody if you become disqualified
to basically take over the entire
process of running and and dissolving
your your organization or selling it so
that's that's all I'm going to say again
um Roger gow is here um and he can fill
in the details behind this from a a a
lived perspective I'll call it um but uh
glad to take any questions all right qu
yes question representative Manos thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um I am confused because it
says each manager of a professional
limited liability company if any and all
the officers if any other than the
secretary or an assistant secretary and
the treasurer or an assistant Treasurer
or the assistant manager in the case of
a single member
pllc shall be qualified persons so as I
read that it sounds like um the
assistant manager does not need to be a
member of the professional of the
profession that forms the
LLC so so my my understanding of what
that of what's written there is that all
of those individuals do have to be um
qualified persons in order in order to
serve in that profession I I you know
again uh that was my understanding of
the way that that that is structured
currently may I have a followup of
course yes so so that was your intent
that that the um that the assistant
manager in the case of a single member
pllc be a member of the
profession that that the assistant
manager in this in this in this modified
bill would not need to be a a member of
the profession sorry if I'm
misunderstanding the original question
that the only change to the existing law
I think most of what you're reading is
in the current statute the only change
is the Bold section um uh you know or
the assistant manager in the case of a
single member Prof oh I see what you're
saying because that's um that's the
change sorry I see what you're saying
now and and it's making more sense so
you know it adds the the role of
assistant manager to the list of
possible roles um so someone could be
assistant manager in the current rule
without the the exemption from being a a
uh licensed professional so at first
establishes that concept of an assistant
manager and that first modification and
then down below basically uh creates the
exemption from it so yeah I if I'm
understanding that right and I'm
representing this correctly I think that
that's why that's in there the way it is
where you read it and then again down
below okay so I'm still a little
confused the assist manager that's being
added would need to be a member of the
profession or would not need to be a
member of the profession in the first
instance yes so where the where it's
added in that first sentence would need
to be a member of the profession so it's
essentially creating a new role within
the organization that could be occupied
by somebody who is a member of the
profession and then down below allows
just that particular role to be occupied
by somebody who's not how can the same
person both be a member of the
profession and not be a member of well
in other words in two different
organizations so one organization could
assign an assistant manager who is say
another
veterinarian um so it doesn't preclude
that it's just the the concept of an
assistant manager wasn't existing in the
law so so I should have mentioned that
that that writes that in as as a role
and then basically allows just that one
role to be occupied by somebody who's
not a member of the profession but it
does not require that that person not be
a member of the profession
in other words it doesn't open up all
the leadership roles of the profession
to a non-qualified person it only open
one person does not have to be a member
of the profession correct okay right for
one yeah for one year right
okay other questions for representative
CH representative Wallace yes thank you
thank you representative for taking my
question um overall I like the idea of
this particular bill seems like would
provide some relief in these particular
situations one question though um on
line 11 um would it not make sense that
um instead of leaving that open for up
to a year some type of a modification
such that uh the assistant manager May
for appeared up to up to one year or
until another qualified manager could be
appointed whichever is
shorter because absent that language
you'd almost have to leave that
assistant manager in that role until all
matter were settled um yeah I I think
the I think the inclusion of the
language for up to a year was meant to
sort of achieve that means but I I I
don't I mean from my own perspective
would not think that what I think you're
suggesting is the whichever shorter
language would be another way or maybe a
clearer way to say it if you think
that's
needed okay right other question to
share yes representative you up thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question representative Tor you know I'm
I'm a little bit confused because when I
read the bill the first line it says
this bill amends the law to permit a
single member professional limited
liability company to designate an an
assistant manager but you know reading
it I was getting very confused because
it doesn't say that the head of the pllc
is the current manager so it's sort of
like you know we're not calling them the
manager we're just calling
them single member professional
yeah in other part of the RSA I believe
uh this this is just the part about um
uh the section 12 is part of
304d um that and I could open it I have
it open on one of my other screens that
is the section definition um so 304 D1
sort of talks about the different types
of of uh professions that are covered
and then D12
is officers and
managers
um so it just basically says each
manager of the professional limited
liability Corporation and if any all
officers um and then it lists out the
other ones um will be qualified person
so it says that the whoever it is that's
the that's the manager of the
organization has currently to be a
qualified professional and this does not
allow a non-qualified person to take
that role may have follow up yes okay so
but we're not saying that the single
member professional the owner of the LLC
a pllc is the m current manager so it
sort of throws me
off I'm struggling a little to figure
out so I mean the the the manager would
be the you know one of the named ENT
named entities that that's uh leadership
I I don't know that the term owner
versus like manager are interchangeable
that may be over my my uh non- lawyerly
grade here in terms of of whether or not
ownership and being the manager are are
uh synonymous or not but the the person
who is the manager would have to be a
member of of the profession and
currently all the other sort of
directors of the organization would have
to be would have to be members so so
this just basically creates a new role
with an exception thank you yeah other
question yes representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I'm still
confused but is is the purpose of
this when when the um primary qualified
person um dies or is
disqualified is for that assistant
manager to um either um merge
close um the business uh within the year
period that's where the focus really is
a provisional sort of that's correct
yeah yeah if if there's more than one um
qualified person in the organization
then there's still somebody that has the
right to operate the organization but if
the if it's a solo organization and that
one person becomes disqualified by death
disability or or lure they then there's
nobody left to be able to sort of wind
down sell or at least from a corporate
standpoint and operate the organization
until you know it can be dissolved and
that the period of one year was chosen
just as a reasonable time frame but um
you know it in many instances it would
happen much quicker than that but but
otherwise there's no there's no legal um
and there's no legal person able to to
operate the
organization follow up follow up
um yeah you would think a year's time
would be enough but boy I've seen
businesses take um couple of years
several years you know railroads
sometimes take 10 or 15 years to
dissolve all the assets I mean this a
much smaller condensed sort of a right
entity um but hold over a provision um
in case it for some unforeseen reason it
took longer than a year what happens if
the year expires and it's not
accomplished yeah that's a good question
you know I uh we we had the assistance
of of uh Mr gown's attorney in in
putting this together I think the goal
was to make it very clear that this
can't somehow become an ongoing entity
um and I think that's the reason but
again I I do not know exactly what what
the reason for a year was but I think
his thought was that you know in a small
solo practice you could wind it down and
and and it should be very clear that
this is not a loophole that's going to
allow a corporate entity to go forward
that that shouldn't be allowed to under
that that statute
thanks that makes it clear okay other
questions so you know uh represent CH I
do have one question I I I think I'm
maybe a little confused I um I
understand from the um from the first
sentence of uh section 304 D12 as you've
proposed to amend it that it says that
the the the assistant manager in the
case of a Li mited liability company
shall be a qualified person so for
example in the in the veterinary let's
say that it's a Veterinary prati
solo Veterinary practice in other words
with with a limited liability company
and the and the sole uh member of that
limited liability company is the
veterinarian that's running the practice
as I understand
this that veterinarian could have an
assistant
manager uh who is also a veterinarian a
licensed veterinarian um and therefore
would qualify as a qualified
person right I think it's the reverse of
that like you have to be a qualified
person to hold the role holding the role
doesn't make you a qualif oh no no no I
understand that but but in other words
in my example so Veterinary the you know
the the tur Veterinary practice has Eric
turr veterinarian as the owner
uh and the sole member yes and has me
let's let's say I has Bob Linn as not an
owner but a veterinarian uh and and
under this you could make me the ve an
assistant manager in case something
happened to you yeah I believe what I
was trying to answer um to
representative mano's question was kind
of along those lines it does not
preclude that person from being a
qualified member but it it doesn't in it
it it allows that one role to be held by
someone who's not and so it's not a role
that comes into play only when the
person's disqualified this would be
somebody who's part of their practice on
an ongoing basis and able to take over
if something were to happen right I you
know what I I guess but the thing that
confuses me is where it says that that
person the ass shall be a qualified
person with respect to the professional
limited liability company and I I
thought that what that meant was in the
Veterinary example that I can become the
assistant manager of your Veterinary
practice as long as I'm a qualified
veterinarian I don't in other words I
don't have to be an owner of your
company but in order to become the
assistant manager I have to be a
qualified
veterinarian yeah again I as I'm looking
at this I maybe I can see where the
confusion because it does say you know
the assistant manager um exists in the
case of a single member uh professional
L limited liability Corporation um I
again I I I my understanding my belief
is that you know the the the idea was
that it would not preclude that um
profession but maybe the way that first
sentence is worded sort of means that
that person sort of can only exist
that's the way I that's the way I read
it and that's why I was saying if if if
if you do read it that way and I think
that to me that is is the way it reads
you know shall be shall be qualified
persons with respect to the limited
liability company that seems to me to
say you you if you want to be the
assistant manager in a Veterinary
practice you have to be a licensed
veterinarian and if that's true then the
second
sentence doesn't seem to change that so
if your intent was to allow
somebody in this circumstance for some
limited period of time who is not a
veterinarian to qu to serve as the
assistant manager I think we need to
tweak this language a bit yeah I'm I'm
wondering and again we can I can do this
after the fact but you know in that
first instance where it introduces the
role of assistant manager maybe the the
second part of that sentence where it
says assistant manager in the case of a
single member uh pllc right um maybe
that part's not needed maybe it just
introduces the role of assistant manager
and then later qualifies that that role
can be held I I I I think I'm seeing
what you're seeing which is that by
saying it can only exist in a single
partner organization you can't possibly
have a a a another qualified member in
that role because it wouldn't be a
single right partner organization so
yeah I I I take that and I think that
could be fixed okay represent Wallace
yes thank you that's what I was going to
just kind of put out there people
understand a single member LLC is just
that the only manager is that member and
I think we may be confusing
managing the veterinary office doesn't
make you a manager of the LLC that's two
distinctly different the term manager if
you will sorry yeah yeah the term
manager I think is a bit confusing in
the the way the law is written because
it it doesn't mean manager in the way I
think most people are thinking of a
manager correct all right great I mean
that's analogous to a president of a s
orc Corporation the manager of an LLC or
pllc
yeah yes representative stapled yeah if
you're going to add anything to it a
business manager might be a better term
for that particular unqualified person I
me we've had a discussion here that
probably could consume another page
worth of uh words to clarify and
differentiate but uh that that little
input would that make sense uh General a
business manager um or something similar
to that clarify yeah I'm not sure where
the the the term assistant manager came
from whether whether it has any meaning
Beyond just being an assistant manager I
can I can we I'd be glad to talk to the
person who helped um you know create
this language to see if business manager
would be an an
effective
solution right representative gon thank
you Mr chair Bill left out because I
wasn't confused
darn well you may have the answer that
we that that has eluded us I read this
making use of the little punctuation
mark called a
comma and as I read this I see that each
manager of a
pllc they skip everything else after
that until you get that there shall be a
qualified person with respect to the
professional liability company right
then if there are any
officers they shall be qualified persons
with respect to the professional uh
limited liability company
MH other than so here's where we have
exceptions to the law the secretary the
assistant secretary the treasurer or an
assistant Treasurer does not have to be
a a qualified person so it's other than
now you're slipping in or the assistant
manager in the case of a single
PC they're also exempt from being a
qualified
person then you go on to say that that
assistant manager can fulfill the role
of the
manager after for up to
one you got it you you're absolutely
right thank you you're absolutely right
I got my associates degree from verm
Tech and is that without the use of an
Oxford
comma
love okay
um m Mr chair I think that the interest
in this is fascinating but the clock is
ticking and we can edit this I
truthfully would very much like to hear
from the I believe probably the next
witness
who is who brought the problem to the
attention of our colleague to perhaps
help give us a frame work so that we can
understand what the difficulty is I
guess I'm an experiential learner and
that's why I might need that and we
could deal with the actual
language after the
hearing sounds good does that make sense
it does make sense and I I I will commit
to you know revisiting the question of
that the all the various things that
were brought up with that that language
and make sure that it a um conforms
to
not creating a conflict within this
paragraph and then and then also to
assure that that the underlying need
which I guess the last question may have
been the question of does is is is this
create the need I I still think the need
exists but I will I will work to make
sure that it
does sound no that sounds good that
sounds good all right other questions
for this
witness thank you thank you for your
attention all right uh Roger gone is
that gun I'm sorry yes
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today my name is Roger gown my wife Dr
jod Kaufman is a veterinarian who owned
a practice in exitor for 20 28 years HB
1082 addresses a problem with succession
planning for small professional
practices like my wife's in New
Hampshire in a single member limited
liability company or professional
limited liability company that has an
owner manager but no assistant manager
when the manager dies the executive of
the estate must petition the probate
court for an order appointing a person
to administer the practice winding it up
and dissolving it or selling it it can
take several months to get such order
from the Probate Court during that time
with no one to manage the business it's
likely to lose much of its value however
if the LLC or PLC has an assistant
manager that person can immediately step
in and manage the practice in present
law in order to designate someone as the
assistant manager of PC that person must
be licensed in the profession of the PC
in our case although I managed the
finances of my wife's business for many
years
I was not eligible to be named assistant
manager because I'm not a
veterinarian in the event of her death I
would have no authority over her
business even as the executive of her
estate I could not pay employees or
vendors hire a relief veterinarian to
keep the business going convert the
business to an LLC or work to wind it up
and sell
it under present law the licensed
professional PC owner must identify
another licensed professional that they
have the utmost trust in one who is
willing to take on such a large
responsibility simply as a
favor this is not an easy task for the
owner of a small single member practice
and it isn't always possible HB 1082
would make it easier for owner managers
to designate an assistant manager as
that person would not need to be
licensed within the profession this
person could be the licensed
professional spouse or other trusted
family member of course the
nonprofessional assistant manager would
have a limited time in which to act
would not be permitted to work in the
practices a professional capacity and
would have to act in accordance with the
plc's operating agreement HB 1082 would
help ensure that the interests and
desires of the owner of a small
professional practice would be kept
Paramount in the resolution of the
business thank you for your
consideration I look forward to
answering your questions questions for
this witness yes representative
Divine um couldn't that designation be
listed in in an operating agreement
within the business yes and would have
to be but the law does not permit it
because it has it's a I'm a
non-qualified person in our case Okay
the law requires it to be a qualified
person but on on based on say in an
operating agreement usually there's some
sort of um Provisions for um you know if
if there was a death or something would
happen where if there were Partnerships
or anything like that but in in a uh
limited single person single person yes
that would not you're stating that that
would not qualify right you still have
to find someone to be that other person
because you're a single member okay and
so the operating agreement in our case
the operating agreement lists as
assistant manager um a very close friend
of ours who is a veterinarian who would
be willing to step in although that
would be a huge challenge right thank
you other questions for this witness
seeing none Thank you very very much
thank
you um I don't have any other pink cards
is there anyone else excuse me who
wishes to be heard on House Bill
1082 all right seeing none I'm going to
close the hearing on House Bill
1082 and I think we're a little bit got
a few minutes to go before we can do the
next
one I
think
thank you um let
just
yeah
it's 2:30 and I'm going to uh open the
hearing on House Bill uh 1089 uh
relative to the statute of limitations
on civil actions involving pfas and I'll
call first uh uh representative uh Veil
please thank you Mr chairman and thank
you honorable members of the committee
um my name is Suzanne Vil for the record
and I am a representative representing
Hillsboro County District 30 which is
Nashville award 3 um I am back before
you today actually to ask you to
consider House Bill 1089 um I was before
your committee two years ago with a very
similar bill it was House Bill 236 at
the time and this bill established a
past statute of limitations that was six
years so not three years it had broad
bipartisan support um I have a speech
here that has a lot of the background on
past but I'm not sure where people are
at with their knowledge of the situation
so I don't want to take up too much of
your time but at the same time I also
want to be able to tell you why you're
voting on this if there's a story behind
it that you need to
know so I leave it up to you to just let
me know if I'm going on too long um so
I'm I'm back here to today um because we
created an statute of limitation on
civil actions relative to damage caused
by past chemicals um and what we're
thinking now is that with forever
chemicals it takes a really long time to
find out what the health impacts are and
the impacts to a community a community's
water supply and so this
bill that we're speaking about today
would change that six-year statute of
limitations to
a um what it says here I'm not sure if
this writing is what we would want it to
say but any time after a plaintiff or
the state discovers such harm injury or
damages and the causal relationship of
an act or Omission to such harm injury
or
damage I can tell you a little bit about
why we would want to change this um just
for the fact that you are hearing P
before you um we're talking about these
bills we're in Health and Human Services
talking about health impacts um we're in
um resources where my the committee I
come from to in order to look at some of
the mitigation that we can do but no
matter what we're doing we're always
working with people who need more time
and we know that forever chemicals can
affect you it takes years for some of
these emerging cancers that are
associated and other health impacts to
come about and it also takes a lot of
time for a state and a state agency like
Dees to be able to bring um what we
consider people responsible for
pollution in the environment to the
table and to be able to seek legal
remedy
I think right now there's a real big
concern because one of the most um
proliferant polluters for lack of a
better word is leaving the state and
they're leaving the factory behind and
we don't know what is going to happen
there in fact it's very difficult to
tell what exactly has gone on
there so um just to review again with
the bill
what we're seeking right now is to
remove the statute of limitations but
also to augment what we already have in
law so that anytime after a plaintiff or
the state or a um Municipal Water Supply
um another Municipal agency can discover
this harm injury damages and the causal
relationship and they can seek the
damages um that they will need in order
to get their town get their health
whatever whoever the litigant is um back
on track so I'm going to conclude with
that and if you um have questions
about as I said the contamination the
source of it the length of time we're
talking about this was only two years
ago that it went through but my
understanding is that if you live in
marac someone came to your door in 2016
or 2017 and they told you that you're
well with was full of something that
needed to be tested and you could be
having Health impacts from that and just
two years later I think there's more
information out there but there isn't
time for people to determine what those
impacts are financially and hold the um
the propagate of the problems that we're
having um accountable financially and in
every way that we need them to be
accountable thank you for taking my
testimony right questions for this
witness representative
Manos thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so this would remove
any statute of limitations at all is
that
correct yes on the uh
pfas
chemicals and where this statute where
this bill would be entering into is in a
separate area of law that's just about
past followup thank you
um I was thinking as as I was reading
through this I was thinking about
insurability and whether if the statute
of limitations is removed
completely whether that would make these
kinds of claims completely
uninsurable for manufacturers and
whether that then creates other problems
for
plaintiffs I think that's a really good
question and I'm glad that I have a
little bit of background in order to be
able to answer it so if we remove the
statute of limitations then insurance
companies won't be feeling that they're
liable they feel that this company is
liable um so my response to that is that
right now if you go to your doctor and
you tell them listen I have this thing
and it's a mile long and I have 12
chemicals and they're like 17 times the
amount that they consider Save which
honestly I think zero is the only safe
number however um you know you go to
your doctor and the doctor doesn't even
know what you're talking about so one of
the things that we're trying to do
through legislation and through ad hoc
committees and and is just get that
education out there because we're we
feel like reaching the Physicians who
are treating the illnesses that this is
causing I mean on one hand doctors treat
something on a symptom basis on the
other hand
there's a whole lot they don't know and
they need to get into and like myself
when a bill comes before me and I'm not
so familiar with the area of law that
it's in there's a lot of research that
needs to be done before you open your
mouth
so yes follow up thank you um I was
thinking more about the question and
it's it's a question for me as to
whether if the statute of limitations
were removed completely whether
insurance companies then would because
there's no such of limitations and the
risk goes up greatly whether insurance
companies would then refuse to ensure
manufacturers of P against liability
claims so that's beyond the scope of
what I would know because that sounds
more like Commerce where you're talking
about insurance and whether or not a
company would be able to be insured I
think that if you have a company coming
to New Hampshire with the way things are
going right now and you're planning on
sping P it's probably too late to come
here and try to do that but I don't know
of any liability that's been assumed let
alone who would be doing
it other questions so I I do have a
couple questions first um can you tell
me are you aware
are there are there any
other areas of where where a person who
is injured can recover damages where
there's no statute of limitations are
you aware of any I mean would if we were
to do this would would P be the the the
only area in the law where there was no
statute of
limitations yes it would all right so if
for example and I I mean if if
uh if there's nuclear waste stored at
sebr or something like that that causes
injury I don't know I I don't know
whether there's a federal statute
dealing with that might be but but if at
least for state law
purposes there would be that that claim
would be subject to the statute of
limitations would you repeat that for me
if somebody was injured if there was
some Escape of uh nuclear material or
nuclear fumes or whatever from seabook
or or or maybe some some company that
was transporting spent nuclear fuel
through New Hampshire to move it to
somewhere else and somebody was injured
that claim would be there would be a
statute of limitations for that claim
but not for
this in my opinion just you know not
being somebody to make these kinds of
decisions in a courtroom I would say
that we would lookit we would look for
some kind of release of statute of
limitations in the law that's about
nuclear waste and how that's treated or
in the the
operating um statutes for operating and
disposing of nuclear waste that would be
a completely different so this as I said
lives right in its own area of Law and
that area of law was created when people
came into these committees from miramac
and started filing bills about how they
could get better remedies um if if I
venture to say a little bit more there
are several bills out there right now
that are about quote unquote making
polluters pay I'm not sure if this one
is necessary but I do think we should
pass it and we should make sure that it
does what we expect it to do and that it
only does it to the area of Statute and
to the topic matter that we're talking
about direct um if we can determine a
cause or demonstrate an irrefutable
relationship between the destruction of
a water supply the cancer that someone's
carrying in their body that they have a
remedy for doing that and they have the
time to do it so 2016
17 was six years
ago so it's
over the first bill I did that time
period for a lot of people they knew
that they had a problem when they got
that knock on the
door that's when the clock starts
running and I had spoken to colleagues
on both sides of the aisle um the
original bill was something that um our
former speaker who was deceased
unfortunately was um a co-sponsor of the
bill and there are many ranking members
on both sides of the aisle that will be
in support of this and um the online
testimony and the signin sheet should
support
that yeah representative
Smith thank you I'm I'm fascinated by
this line of
inquiry um as someone who actually has
still not had occasion to try
tobacco um and I'm not planning to was
there a time
limitation on all the tobacco suits I
mean if I you would know more than I um
you know I don't even play a lawyer on
TV um but I was under the impression
that there was no time limit I mean
someone could have stopped smoking
and as soon as they came home from World
War II when so many people were in fact
introduced to
cigarettes um but would have been
eligible
for
compensation decades later isn't is am I
wrong about that no I don't think you
are but I think the it's not that
there's no statute limitations I think
the the the cause of action doesn't
arise until you until you are sick and
you can you can C you know trace the
sickness to Tobacco so but isn't that
the same situation we're facing here
what happens is um as each month pass
forget about year we learn more about
these particular um chemicals and what
uh I think what is a larger category
that are referred to now increasingly as
Forest forever chemicals because they
don't because they are forever and and
they um they're not so great for us I
mean I you know I remember I remember
thinking Teflon pans were great because
I didn't have to use a lot of fat or oil
things wouldn't stick to them wouldn't
that be so healthy well guess
what they're not so healthy but we
didn't know that then and we do know it
now and um that's probably an
unimaginative example but it just shows
how limited I am I
guess I I think it's the same situation
Mr chair and
um yeah I mean I I guess I would say I I
disagree for it because I think if
that if
the if you don't discover that you're in
injured from
P um or have uh if you don't discover
that you're injured number one and
number two that it's tied to past for
some you know some period into the
future then that's when when you as I
understand a l when the statute
limitations begins to run when you know
or should have known that you've been
injured and that you were the injury was
caused
by what you're suing about that's I
think that's would be the same for
tobacco for p i mean under existing law
for tobacco for P for for for whatever
um and I don't think I mean I unless at
least in New Hampshire I don't think
that there's any you know that we have a
law in New Hampshire that says there's
no statute limitations for example for
tobacco injuries I don't think that
that's that that's the
law representative Divine staying on
this topic would there be um any
uh sorts of statues on say asbest where
there was asbest dumped say in
nashwa um around New Soul school about
oh God 30 40 50 years ago so to me I
don't and there's ASB bestus cases that
go on throughout the country would you
see this very similar to what that was
and I don't know if there's any statues
for that but ASB bestus was a big thing
for a long time there's a lot of
litigation it goes for years and years
and
years
so I'm just trying to pull a question
let's see an answer out of that
um I don't see it as the same I see it
as
you are living with something you're
learning about something you're learning
that there's a contamination Zone that
some of the impacts on your community
are being um addressed but many are not
the zone of contamination
is
includes areas and excludes a lot of
areas that are probably very active and
it's based on how your well how many
Wells we can test at a time and how many
how many people do we determine need an
alternative water supply so there's
things I mean there's just a a lot going
on I I we do find ASB bestus everywhere
we do know that it's a um a contaminant
and we know that it's everywhere and
we're trying to deal with it and help
people deal with their mesothelioma and
other um disorders that come from
inhaling ASB bestus or being around it
but I think with this this is you know
as best as was thought to be the
greatest thing um and that can sound
like Teflon except that St gobain was
here after they had to leave HK Falls
New York because they had statutes that
would no longer tolerate the pollution
and that the same thing in Bennington
Vermont with st gobain and they came to
New Hampshire and they knew what they
were doing they had been out in other
states they have longterm information
about the the impacts of pasas the
industry going all the way back to 3M
and other companies in the 60s the 70s
they knew about this in the 50s they
knew about it in the 60s and they just
kept on going and all of us know that we
were told that the um Teflon pans were
bad but then they came out with a
replacement so this is kind of what the
game has been it's almost like okay well
originally there's two pases that are
thought to be the most evil of all of
them and that's the pfos and the
pfoa but when you make Gen X so you can
still make those codings but you can say
well this isn't the same molecule and it
can't be restricted and it's not going
to do the same thing to
you those assertions need to be either
supported or they need to be dispelled
and this is a situation where the where
the company has stepped up but only
after being dragged into the courtroom
and signing dis consent decrees with
towns like marac that are you know
there's a lot of areas
private Wells that are all over the
region and you know we still need to
test we still need to catch up there's
just the science is still catching up on
the health impacts we're starting to
gather data in New Hampshire from the
mayor Matt cluster and from the cluster
that's near the kle landfill so these
kinds
of empirical data are coming in now we
didn't have that till we started
collecting it we couldn't collect it
until we made a statute to collect it so
thank you all right other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much thank you so much I appreciate your
time uh Chris uh Servo
service thank you thank you Mr chairman
and honorable MERS press the but oh oh
okay there it
is thank you Mr chairman and honorable
members of uh this committee um yeah uh
my name is Chris SRA I'm a student at
Philips exitor in exitor New Hampshire
and I'm originally from New Jersey and
today I believe we're uh at a critical
juncture in our collectives surrounding
uh safeguarding public health and
protecting our environment uh as we just
know um are confronted by a silent uh
but I believe to be Insidious threat
lurking within our communities per and
poly floral alkal substances known as
pasas or pfas U and they are found as
people have already mention in all kinds
of products from uh things like
non-stick pans to firefighting foam uh
to waterproof clothing and uh these
chemicals have seeped into our water
systems uh and have infiltrated over 97%
of people all around the world um
resulting in some health implications
I'll discuss later on I posit that house
build 1089 represents
a pivotal step towards confronting this
threat headon and we're taking a step
towards the justice that the victims of
these substances deserve um as I
mentioned I think it's very important to
examine some of the medical research
done on this topic um pasas has been
linked to higher rates of varying types
of cancer from liver uh cancer to
hyperthyroidism um in a recent study um
from the National Institute of Health uh
they examine the effects on heavily
exposed workers and I detected a
significantly increased death rate um
compared to those who were exposed less
um another link that I saw um was
between pasas and developmental issues
and birth effects in infants um one
study examined over 500,000 mothers and
children and found a link between pasas
and many conditions from congenital
heart defects to cleft
lips and I want you to know in this room
uh that past chemicals are not just
another Environmental concern there are
clear and present danger to the public
health of New Hampshire individuals and
I don't think that the health risks can
be overstated and The Time for Action is
now uh as a conservative myself I see
that Republicans often advocate for the
protection of our natural rights and
advocate for limited government
intervention and I do really value these
items however past contamination
infringes upon these rights by
contaminating private property and poses
risk to the health and well-being of
Americans this is a case where I believe
government intervention is Justified and
where we must put aside our political
differences to protect the
people and certainly some may argue that
regulation uh stifles economic growth
and burdens businesses with undue
restrictions however what price can we
place on the health and well-being of
our citizens can we in good conscience
prioritize short-term convenience over
the long-term health of our communities
and we must stop past now um as these
persistent chemicals pervade and
accumulate um being named uh forever
chemicals and I do hope that you will
stand with me in support and truly uh
value the importance of human lives that
have been and will be affected by past
contamination as a 17-year-old myself I
hope that our state legislators uh like
yall uh work towards reform in some sort
of way uh that will protect generations
to come um and promote environmental
Integrity so thank you so much
questions for this
witness thank you sir you oh I'm sorry
yes represent one comment um would you
believe that the EPA was started by a
conservative president certainly yeah I
yeah the EPA and many of the first
environmental acts the Clean Air Act uh
Clean Water Act were uh very bipartisan
and actually led by a conservative
majority which yeah so yeah thank you
other questions seeing none thank you
very much next I'm going to call uh
Ghana Kuba
please we can hear you
so there you go thank you I have copies
if any of you want I don't have enough
for everyone but that's okay just we'll
yeah we'll we'll figure out a way to
handle that thank you yeah
course
um good afternoon Mr chairman and
honorable members of the committee thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
speak alongside Chris my name is ginina
Kuba and I'm also a senior at Philips
exitor Academy but Virginia Beach is my
home I'm here to testify and support of
House Bill 1089 to remove the current
six-year statue of limitations on
damages caused by past
exposure as Chris mentioned pasas is a
group of synthetic chemicals using
various industrial and consumer products
due to their water and grease resistant
properties although pasas can be useful
in application the effects are
horrifying what is so dangerous about
past is how little we know about it the
extent of its destruction despite its UB
ubiquity there's past in my blood yours
and everyone in this room it is not a
natural chemical it is found in our
bodies and like people have mentioned it
lasts forever how scary is that
of the 9,000 known past compounds 600
are currently used in a multiple
multitude of products and goods in the
US this includes food packaging
firefighting foam dental floss carpets
clothing and the list goes on P chem
chemicals contain a carbon Florine bond
which is an incredibly strong bond and
therefore when pasas enters the
environment the environment is unable to
break apart the bond causing the
quantity of pasas in the environment to
build up aside from usage pasas is
virtually everywhere industrial
processes use past and these sites often
release pasas into the water or air past
contamination of water happens
frequently near industrial facilities
military bases and areas where
firefighting Foams containing past have
been used years of this have occurred at
our very own peace Air National Guard
base where soil and groundwater were
contaminated it is not only Public Water
Supplies private Wells also contain p
contamination the exposure to pasas is
much broader than you might think even
Beyond drinking water it's in our food
and household products I ask you today
why take that risk human life is
precious and it is only just that we
respect and acknowledge that inherent
value particularly when it comes to
health concerns we do not know when we
might observe the manifestation of the
effects of pasas and it is essential we
give our citizens and communities that
Liberty aside from the ecological degrad
degradation pasas causes we are coming
to learn more and more about how pasas
is affecting the Public's
Health in a recent study published in
environmental health insights
researchers found that in Southern New
Hampshire in marac residents had higher
rates of thyroid cancer than national
average and particularly higher rates of
thyroid colon and prostate cancer
compared to nearby towns that did not
have high levels of past exposure marac
is home to a factory that produces past
lined glass and
fabrics it's not just ordinary people
like my myself who know the effects of
past but the companies who are using and
unleashing these chemicals as well
Dupont Chemical Company is one of the
largest chemical companies in the world
in 1951 Dupont began purchasing plur FL
octenic acid or PFO for use in
manufacturing tough Fon a synthetic
floral polymer known for its
non-sticking properties instead of
properly disposing of it deont dumped
thousands of pounds of chemical into the
Ohio river and pits into which seeped
into the ground and contaminated the
drinking water of nearby
communities at the same time deont was
conducting researches research in the
1960s on pasas and knew that it caused
organ damage in animals in the 1970s
dupon also discovered that there were
high concentrations of toxic chemicals
in the blood of their workers and did
not notify their workers of this then in
the 1980s defont confirmed that the
chemical was a affecting the health of
their workers and found defects in the
babies of their pregnant employees and
even after all this Dupont did not make
the information public by the 1990s
deont knew that pasas caused cancerous
test testicular pancreatic and liver
tubers in lab animals finally in 2006
depart reached a $16.5 million
settlement with Environmental Protection
Agency for concealing information and
knowledge about P's toxicity the $16.5
million siment represented less than 2%
of the company's profits that year dupon
has been found liable for the health of
thousands of
plff all for what profit to me that is
inexcusable it took only it took over 50
years of suffering for so many innocent
civilians to have their Humanity
recognized many will never even know
about the harm done to them furthermore
6 years is merely a drop in this pool of
chemical waste destruction and greed I
believe in this fundamental recognition
of people's autonomy and well-being
people like myself do not even have a
sliver of the influence and power that
Dupont
possesses and that is why we come to the
law to provide us with the hope of
challenging power structures dominant in
our socioeconomic conditions thank you
for your time I hope you consider the
positive impact of Bill and Justice that
HB 1089 will provide for the people of
New
Hampshire thank you questions yes
represent thank you thanks for taking my
question you know the
takeout containers that we take out yes
if they don't leak you know they have
Pas in them are you aware of that yes
it's everywhere
y other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very muches oh I'm
sorry representative stap sorry about
that thank you just a quick you
mentioned being a student of an academy
I didn't catch where that is Philips
exitor it's in exitor New Hampshire okay
thank you very much of course right any
other questions for this yes
representative Loreno thank you for
taking my question um now is this part
of a class project that you folks are
working on yeah well done thankk you all
right thank you very much awesome thank
you next I'm going to call on Chris
Appel
please
thank you chairman Lind my name is Chris
Appel I'm an attorney at the law firm of
Shak cardian bacon in Washington DC I'm
testifying in opposition to HB 1089 on
behalf of the American tort reform
Association which is a broad-based
coalition of businesses municipalities
associations and professional firms with
an interest in promoting greater balance
and predictability in civil litigation
hopefully I can answer some of the
questions came up during the first round
with uh the representative uh sponsor my
goal here is to explain the vital role
statutes of limitation play in New
Hampshire and in every State's Civil
Justice System and to provide a national
perspective on attempts like the one in
this bill to eliminate a statute of
limitations first and foremost statutes
of limitations whether two years 3 years
or here six years are an essential
element of a properly functioning Civil
Justice System they allow judges and
juries to evaluate liability when the
best evidence is available before
records are discarded or Witnesses pass
away or can no longer be located as the
New Hampshire Supreme Court has
repeatedly emphasized the primary
purpose of a statute of limitations is
to eliminate stale or fraudulent claims
as the court has further explained a
statute of limitations establishes a
deadline after which a defendant May
legitimately have peace of mind it
recognizes that after a certain period
of time it is unfair to require a
defendant to attempt to piece together
defense to an old claim the court
another case recognized that statutes of
limitation serve society's purposes by
keeping from the courts those claims
which are stale and in which credibility
has been eroded by the passage of time
and faltering memories these limitation
periods expedite the orderly
administration of justice and promote
security and stability to human Affairs
again all statements by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court HB 1089 would
proposes to upend those foundational
public policies es by eliminating the
statute of limitations for p injury
claims the bill would allow P injury
lawsuits to be brought for literally
forever in doing so the bill would
remove any semblance of predictability
or rationality in past litigation and
expose countless New Hampshire entities
to potentially indefinite
liability importantly there is no
compelling reason to take this extreme
approach as was mentioned at the
beginning just a few years ago in 2021
the legislature doubled the statute of
limitations for p injury claims from 3
years to 6 years the amendment also
included an explicit Discovery rule that
can extend that already longer statute
of limitations period the six-year
limitations period does not begin to run
until the plaintiff discovers or in the
exercise of reasonable diligence should
have discovered both the injury and the
causal relationship to a defendant's
torous act or omission in other words a
person can already Sue 10 20 30 years
after being injured if for whatever
reason they didn't discover the injury
and who caused it and they were
reasonably diligent in trying and didn't
just sleep on their injury
claim to put this bill in a national
context no state has ever taken this
approach to P or any other potentially
harmful substance as far as I can tell
the there is only one situation in which
a state has eliminated a civil statute
of limitations period and that is in the
very different very unique context of
childhood sexual abuse claims the
rationale for doing so in that situation
is that sexually abused children might
repress their trauma and injury so A
specialized rule is needed to address
those exceptional
circumstances even so only around a
dozen states or so have taken the
approach of eliminating the applicable
statute of limitations as opposed to
extending it or creating a specialized
Discovery rule for it I would submit
that a p related injury uh Bears no
similarity to repress childhood sexual
abuse uh and instead fits within the
universe of other tort claims for which
finite statutes of limitations govern it
is also worth noting that from a
national perspective 6 years is among
the longest limitations periods for
bringing a tort claim in many states
that limitations period is 2 years or 3
years finally eliminating the six-year
statute of limitations for pasas injury
claims would be especially unjust in the
context of exposure to pasas as as was
stated uh by the by the students uh in
terms of how ubiquitous p is p refers to
a class of nearly 15,000 chemicals and
virtually everyone is exposed regularly
to P for instance as a recent Time
magazine article pointed out every
raindrop has pasas in it approximately
90 7 to 99% of Americans have some level
of past in their bodies right now that
this means that pretty much everyone is
a potential plaintiff and could bring a
lawsuit against someone at some point if
that person ever experiences any ailment
allegedly caused by pasas as a practical
matter it would be virtually impossible
for any defendant whether a large
corporation a small business even a
neighbor to mount a fair defense to
claims alleging injury that occurred 40
50 60 years prior this is why the
existence of statutes of limitations are
so vital to maintain a balance and
predictability and avoid chaos in New
Hampshire's Civil Justice System and
with that um for all these reasons atro
respectfully urges the committee to
reject this bill and I'd be pleased to
answer any
questions questions for this witness
representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking my
questions are you aware that New
Hampshire I know you mentioned other
states and everything but we're New
Hampshire uh are you aware that New
Hampshire has an
incredible Southern New Hampshire an
incredible water problem because of pest
and it's a huge I happen to live in
londonairy and we have a huge past
problem in the water in the water
because of a company much like Dupont
are you aware of that and that is why
okay and are you aware that this
negotiations or whatever you want to
call them with that company have been
going on for a long time the company's
now leaving closing down and leaving and
been going on for a long time and that
the wheels of this turn very very slowly
and that's why they're looking to extend
this I am aware of that and I will just
say that the statute of limitations
doesn't affect whether a claim is
Meritus or not it affects the period in
which a claim can be brought right and
so when you have a dis the existing
Discovery rule provides that the claim
can be the the period in which to bring
a meritorious claim can
extend decades if if if the science
isn't there to link to show a both
injury you have first of all you like
all tour claims you have to show an
injury so people might not develop an
injury for 10 20 30 years after you have
an injury you have to be aware you have
to discover the injury or reasonably
should have discovered the injury and
the causal connection to it so not just
I'm injured and I now know who caused it
that is when the statute of limitations
kicks in so to answer the questions that
were earlier I think there was a
question about tobacco litigation and
asbest and all of those have statutes of
limitation I'm at most their six years
they probably less but the reason that
those claims that litigation goes on for
10 20 30 years in asbest case more than
a half century now the reason is that
because the injury doesn't develop for a
very long time sometimes they latent
injuries they take decades to develop in
some cases and in C in other cases the
science wasn't there to show that there
was causation so that the injury was
caused by past as opposed to I don't
know I drank a vial of you know toxic
waste I mean so uh you have to establish
both and the current New Hampshire law
allows for that and so that would it
tolls the limitation period and
potentially toll it for a very long time
what this bill does again is just throws
that out the window which again no state
has ever done in the context of P or uh
any other potentially hazardous
substance and there are certainly a lot
more hazardous substances than pasas
that exist in the world uh toxic waste
was thrown out as an example earlier but
um there's a reason that states don't do
this it's it's because it fundamentally
disrupts the Civil Justice System in the
state or would if they if if they went
down that
path Mr representative dorenzo thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um would you please send the
committee a copy of your
testimony um my oral remarks uh
sure thank you right representative
Smith um thank you first of all you know
New Hampshire is not
made uncomfortable by the thought that
we might be first in the nation in
anything so um I just want to if if
you're going to make the trip up from
Washington again in the future you might
want to skip that line and testimony um
but I want to ask you something about
the fact that you're making this trip up
from Washington um it fascinates me
we're a small state um 1.3 million
people of course there are those of us
who love it Daniel Webster loves the
state uh the fact that you're
here kind of confuses me is there not a
New Hampshire Law Firm that would have
had the information The
credibility to represent at least some
of the
entities you you um are here on behalf
of I
guess to me it's an alarm signal that
you are here and um and that makes me
think that maybe this bills on the right
track and that might be unfair and
that's why I want to share my feelings
with you I I understand and maybe I can
put you at ease a little bit I was
actually here testifying on a bill
yesterday and I just was asked oh so
it's a twofer in a sense yes like I I I
I'm not here I wasn't here specifically
for this bill if it makes you feel
better right representative Wallace have
a question yes thank you thank you for
taking my question you're up here from
DC could you speak to uh any federal
regulations and I'm thinking of EPA type
uh situations I'm sure we've all
remember the Love Canal in Upstate New
York back in the 60s and 70s the river
actually being on fire from Hazmat we've
had some local um occurrences here in
the State uh the Tanner and Raymond uh
BD oil waste oil distribution these are
all super fund sites that are still
being remed remediated 40 years later I
remember as a young man um and these uh
the BD in particular that lawsuit went
multigenerational in that I believe the
feds prosecuted this but not only did
they um sue the uh the operation got
shut down and also the the kids uh their
fortunes were brought into this so my
question is don't we already have almost
no statute limitations for environmental
crimes I mean this would be anal to an
environmental crime I understand it's a
civil no I mean um I'm not extremely
well versed in how super fund works but
I believe there is I mean there are
statutes of limitation they just in in
super fund cases a lot of times they a
remediation effort can be to your point
a multi-decade process just because it
it's very difficult in some situations
depending on the type of uh
environmental contamination to just snap
your fingers and and get it clean it it
can it can be so it's not so much that
and superf fund we're talking here about
private personal injury claims as
opposed to a what might be a class
remediation effort or a fund site of
remediation effort which is very a
different
animal follow yes please yes thank you
um I understand that this is to address
individual causes of action but we're
not not there's a there's thousands of
individuals that have been affected here
in New Hampshire from this St gobain
site in Northern marac New Hampshire um
I've had personal properties Wells uh be
inspected by this and it's it's
absolutely contaminated so this may
develop into more of a class action suit
but uh clearly um the deed has been done
the harm has been done and we do have
victims uh here in New Hampshire and uh
you know the piper needs to pay is due
and leaving the State doesn't solve the
problem you know that's that's part of
our concern so if you're going to
operate in an above board Manner and be
responsible that's not what's happening
here these people are leaving the state
and leaving our jurisdiction so it
leaves us no choice they're not doing
the right thing we're going to change
the Rules of Engagement and we're going
to lock horns with them however long it
takes uh well Ju Just to recap so this
bill affects far more than with just
more one company this bill would affect
countless entities it could affect
someone I mean it could affect down to
the personal level not small business
large business correct up and down the
line so um you know I I I would urge
that it's not
um taking this path the this type of
path in in this legislation would not be
uh a sound way if you're just if your
beef is with uh a particular entity or
uh because because again this affects
everyone agreed and as a as a 30-year
license small Hazmat generator by the
EPA who's never had any incidents um we
take a lot of time and effort to make
sure that we don't have any releases
into the environment um and even in the
small auto repair shop like I own and
operated for 30 plus years we took it
very seriously and I am a mom was a mom
and pop operation these are clearly
large organizations that have the
science the the research uh wings and
their organizations they know what they
were doing that's why they located here
back in the day
um I appreciate the answer but I think
uh there was some nefarious acts going
on here and we we need to get to the
bottom of it and people need to right
just again this doesn't affect the Merit
the meritorious of any individual claim
this is merely the period in which you
can bring a claim and how that how that
is uh
determined other question for this
witness yes representative CH yeah than
thanks and thank you for taking the
question um I just following up on some
uh line of of discussion that you
brought up earlier which seemed to sort
of
say PS is a very large class of
chemicals um that's broadly exposed
everyone over over long periods of time
um and
uh
and that the the sort of ability to
connect um the exposure to any given you
know
outcome uh because of that because there
are so many chemicals and they're so
ubiquitous and they last forever as
third point I was trying to bring up um
I was not clear of why that was brought
up it almost in my mind seems to speak
to why this class of chemicals would
have a longer or maybe no statute of
limitations because it will take so long
to establish the impact in other words
if everyone has these how how how how
much exposure and how long does it have
to happen before you begin to be able to
make the case that this
particular um contamination led to this
particular outcome and then basically
have to move forward from that yeah so
that that's a great question so because
there is so much P if statutes of
limitation exists to provide a balance
in our Civil Justice System fund at a
fundamental level that's why they exist
in every claim so on one side you want
to balance the plaintiff's ability to
bring a claim within a reasonable time
of suffering an injury and knowing who
caused it and on the other hand you you
want to protect defendants you want to
sec give them a fair shake so that
they're not having to defend claims 60
years down the road when there's it's
really just all the there's no records
everyone who's involved dead and you
just have basically one person saying
yeah you injured me 40 years ago when I
drank from your well um you know I I
suffered an injury and I want to bring a
lawsuit against you well realistically i
i i that doesn't provide someone with
the ability to mount a fair defense
which is fundamental to our legal system
so just one quick follow sure so so it
sort of sound and this is what I'm
struggling with it sounds like what
you're saying is the the problem is so
big and so ubiquitous and so diverse
that it almost defies the concept of
civil liability to begin with no not
necessarily no because if you can if you
have S if you sustained an injury from
exposure to P fast for a long period of
time and you can point to someone and
say you're the one who did that you
caused my injury you can sue them like
there's there's no I mean you have under
you have six years under current law to
sue them or you have potentially decades
to sue them if that's when your M after
your injury materializes and you
exercise reasonable diligence in not
sleeping on your injury claim the the
the basic point of a statute of
limitations is to protect people who
just purposefully sleep on their claim
knowing that it gives them an unfair
Advantage later on if you if you sleep
if you know that if I wait a little bit
longer there's the ability to defend
these claims dissipates because everyone
who can uh mount a fair defense can no
longer do so there's a
again backing up to what the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has repeatedly
said the statutes of limitation the main
purpose is to prevent stale and
fraudulent
claims representative
kab thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question I want to en uh
make sure that I understood you
correctly because I it seems like
there's a little bit of perhaps
misunderstanding from other committee
members so I just want to clarify what I
heard you say was that let's say
somebody is exposed to past now they
don't know that they're currently
injured and 20 years from now is when
they first discovered that they were
injured from that when they discover
that in 20 years they have six years
from that date of discovery is that
correct yes and potentially even longer
than that they because it it's not just
that they developed an injury it's who
caused that injury so if it they develop
an injury in 20 years and they don't
realize who caused it for another
then the statute of limitations kicks in
under the discovery rule thank you other
questions for the yes representative for
us thank thank you thanks for taking my
question my concern is that you're
talking about
individuals um my concern is being a a
resident of londondary um we're trying
to get St gobain to do some things like
put a pipeline down a road so that
people can get uh water and they're not
depending on their their um cont
extremely contaminated Wells extremely
contaminated Wells um my concern and I
don't I my concern is not so much about
the individual but the the big picture
for Southern New Hampshire and it seems
to me that the statute of limitations
with that has really started because we
know it's a problem and so we have our
six years as started is that correct uh
well there when you say we know we have
a problem that doesn't what what what is
required under the law is the existence
of an injury so that might you might
know you have a problem but you might
the injury might not be there
yet is not having contaminated water an
injury uh the existence of contaminated
water is not a physical injury with when
we're talking about Tor claims which is
what this is personal injury claims
those are a physical injury to a person
okay all right other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir um I don't think I have any other uh
uh pink sheets pink cards on House Bill
1089 is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
1089 yes would you come up and you need
to fill out one of the pink cards
please oh is no that was for the next B
that that's for the next one um I just
would like to say one brief thing based
on his sure you fill out a card if you
would
please red the pink cards pink cards
right on the edge of the table yes Mr ly
thank you okay yeah you can you can
start testifying and just fill it out
when you're done thank you sir uh nice
to meet you um thank you all for hear me
speak um my name is Robert tangue um
just in reference to the gentleman's
last uh
testimony um he said that personal
injury is physical it's also P statute
emotional um and I don't know the exact
statute but it is emotional damage too
and so that's kind of not looked at and
when you go around uh looking for a
lawyer or a law firm you'll see personal
injury lawyers and they typically only
take the slam dunk physical you know
police abuse or a car accidents physical
but it is per statute emotional abuse is
intentional emotional uh intentional
infliction of emotional abuse and there
is also
um uh negligent infliction of emotional
abuse um as regards to the bill I don't
know too much about the bill but I
understand that there are some timelines
that should be met uh for the defense
but then there's also statutes uh which
allow upon discovery
of uh elements of the tort physical or
emotional um that can extend those
threeyear statute of
limitations and uh that's my testimony
on this unless there's any questions
great questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you
sir is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
1089 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
okay I'm going to open up the committee
on house bill 1104 FN and ask
representative L Lynn to take it over
thank you Mr chair uh good afternoon
committee members I know it's been a
long day and we're not done
yet um uh I'm uh Representative Bob Lynn
from wendam I'm the prime sponsor of
this bill um and I should say that um
this the impetus from for this bill was
uh some discussions that I had with uh
representative katab who is a member of
the special
committee uh along with representative
Smith um on the uh uh the family family
court um and I should say at the outset
I I would direct your attention uh at
the outset because I think this is
really
important to paragraph Roman numeral
three of the bill which appears on page
two it's really the
last uh
paragraph and the importance of that is
that it
says nothing in this section shall
affects affect the rights of Agri
parties or litig
to pursue any other remedies available
by
law so I think I'm going to wait for
until everybody's through passing things
out
so anyway what uh what I the reason I
bring to the the last paragraph of the
bill to your attention is this um in all
cander I don't know that this bill is
absolutely necessary because it seems to
me that under the existing
law if there was a situ ation where a
Judicial officer was found to have
committed some
misconduct and there was any kind of a
credible claim that that misconduct
could have
affected um the the results in any
particular case there are already
procceed I mean for for example there's
there's pretty well established case law
in New Hampshire that if the in a family
law really in any case but in a family
law case if there's been a fraud
committed um uh in connection with the
proceedings um that case can be reopened
um so there's you know
um and that's sort of the kind the kind
of thing that we're talking about here
so I think in those in those kinds of
cases I'm not sure that you need this
bill but but it seemed to me that
that the importance of the bill and this
is what I sort of ask you to consider is
that to the extent
that there needs to be a there needs to
be a public
perception that not just that there's
case law in the New Hampshire Supreme
Court or in yeah in the New Hampshire
Supreme Court really that would allow re
relief in these kinds of cases it would
be better to have something in writing
in statutes sort of confirming that and
so that was a large part of the
motivation uh for drafting this um and
uh so I so
I uh drafted this bill basically to
create a statutory remedy that would say
um if there's been a finding of judicial
misconduct against primarily it's going
to be a judge although Clerks of Court
uh could be covered are are constitute
judicial officers for purposes of the
code of judicial conduct but let's
assume we're talking about a judge if
there's been a finding of misconduct by
a judge then a person who alleged that
that
misconduct had a causal relationship to
their case and you know I I think it's
really important to to emphasize this
point I think it's its common sort of uh
rhetoric for lack of a better term for
if if if a judge has committed has
committed some
misconduct to assume well everything
that that judge touched throughout his
or her career must have been affected by
that misconduct well Common Sense would
would tell you that you know that's
probably not the case um if a judge uh
uh for example suppose a judge
should have recused himself or herself
on some particular case because let's
say the there you know they had a
personal relationship with the attorney
in the case well certainly you might say
it would be entirely appropriate to say
well wait a minute you know we better go
back and look at what rulings the judge
made in that case
um that's one thing that seems to me it
could make perfect sense but to say well
the you know five years ago the judge
handled other case with people that had
no relationship with there's no
allegation that the judge had any
relationship that that must have been uh
there must have been some misconduct
there too that's just what's the basis
of that um and so that's what this is
designed to get at is if you are
claiming
that a judge who has been was found to
have violated the code of judicial
conduct has has or may have have done
something that affects your case that
that finding of misconduct has some
implications for your case you can ask
that the case be reviewed by the chief
judge of the court that that judge sits
on and the judge will make a preliminary
determination of basically um
uh uh is it you know is there a uh a
reasonable likelihood that the
misconduct of the judicial officer had a
causal bearing ing on the challenged
ruling uh decision or judgment in your
case and if there's that reasonable
likelihood then the judge will uh the
decision will be vacated and the case
will be remanded to a different judge uh
for basically for a doover for lack of a
better term uh a doover to reconsider
the the matter
um so that's that's kind of the upshot
of this the one thing and I this this
gets to be Technical and I and I but I
think it's important because I I I
suspect we may hear from some other
people and I think it's kind of
important that you um you understand
this um you'll notice that I said that
the decision of the chief judge in my
example is not reviewable that decision
is a final decision and is not
appealable and I I know that um I had
some discussions with with the New
Hampshire Bar Association about that and
they may have some some objections to
that I'm not particularly married to
that view if there's I mean I to the
extent that there is that some people
think that decision should be
reviewable um you know I I I'm certainly
open to that and leave it to the
committee the one thing I would say and
this this is where this gets to be uh a
little bit of inside baseball but it it
really has very practical
importance if in the example the the
chief just the chief judge of the Court
says that the judge finds that there is
no reasonable likelihood that the that
the uh the the judicial misconduct had
some bearing on your particular
case um I I could understand changing
the D what I've drafted to say okay that
ruling can be appealed to the Supreme
Court that's one thing because uh if if
the judge says that there's no causal
connection that's the end of that's the
end of that complaint and so an argument
could be made that you should be able to
appeal that to the Supreme Court before
your case is sort of finally thrown
out flip the situation suppose the judge
says
yes I find that there is a reasonable
likelihood that the misconduct had some
may have had some bearing on your case
so I'm sending that
case back to another judge for a
redo in that
situation the party who doesn't like
that ruling doesn't like it being sent
back to another judge I feel very
strongly should not be able to appeal
that decision right then
because if the person can appeal right
then it's that that's going to be that's
what that's going to do is just delay
the initial
determination rather what makes more
sense is to
say you can't appeal right then if you
are on the losing side of that decision
but once it goes back to the other judge
for a redo that judge is going to make a
decision and if you you know if you are
the losing party on the decision to send
it back to the
judge and you are also the losing party
when the judge reconsiders it then you
can appeal at that time and you can
appeal both decisions it just it's
that's a Doctrine in the law called
avoiding peace meal appeals and it makes
a lot of sense and I think it makes
sense here I know that's you know that
may be more more legal Nuance than you
uh than you want to know about but I
think it's I think it it is important
with that I'm happy to answer any
questions that anyone may have and I'm
sorry if I bored you representative
Manos
please thank you you you would never
bore me with this stuff I love it um
anyway I wanted I wanted to know about
the phrase formal
discipline um and I was wondering
whether that means public discipline and
what if the discipline were private I
presume there can be private judicial
discipline
right you know what yes although it's
it's it's at a pretty low level I think
it if it goes
beyond you know like a warrant maybe a
warning or U I'm not even sure I think a
reprimand even becomes public uh if you
know have it's been four years since
I've dealt with uh the code of digal
conduct but I think that's right I think
even a reprimand becomes public so it's
would have to be something less than
that like maybe a warning would not be
public um and if there's somebody from
the bar or the the court system here
they can correct me if I'm wrong on that
but that's my impression it gets to be
public at a pretty you know at a pretty
low level uh but I think if it was not
if it was below that then I then it's
not covered by
this representative
tur yes representative tur oh I'm I'm
sorry representative Lyn I've got to con
right now thank you you know you give
you give somebody power and they forget
where they are sorry about that U than
thanks for taking the question um I'm
just wondering is is is is are there
cases that have happened that that that
one could look at to sort of see where
this would have changed the result is
this sort of a is this I guess I'm
wondering theoretical or is this
something that happens with some
frequency um and and there's observable
outcomes that that we could say you know
would be the reason for this
I think my answer to that question I'm
sure you will hear from other Witnesses
something much different my my answer to
that question is that it is pretty rare
I'm not saying never I Do Not For a
Moment say that you know the judicial
system in New Hampshire is is there's
you know it's it gets an A+ on every
single thing but I do think unbalance
the judicial system here is pretty darn
good um and I think that it instances of
misconduct are relatively rare um and
where they happen um I
think
the they tend to be a you know a sort of
a pretty
discreet situation as opposed
to you know I I I don't you know a judge
a judge taking a bribe to fix all kind
all traffic cases or something like that
I have never heard of that uh kind of a
thing in in New Hampshire but there are
you know there have been some misconduct
no
question and just just following up
there there's not like a case that you
would say would be one that that someone
should look at if if they were trying to
think through
this uh well there's a
[Music]
um I mean I can think of two cases
unfortunate really really unfortunate
situations uh we had one case it really
had nothing to do with any you know a
judges ruling in any particular decision
and by the way these are I can talk
about these because they became public
we had a judge you know judges are
evaluated every three years um uh we had
a judge that was and and the way the way
that happens is people fill out
questioners and they send them back in
to to people that um uh uh
calculate the the
results unfortunately we had a judge who
was filling out his own questioners and
submitting them as if they were
submitted by you know members of the
public um and as you might expect uh he
was not giving himself bad
ratings um that was discovered I have to
EMP this is really really important that
was
discovered by uh administrators and the
administr judge in the C it was a
circuit court judge that this was
happening but it was discovered by that
administrative uh judge and the the
administrator in the Circuit Court um
that you know that that uh that that
happened and that person is no longer a
judge um the uh the other the other one
that I that I
don't really don't know much about the
details but it's obviously been in the
in the papers you've probably heard you
know there was a judge who allegedly had
a had a friendship with a um with a uh
Guardian atam I believe and
was uh was because of that friendship
was making
um uh appointed that Guardian at
lium in circumstances where where where
you know that maybe that that shouldn't
have been done and apparently there was
an allegation if I understand correctly
that that Guardian at lightam was sort
of
billing uh was billing more time than
was justified and the judge was
approving that I don't believe and I
again somebody could correct me if I'm
wrong because I was not personally
involved in in any part of this case I
don't believe there was any claim that
the judge was somehow you know on
getting a portion of the of the
Guardians fees or anything like that the
claim was simply that because they were
friends the guard the judge was uh was
was you know overly generous in
approving uh or being less critical than
she should have been on the uh on the
bills that were submitted by the
guardian that that's my understanding
anyway of it but those are those are
sort of two two
examples I'm happy to answer any other
question any other questions for
representative
Lynn great thank you you're excused uh
we now call Robert tangl tangway excuse
me
uh thank you all um I really appreciate
being here and what you guys are doing
um first time uh speaking before uh The
Honorable Bob lint I do listen to him
rep Smith thank you and uh Miss kutub
and everybody else as well uh so I'm
opposed to this bill as it's in
expedient um it's not necessary article
8 of the New Hampshire
Constitution uh already holds our
government accountable but what we're
actually happen happen what's actually
happening on the streets or courtrooms
and to me the courtroom is is a church
where you go to find Justice the truth
and uh and be treated fairly uh we're
not having that and and I've gone to
other courts and it's really with the
family courts what we need to do is we
need to repeal
173b it's unconstitutional Article 15 of
the New Hampshire state
constitution rights of the accused where
there's a criminal process you are
required the state is required to
provide
a legal counsel to you and also prove
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and and with
there's plenty of instances where this
hasn't happened and so I've already uh
sent to all your attention
um the extreme conflicts of interest
that are happening in New Hampshire
courts and I'll describe those in my
personal
capacity
um the the judicial referee wrote
physically and mathematically impossible
findings of fact I gave a notice to the
clerk and she um
dismissed it and passed it to another
judge and then another judge and I'm
these are signed
affidavits and so what we found in my
research um is that there's a rule
called RSA 21
G25 it's a law I apologize and it goes
from the Constitution the laws God gives
us our constitutional rights or nature
and so this
21g um it says
that
the lobbyists or companies that employ
lobbyists are not allowed to be on any
commission yet we have a legal testimony
in
this uh room and also in the special
committee anything that came from the
domestic violence Coalition Lynn chanet
and three other registered lobbyists is
a legal testimony and it's been brought
to the attention and uh nobody's doing
anything about it just ignore it and
this is because she's Lynch manette is
on the governor's domestic violence
commission and the Supreme Court task
force which has judicial referee I mean
I'm sorry uh Supreme Court Justice Hans
Marone who's a member of the women's Bar
Association on November 8th of
2023 the domestic violence Coalition got
$2.4 million signed by the
governor and yet she
lobbies and then also heads that
commission which was at the Supreme
Court on November 17th
2022 and I'll go through the things that
happened I was at the Supreme Court Lyn
shanet was
there running the meeting where they
talked about wiretap
laws and they're really part of a
nationwide organization the National
Domestic Violence Coalition and then
when you go from
there um later that day I come into
Governor shunu office office and on
there so this is November 17th there's a
letter that was written to me saying
I've been talking to them for a year
trying to expose this but basically a
letter they wrote To Me November 2nd
November 8th $2.4 million is given to
the Coalition November 17th when I was
there on the desk in the governor's
office was a email from Jennifer Smith
defaming me Robert tangu saying
basically I'm crazy saying that I have
to get a psychologic iCal examination
which is not true and that uh I'm not
allowed to see my children without
supervised visits unless I get that
psychological evaluation which is not
true I'm a registered lobbyist I'm here
on my own behalf I have nobody has paid
me to be here I'm here to save my
children and um so with that those facts
have been presented to people it's very
important that this is on the record and
that anything that the domestic violence
Coalition has touched during these
periods of time from 202 21 I believe to
November 17th and they just canceled
their meeting all bills going forward
are tainted all funds going forward are
tainted and then um just to just bring
up so 173b that we have judges that are
just breaking the law it's it's what I
call paper stuffing they paper stuff you
for use of a better word uh that is in
appropriate to the decorum of this room
uh they paper stuff you they just throw
lies at you they write false narrative
they break the law they provide no
justification and this is the level of
my pleadings they are very very good
they are very well done but they
retaliate proos against prosay
individuals so this bill is
inexpedient we need to repeal 173b we
need to look at before you go with any
bill you need to read the Constitution
and then the bills that are repugnant to
the Constitution shouldn't move forward
this enhances it but but where this bill
was derived from is uh one that was made
in 2001 which the Supreme Court made a
rule we need a commission internally for
the balance of powers we need to
counterbalance and then by having a
commission you can't have lobbyists or
people who employ lobbyists on that
commission so that's what's happening
and it's it's really what
sununu's
um administ ministration it's very
corrupt and I've been having a lot of
problems with it I would appreciate any
questions I could talk for almost as
long as uh Mr Lynn but I would
appreciate any questions for
clarification I'm not going to ask
question I just G to ask there were
questions I can't ask if you
question I found a question if you don't
have a questions I'll I'll I'll read um
article two of the New Hampshire
Constitution representative Oregan did
you have a question um yes this is just
a slight um factual things so we heard
yes sir I heard s reference to somebody
named Lynn shenet and is she related to
Lori shanet who is director Health and
Human Services thank you for correcting
me sir uh uh Miss shanet is the director
of the domestic violence Coalition I've
supplied these in writing um so to be as
factual as possible I'm 100% honest
thanks thank you thank
you any other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you thank you um I I
just want to draw special attention to
article two natural rights article 3
society and its uh organ organization of
purposes and rights of conscious
unan I also want to bring attention to
the classifications of crimes RSA 625
colon 9 where it describes that violence
is a
physical or severe bodily injury
violence is not emotional or the threat
of physical so they have Jerry Mander
the family courts and they have Jerry
Mander
our idea which is by Statute of what
violence is violence is not a
disagreement violence is not a sad hurt
feelings or wishing that the husband
made more money or the
woman was in better shape or whatever it
may be thank you so much for
everybody
uh we now call Dana
alch good afternoon Mr chair and members
of the committee thank you for having me
my name is Dana alre from nashaa I'm a
father of four and uh this isn't
theoretical to
me uh a point earlier uh three judges
with proven findings of
misconduct uh have been involved in my
case the first being Paul Moore who
signed the very first order in my case
uh that replin alluded to earlier with
the uh ballot stuffing on the
evaluations
um the uh second of which was Julie and
traso uh Julian traso was uh I am one of
the nine cases in which Julian traso
appointed her close friend Kathleen
Sternberg and improved uh improper Fe
increases so I'm one of those too and
last but not least and specifically
because of my case uh marital master
dapra Bruce dapra was removed from the
bench again we have a supreme court
order on that
uh so unfortunately I feel uniquely
qualified here this isn't
theoretical and I guess to quote Katniss
everine I guess I volunteer as tribute
to testify about this so everybody
should
have
uh three handouts from me first is an
exhibit list Mr alberch the committee
has all your your exhibits we will read
through them if continue with your
verbal testimony that would be greatly
appreciated thank you okay just to
remind you what you I exhibit list
uh deposition of Judge David
King and uh deposition of honorable
Julian traso I may refer to those in my
testimony
so uh first and foremost the issue I see
with this
bill is that it would ask an AG grieved
party and I think in this case I count
with the three different findings uh to
go to the administrative judge for
Relief the problem with
that uh is in my opinion the
administrative judge is personally
responsible for much of this
debacle and actively covered it up
uh if you have a look at the
exhibits in my
case uh Master dapra committed proven
misconduct November 6
2020 within one week of that the
administrative judge was fully
aware uh that that uh misconduct was
being deliberately admitted from
official transcripts in my case so we
have a falsified
record uh and he did nothing about it
when that went to The JCC you'll see
exhibit 3 on 216
2021 uh The JCC actually dismissed it uh
the complaint against Master Del
pra uh claiming there was no likelihood
of
misconduct uh and again judge king was
aware of that at that time as well and
did
nothing by the time you get to to uh
exhibit 4 uh December 16th
2021 you have a final uh New Hampshire
supreme court order in my case I think
the relevant portion the whole order is
in the packet but the relevant portions
are highlighted in
yellow um essentially because of Judge
King the Supreme Court was sent on a
wild goose
chase ordering three different
copies versions of What should be an
official transcript over the course of
two
years when he knew there was a problem
within a week of the
event
um if so we kind of sent the Supreme
Court on a wild goose
chase uh when you look at exhibit five
now we're out in April of
2022 we've got the New
Hampshire uh Attorney General's office
investigating
uh the AG's office public Integrity unit
uh you've got a letter there uh
investing irregularities in the
transcript and once again uh they got it
wrong uh kind of lacking knowledge of
Judge King's involvement and cover up
even by then uh Mr chair so excuse me
could I ask question of the chair
um all this information is very
interesting from an hysterical point of
view some of it some of us have seen
before and not my question however is
could you please tell us
exactly what relates to the pending
legislation we are not here to rehear
any of your cases or anything that may
have gone right or wrong what we need to
know is looking at the bill that's
before the committee do you agree with
the bill do you disagree with the bill
how would you change it so if you can
confine your if that's all right with
the chair if you could confine your
testimony to that rather than going back
yet
again over matters that are incredibly
important to you and therefore to this
committee but not necessarily relevant
to the bill uh I think it's directly
relevant to the representative Smith
because if you look at uh page one uh
line 17
18 the relief is supposed to go is a
petition to the Chief Justice or
administrative judge of the court and if
the
problem is the administrative judge of
the court in the first place
you're asking the person who
potentially
uh
um was UN potentially untruthful under
oath in his deposition to the judicial
conduct committee for
Relief
um you know that's like asking the the
fox to guard the hen
house the bill asked me to seek relief
from the very
individual
who is probably most responsible for
this debacle in the first
place it's right in the bill I'm
supposed to go to the administrative
judge well I'm talking about the
administrative judge that's the direct
relevance of the bill you have the
deposition of the administrative Mr Al
if I can ask you a question is your
matter settled at this point in
time uh I it's a yes or no question what
is your matter settled at this point in
time you've brought us um quite a
substantial amount of documents so is
your case settled at this point in
time uh I have a pending uh I've asked
the US Supreme Court for so you got a
pending appeal to the US Supreme Court
okay so at this point in time it's
subtle so if we did pass this this
wouldn't have any bearing on your case
at this point in time would
it um because we cannot make any laws
retrospective exp the whole laws not
permitted to the New Hampshire
Constitution so as such let's move on
with your presentation because this is
all in the rearview mirror thank
you so
uh respectfully sir it may be be in the
real VI but one of the representatives
over here asked if there are specific
cases and there are more than
mine uh I would refer you
to that question was directed to a
previous witness so it's the questions
that are directed to yourself Mr Albert
thank you okay but I believe that issue
was properly before the committee
whether there are specific cases if you
look at exhibit nine you'll see the nine
cases uh I gave you a
list uh so you guys go through that uh
as a case
study uh you have the complete
deposition of Miss incasso discussing
those cases so you can go that through
that for a case study on what the
potential is and coming back to the bill
itself and to address some uh comments
by the
sponsor
um apparently this is about public
perception um I
respectfully disagree on uh the whole
need to prove a causal
connection uh that's inconsistent with
US Supreme Court president and ripo V
Baker which chastised the new excuse me
the Nevada Supreme Court for applying
the wrong legal standard the legal
standard is not some kind of proof of
bias the legal standard per current US
Supreme Court is risk of
bias and the
issue so first of all this bill is
repugnant to article 8 in terms of
accountability of magistrates and
officers it it's just repugnant to the
Constitution it doesn't hold the right
people
accountable um with regard to the nine
cases you have before me
I would assert it's also utterly
repugnant to article 10 of the State
Constitution I'd certainly review um
suggest everybody review articles 8 and
10 including our
listeners uh article 10 provides strong
protection for equal
protection uh our state supreme court
has recognized that for over 100 years
opinion of the justices 144 and H 374
1999 going all the way back to State
vpoer
65 uh NH
1889 and because article at 10 provides
such strong equal protection or is
supposed to what you have here is nine
cases a very similarly situated
litigants who were treated radically
different by the court system you've got
selective recusal and sign
you've got people not knowing about it
for years and other and the way the bill
is written it would only provide relief
to the person who brought the complaint
it wouldn't provide any relief to you
know the other nine cases where this
specifically went on
so
um I mean the way this is
written I don't see any way any body
could in practice ever get any relief
from this it kind of brings to mind May
the odds be ever in your
favor are there any questions for this
witness representative
kutab thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so you have ex
you've given us examples of cases where
judges have now been or been found uh to
have committed miscon conduct however
you are opposed to this bill is there a
way that the bill could be amended to
address the concerns that you have or
you just opposed to it in
general uh I would amend it to bring
back something like the prior RSA
494 a uh judicial conduct
commission with enough tweaks to make
that past constitutional muster so that
when we have sort of real
cases like we're demonstrating here
where there really is a
problem uh we have more legislative
oversight and more independent oversight
that's not under the
Judiciary um sort of to quote juvenile
who will watch the
Watchers are there any other questions
for this a witness
seeing none thank you thank you for your
consideration uh committee now calls
Randall s
Collier representing
himself good afternoon committee um
thank you for letting me speak today I
oppose uh the commission's bill um there
obviously some word needs to be fixed
with it um originally it says in the 60s
that uh the judicial conduct commission
was uh organized to investigate
prosecute and adjudicate complaints
about judicial
misconduct um I believe was it in two
2001 that the Supreme Court said that
the commission was
unconstitutional um and I'm just kind of
curious I'm confused and and regards the
committee and the and the commission um
we filed grievances with the Comm with
the judicial conduct committee uh and
they were all
denied um but I have some questions for
the for the committee if the Circuit
Court was made by legislation that is
unconstitutional there's a good chance
the committee uh that was formed in the
60s was right that the commission is
also un
unconstitutional um what was the Supreme
Court's reasons that the commission was
found unconstitutional is the same
reasons that the Circuit Court was found
unconstitutional uh this also means that
uh circuit Court's obviously an
administrative Court um and they violate
our rights through
173b um but however we all know that uh
circuit courts an administrative Court
not a constitutional court so they
violate all our rights anyway um but we
do need checks and balances throughout a
independent commission um we need checks
and
balances um and I don't know how to to
reword it but we we do need um checks
and balances on on all branches of
government um I have a lot here to say
but it's probably too much for everybody
so uh any
questions representative
gon this may be a question that someone
else can
answer but I wonder if there's a little
confusion about what this bill or maybe
I'm the one who's confused this
time this bill appears to me to
say a judge has been found to have some
sort of of
misconduct by the judicial
misconduct
whatever now if you had you have had a
case before that judge and you believe
that that judge's misconduct affected
the
ruling you can now petition the court to
have your case reviewed so this isn't
about bringing a complaint against the
judge it's about getting getting your
case
reviewed and as it pertains to perhaps
if the problem is the administrative
judge the remedy is in lines 20 through
22 that says that you would then if if
that's who the problem is you would go
to the most senior associate judge of
the court in question so if that's the
problem you go you you jump the chain of
command to the next highest one or
whatever
so am I am I reading the bill correctly
that that's what this bill does and do
you understand that that's what this
bill is doing not about your claim
against the judge and and trying to
initiate some sort of action against the
judge but rather to have your particular
case that that judge heard reheard or
reopened in some way yeah but there's a
lot of other uh like back doors that
need to be checked before that happens
um and we're trying to get through that
through all these other bills but if
administr Court Circuit Court rule 2.2
says um Rules of Evidence don't apply in
domestic violence or or family cases
because it's an administrative Court
Article 15 is rights of the accused
right judicial mission mission conduct
or mission statement is the follow the
Constitution so every single
administrative hearing is completely
violating all of all the citizens rights
so the judicial conduct committee knows
this because it's not a con
constitutional court but we we need a
remedy because every time that we go
looking for a remedy it's always backed
and it's always denied so we we
need a body separate leg well I don't
know including the Judiciary but for
oversight
because they continuously violate our
rights but then when we go for redress
because the redress committee's gone too
now part of the First Amendment um we
have nowhere to
turn so I I understand what you're
saying but go
ahead follow I I I I don't think that
this bill actually addresses that
problem it's not intended to I know
there's another bill somewhere at least
I maybe dreamed it one night but uh
there there is other legislation that
may address your that issue but that's
not this one okay unless I'm
mistaken any other questions for the
wit article 14 and Article 15 to I mean
it's the rights of the people so we we
need to have something in place
so questions okay saying none uh Anthony
Kenny
please that is the last one thank you
representatives of the committee for
letting me speak today I'm here to
oppose HB
1104 uh
in cases where uh well every judge
swears an oath uh to support both the
state and federal constitutions and to
be faithful and
impartial
uh but the judge showing uh a knowing
and
willingly uh showing partiality in
favoritism or bias poor
decision-making uh due to a known or
many known conflicts of interest uh
intentional violation of Rights to good
parents and innocent children in cases
where these violations by the
judges uh also violate their oath of
office they harm families keeping
parents from seeing their children uh
keeping innocent children from seeing
their parents the system is already
broken uh and it makes it near
impossible for any late to seek Justice
for their losses family or children uh
it seems like the way the law is set up
right now uh there is a way to get a
remedy makes it hard to go through the
judicial conduct committee uh when you
make a complaint as you've already heard
today um it's not if the administrative
judge is the problem then it goes to a
different judge I think what the meaning
was is if there's a problem with any
judge it goes to the administrative
judge who covers it up that's the issue
okay so uh
1104 just adds to the problem because
now you have to go through the channel
you have
to it says all of these considerations
must be met well what if all of those
considerations are not there in your
complaint what if it's you know oh the
judge has a relationship with a
co-parent attorney uh and refuses to
recuse himself and making bad decisions
uh leaving your child either without
parent or or living with their abuser
uh so so uh this bill is just another
act uh for judicial Mis conduct to get
pushed under the rug uh as far as formal
discipline the law was already set when
it was
changed uh uh in in in it uh and just
touch on uh uh alyn when he said that uh
the finding of judicial conduct is rare
or very rare that's again the issue it's
very rare to find by the judicial
conduct committee or go going through
the administrative judge but it's not
very rare that there's a complaint
because the judicial conduct committee
acts like each individual complaint is a
new complaint on a different judge when
they're compiling many many complaints
on the same judge that shows a pattern
of behavior when all prosade litigants
are in there saying the very same thing
about the very same
judge so I asked the Senate to oppose HB
1104 and request that the Senate also
oppose the passing of
104 I further ask that the Senate amend
New Hampshire RSC
494a uh 494a the judicial conduct
committee uh would have if it had been
imp implemented would have shown greater
accountability transparency in checks
and
balances uh Bill 1104 clearly I already
read that part so I'll take any
questions if you have any
are there any questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
and uh is there anyone else who wishes
to be heard on House Bill
1104 seeing none we'll now close the
hearing on House Bill 1104 thank
you and since we are Beyond
3:45 I'm going to uh reopen the hearing
on how Bill
1283 um and I'm going to
call
uh
Lisa Lisa Schmid pardon Lisa Schmid
Schmidt yes I'm sorry okay M Miss
schmith
Smith right
right
thank
you this
is to
die
no no it's fine I yeah no I understand
don't no problem no
problem all
right M SM again I'm just going to ask
you if you could please confine your
remarks to two minutes okay thank you my
name is Lisa Schmidt and I support this
bill my husband Jack was a vibrant
active 82y old still kaying hiking and
splitting and stacking six cores of
firewood in August 2022 when he was 83
he was diagnosed with stage four
prostate cancer he started hormone
treatments and he had some benefits from
that uh but then the nausea pain
constipation and weakness increased he
went from a cane to Walker to wheelchair
in a few months he chose Hospice in
April of this last year hospice was
amazing but he even so he experienced
breakthrough pain and his constipation
got
worse he had always wanted to make use
of Medical Aid and dying and he wanted
us to go to Vermont where it was legal
for out of-state residence but it is
nearly impossible for a terminally ill
person to Access Medical Aid and dying
in Vermont at that point so it was not
an option for us he talked about ending
his life and he wanted me to purchase a
pistol
in August he was unable to get out of
bed even with a Hoyer lift the the only
way to help him evacuate his bowels was
with multiple enemas and me wearing
gloves and helping draw out the the
poop a manual assist in
September in order to control his dying
he chose to stop eating and
drinking he stopped eating and drinking
on September 4th and died eight days
later helping my husband navigate his
final 12 months of his life was a
journey and a gift but nothing was to be
gained by forcing him to live beyond his
meaningful
life and with so much
suffering he wanted me to do whatever I
could to make Medical Aid and dying
available to more people and in New
Hampshire thank you thank you ma'am
questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much uh Betsy
Wallman or Walmart and then the next
witness will be cherelle
Sando uh Betsy Walmer here all right no
uh sherel Sando Sando and the next
witness will be uh Nancy uh Dorner
good afternoon my name is Cheryl Sando
sorry for the voice and thank you for
being here this
afternoon um I had this all prepared but
for the two-minute limit I'm winging it
I submitted my testimony and I just want
to say I've been a registered nurse for
40 years I worked in catastrophic case
management and oncology so a short story
is I just managed their care from
beginning to the end whether it be
recovery or end of life
I currently work in hospice and have
worked in hospice for a long time now
I'm just going to switch over to my own
personal experience I've taken care of
lots of people I'm done so many stories
good bad and all that um I was diagnosed
I moved up from conquer to millsfield in
2011 and got diagnosed with cancer not a
lot of care up there being the case
manager I had to case manage myself and
I went everywhere to get my treatment so
I had surgery I had chemo and radiation
everywhere and my tumor is um a very
aggressive a tumor and it's
um uh it's got a saroma component and as
a hospice nurse I know how badly that
can end and so I love my life and I'm
doing well uh since then but I want the
option I believe in this bill because I
want the option to have that should my
cancer invade my body in a way that I
don't think hospice can manage
and I really truly believe that we
should have the choice just having the
choice alone will take away the anxiety
I would have knowing how I would may die
may not I may not need it but I like I'd
like to know I could if I needed it so
that's my story thank you thank you very
much ma'am questions for this witness
seeing none Nancy Dorner and next will
be Dr Kevin
lus here okay all right not here Dr
Kevin lo
lus I
think okay great if you could just share
it with us at at the end maybe uh uh
Christine Peters please Christine Peters
here all right Dr uh
Dion Deon Bernard I was she already here
I think she yeah she testified I think
yes
sorry uh aen wmac
good thank you and I just want to
commend everybody no matter what side
they were um sitting up here for it's
not
easy so I had um I sent something
electronically and then I changed it and
so this is my new
change and then I change it again for
the two
minutes I'm here in support of the bill
HB B1
1283 my name is aen wmck I live in
Walpole New
Hampshire and uh as a hospice nurse I
was a hospice nurse for 30 years and a
nurse for 50 years not that it was 80
um but some excuse
me many people said to me during those
30 years and I would say it's a handful
left hand right hand 10 people in the 30
years who begged for me to end their
life it wasn't all of
them um and one of my first experiences
was a husband of this woman that I took
care of after he died he went to his
truck and he put a gun to his head and I
had to go out and pronounce him and it
was because he was suffering a great
deal uh I think that my experience has
convinced me that for some patients the
most humane and
compassionate care we would be yeah
sorry would be to allow them the option
of deciding to end their own suffering
in hospice you've got psychiatric
evaluation counseling anti-depressants
anti-anxiety meds pain meds and
spiritual care if they accept it those
are all used to help with both the
emotional and physical pain but
sometimes it's just not
enough
death and I and I would like to say um
is that suicide euthanasia the words
that I'm using I'm hearing here today
should not be included in this this is
not
suicide this is death of the patient who
their goal has not been met to be
comfortable we have somehow let them
down the goal is to manage intractable
suffering caused from not only the pain
but that of of emotional and existential
suffering many have embraced and
accepted the dying process but hospice
and end of life care doesn't always get
it right so that's why I'm here today is
to understand that sometimes we just
don't do it and people need to have that
right thank you questions for this
witness thank you very much Deborah
berasia Deborah ber
AIA Wendy
Chase Wendy Chase thank
you okay hi Hi how are you
good I just shut it off thank you
Tim uh thank you very much for letting
me speak today I'm actually speaking on
behalf of my position as a Bo board
member of the New Hampshire Alliance for
end of life options and my name is Wendy
Chase and I am a member of the New
Hampshire Alliance of end of life
options and also I'm a board member of
AEL New Hampshire which is a disability
Justice
Advocates so um I am also the mother of
a physically disabled daughter and it's
important that we protect the people
with disabilities in New Hampshire
therefore when we were doing our
researches we extended invitations and
open discussion s focusing on any
concerns or language changes that might
be needed from our Disability Advocates
to feel comfortable with this bill we
consulted with people from all over the
country excuse me um so
sorry we I'm so sorry we we consulted
with people all over the country the
policy director of disability rights
Center in Oregon told us that none of
the fears have been realized and they
believe believe that people living with
disabilities who qualify for Medical Aid
and dying should have the same rights as
anyone else we asked about
devaluing lives and she said the lives
of people with disabilities are devalued
in all sorts of ways by our culture
Medical Aid and dying law had nothing to
do with that um our New Hampshire poll
which you've heard about and we have
hanging outside 75% of the individuals
in New Hampshire who identified as
having dis abilities agreed with Medical
Aid in dying that it should be legal the
idea that Medical Aid a medical person
would Co a disabled person into Medical
Aid and dying would be a process not
worth taking a dying person has to be
the one who asks for Medical Aid in
dying a caregiver guardian or a family
member cannot do this it has to come
direct from the person there are
multiple steps of eligibility in order
to go through the process
there is no way to say well somebody's
forcing me to do this you can't qualify
solely for a disability old age chronic
illness you must be terminally ill with
six months less to live which you've
heard over and over and then in the
beginning I mentioned my daughter at the
start of my
testimony excuse
me Aaron was a Childhood cancer
survivor who suffered for 20 for for 34
years with severe chronic pain and
medical complications as much as I
believe in support in HB
1283 my beautiful daughter would not
have qualified because she did not have
a terminal illness within 6 months or
less to live the safeguards are in place
if you don't qualify then you don't
qualify but for those who do please
allow this option to be available to
them I thank you so much for your time
time thank you questions for this
witness oh I'm sorry I forgot the seeing
none oh we're all set thank you thanks
Anna
Rudy and next will be Reverend Peter
FR
Fred Fredick Fredericks I think fredin
I'm not sure but I not sure I'm
pronouncing that right but anyway go
ahead good afternoon my name is Hannah
Rudy and I'm a nurse practitioner
working in paliative care currently a
Catholic Medical Center every day of my
job I witness and care for patients and
families who are faced with the
unexpected and unimaginable namely the
diagnosis and subsequent living with a
serious illness that will significantly
impact their lives perhaps it's a
diagnosis of a terminal cancer bringing
with it significant symptoms such as
pain or facing Advanced cardiac issues
and Pulmonary diseases which many times
lead to recurrent hospitalizations and
Progressive limitations
to their day-to-day functional abilities
and need for assistance from
others each of these situations are hard
to face and live with but it's possible
and it's done by many people likely some
in our own families and spheres of loved
ones and while serious illness brings
with it many challenges and
vulnerabilities legalizing assisted
suicide also being referred to as
Medical Aid and dying is not the answer
rather let us focus on inol the services
and supports available to these
individuals and their families paliative
care is focused on helping people live
with their serious illness for however
much time they may have with the aim of
alleviating physical
psychological social and spiritual human
life is precious and amidst facing pain
dependence on others for care and
Assistance or or experiencing unexpected
limitations I've witnessed meaning
making reconciliation love acceptance
and forgiveness come forth during the
final months weeks and days of one's
life by intentionally hastening one's
death time is lost and is unable to be
retrieved and one may never know what
could have been symptoms such as pain
anxiety shortness of breath can be
managed with medications psychological
distress can be addressed by a
multidisiplinary
team kind of over your time I'd
appreciate sure thank you spiritual
distress can be explored and hopefully
alleviated therefore a paliative care
team can distress all of these potential
domains of distress and
suffering and remind patients that
they're not alone and help their family
members in hopefully experiencing a rich
and meaningful end of life and a natural
death thank you thank you questions for
this witness seeing none uh Reverend
Peter FR fried friedricks okay thank you
it's more my handwriting than your
pronouncing and uh Bonnie uh blazel will
be
next good afternoon Mr chairman
honorable members of the committee my
name is Reverend Peter friedricks I am a
Unitarian Universalist Pastor living in
Kean I'm a hospice volunteer I'm also a
member of the board of the New Hampshire
Alliance for end of life options while
while I believe in the separation of
church and state our personal beliefs
can't help but inform our opinions about
issues of life and death and because
there is substantial opposition to this
bill coming from one particular Faith
tradition I feel it is important to
remind you that theirs is not the only
faith-based voice to be
heard my faith compels me to advocate
for the passage of the end of life
options act hp1
1283 Mercy compassion Peace and Love Lie
at the heart of My
Religion passage of the bill will ensure
that terminally ill people will have a
compassionate merciful peaceful and
loving way to bring their unbearable
suffering to an
end you need look no further than the
story of the Good Samaritan to know that
we are all called to provide comfort and
to reduce suffering wherever and
whenever we encounter it as proven by
the experiences of people in the states
that have it Medical Aid and reduces
suffering and provides Comfort to many
who are at the end of life human life is
precious but its sole measure is not in
longevity quality of life as determined
by each individual is an important
aspect of its sanctity Medical Aid in
dying empowers every terminally ill
person to decide for themselves whether
they wish to keep on living under their
current
circumstances Medical Aid and dying is
not just a theoretical theological
question for me as a church Pastor I
have borne witness to painful and
prolonged suffering where this option
has not been available and I have
witnessed the calm peaceful and
compassionate death of a dear friend and
colleague who lived in Oregon where she
was able to exercise her right to bring
her own life to an end on her terms
there's no doubt in my mind which of
these consist of the good death we would
all prefer when our time comes thank you
thank you questions for this witness
seeing none thank you
uh Bonnie blazel and next will be
claudet
Kelly all right okay claudet
Kelly Kelly thank you and next after
that will be uh
Mark uh
lroy good
afternoon I've brought my husband with
me
my name is claudet Kelly Mr chairman and
members of the House Judiciary Committee
thank you for the opportunity to offer
testimony to House Bill 1283 a bill I
might add with bipartisan sponsor
support thank you to each of the
sponsors let me take a moment to tell
you briefly my story on December 18th of
last year I lost my best friend my
husband Bill he was as tough a man as
you will ever meet and he fought hard
battling cancer for three and a half
years
so that he could unselfishly be here for
his loved ones bill was in and out of
the hospital more times than I can count
late last year he nearly lost his foot
and became immobile this for him was the
final straw sitting in a chair in a home
he rebuilt for me unable to function in
insignificant pain despite the
medication assistance from a wonderful
hospice
team House Bill 1283 passed would have
allowed my husband to go peacefully on
his turn Ms surrounded by his family and
loved ones in the state he spent his
entire life in instead we had to
traveled to Vermont with only a few
family members so that my husband could
pass responsibly and safely and make his
own choice and pass on his own terms
ending the months and months of
suffering he endured I urge you to
support this critical house bill to
embrace the meaning of our motto Live
Free or Die and importantly embrace a
person who has been diagnosed with a
terminal illness and allow them to
choose their own path and their own
peace we use the word you made to
underscore the importance of proper
treatment and regulation of animals why
is that word applic why isn't that word
applicable to us to humans I ask you to
consider for yourself what it means to
be Humane and what kind of treatment you
would want should you ever be terminally
ill and suffering like my husband would
you want the government to dictate to
you you with a sound mind knowing your
death is inevitable that you cannot die
with what little dignity you have left
and allow you to end the pain and the
suffering you endured my husband and I
traveled to Vermont so that he can make
his own choice some might say we don't
need this legislation because anyone
else could do the same they are wrong
for it's very difficult to arrange every
step has to be in Vermont a fundament
and fundamentally why should we have to
leave the place we love to die in peace
the morning of his death was Stormy with
high winds and rain my brother and I
could barely brother-in-law and I could
barely get my husband into the truck a
somber 1 hour and 30 minutes of driving
later we experienced a process so
responsible so warm so caring and so
peaceful and so much in the best
interest of my husband it has led me
here today I am begging you to give this
choice to the people
here in the granite state so that you
don't have to limit remaining time to a
few family members so that you're not
forcing your dying loved ones to endure
an arduous long drive in bad weather so
that people like my husband who believed
in everything about Live Free or Die and
was a loyal Grant at Stat or can pass
peacefully in their own home in the
state that they love so much thank you
for your time today and your
consideration on this important piece of
legislature consider how many others you
can help and how many families you'll be
supporting by pass passing this
legislation thank you thank you
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much ma'am Mark uh lroy
and next will be stepen
Wade Mark okay Steph
Wade Mr Wade please and next will be uh
Lawrence
Miller
Mr chairman members of the committee uh
my name is Steve Wade I'm the executive
director of The Brain Injury Association
New Hampshire I'm also a member of the
New Hampshire Coalition for suicide
prevention which works uh mostly with
vets and uh who have suffering with
traumatic brain injury and PTSD so um
really here I'm honored to be speaking
for many of the survivors of brain
injury in the state and their families
family caregivers many those survivors
are just are profoundly disabled uh and
are unable to be here so uh our
community stands firmly against this
legislation uh our feeling is that uh
Medical Aid and dying by physician
assisted suicide they really go together
you can't have one without the other uh
and um also there's some real concerns
about the message of choice and freedom
are the limits to choice and freedom and
we think there are there are spe
specifically limits the choice and
freedom when it affects the safety of
other people or potentially impacts on
other people and uh the feeling is that
this is a dangerous bill it's dangerous
for folks living with severe disability
again I'm speaking on behalf of folks
with traumatic brain injury which is one
of the most severe so uh two reasons why
it's
dangerous one is because the the
proponents of the law cite issues that
essentially are the daily lived
experience of people with with
disabilities loneliness feelings of
burdensomeness lack of control so the
concern is what message does that send
what message does that send to folks
that we're trying to uh to support and
be and be so and express solidarity with
the other danger is most folks on
disability in New Hampshire are on
Medicaid and as you probably know
Medicaid does not provide adquate access
to paliative care so if a law like this
exists what incentive would future
legisl
or funders or insurance companies have
to expand and extend paliative care that
whole system is a mess the long-term can
system really is a mess in terms of
folks on Medicaid there's really not
great support so again I think there'd
be a built-in disincentive for that so
um the final point I wanted to make is
we've heard a lot that this isn't
suicide and all you have to do I we
would disagree with that by the way all
you have to do is go on your your cell
phone and look up online or or Google um
Medical Aid and dying or assisted
suicide and the first thing that comes
up is the heline for suicide prevention
in big bold letters the nine is the 988
number as well as um it says help is
available suicide and crisis helpl line
so that's the again the first thing that
comes up so I don't know how people can
say this is not suicide
when it's recognized at least by the
rest of the world that it's suicide so
um so anyway again I thank you for for
taking my testimony I also have uh in
addition to my own testimony I have uh a
statement by over 20 of the state's
leading disability organizations many
work with veterans living with PTSD and
TBI and others um with concern of this
legislation so thank you very much I'm
please to answer any question pass that
if you just pass that pass right over
here thank you very much questions for
this witness seeing none I'm next going
to call Lawrence Miller and the next uh
will be Brenda but
uh Mr chairman committee members good
got change my testimony good afternoon
uh my name is Larry Miller I'm a retired
US Air Force Reserve Lieutenant Colonel
and I have lived in marac for over 40
years I'm here today as president of the
New Hampshire chapter of the military
officer Association of America we are an
affiliate of the country's leading
organization protecting the rights and
benefits of Uniform service members
veterans and their families to Veterans
MOA has been has made the same promise
they've made to their country never stop
serving I represent the 550 members of
the New Hampshire chapter our 26 member
board of directors unanimously voted to
strongly oppose this bill as veterans
were concerned about the potential
impact this bill could have on our
community as you know veterans are the
leading suicide risk category in the
United States 16 veterans die every day
by Suicide and here in New Hampshire
veterans living with physical injuries
and especially those living with tbii
and PTSD are eight times more at risk
than the general population yes this
bill is about terminally ill people but
it opens the door to unintended
consequences and the message it sends to
veterans is O is worrisome it normalizes
suicide it undermines veteran Suicide
Prevention efforts by by presenting
suicide as a legit as a legitimate
medical option it creates the the
potential for veterans to feel pressured
into making irreversible decisions it
could unintentionally create permission
for veterans to consider suicide
especially if they see themselves as a
burden to their families or communities
it could present a dangerous alternative
that devalues the inherent worth of
veterans living with severe disabilities
and chronic illness and we know from
other States and Canada it opens the
door to expanding assisted suicide to
other vulnerable opt populations and we
know medical Aiden dying legislation in
Canada has led to recommendation of
suicide to Veterans we owe a debt of
gratitude to these veterans who have
made the continue who make and continue
to make sacrifices for our country this
legislature has made enormous
achievements in increased suicide
prevention programs in our state this
bill has a potential to undermine those
Noble efforts so instead of this bill I
would encourage you to explore
legislation expanding veterans access to
mental health programs and compassionate
Health Care especially for veterans
unable to access VA services this
approach should be our priority it
respects the dignity and worth of
veterans and keeps Faith with pe's faith
with the honor they've earned thank you
for listening to my concerns thank you
very much sir questions this witness
being none Brenda butrick and next will
be Ellen
ederly good afternoon oh most evening
um I'm a registered nurse and a nursing
home administrator I've spent the last
35 years caring for frail Elders who
have come into long-term care in the
state of New Hampshire with this
population of people that enter the
nursing home they really are very
vulnerable they're afraid they don't
want to come but they don't have other
options many of them dread having to be
admitted to a nursing home often after
they spent some time they adjust and we
as a team are able to offer them quality
of life and purpose and their vulnerable
state our residents often state that
they do not want to be a burden on their
families it is my concern that there are
those who would oper assisted suicide so
they can avoid being a burden on their
families this will influence their
decision without a doubt it is our
responsibility to show compassion to
this population we serve and to promote
their dignity and help them understand
that they matter they're loved they're
important there have been times when
I've seen a resident be admitted to
hospice often many of the medications
are stopped and they're only giving
Comfort mes which which ease their pain
and other symptoms there have been times
when we've seen them improve when they
come off their meds they've lived long
past the six-month Mark and have
improved quality of life I've seen res
resents come in with a diagnosis of
failure to thrive in the expectation
they will only have a few weeks to live
more than once I've seen a resident like
this get better and live for a few more
years I attribute this to coming into a
supportive environment where they feel
that they're matter and they're given a
reason to live every day to me it is not
the answer uh and sends a message um
that we can that you know you can end it
all and you can lessen the burden on
your family and to to all of us this is
a wrong message if this bill is passed
it would lead to a slippery slope of
normalizing suicide in other populations
we have a serious problem with suicide
in the state and with groups such as
atrisk teens veterans and those with
disabilities passing this bill would
only lead to more suicides among these
vulnerable populations and then the
problem will only get worse we have
multiple ways we can ease symptoms
during a residence terminal illness with
a different option for pain control
symptom control there's really no reason
for people to suffer please vote no on
this bill we have a moral obligation to
take care of those who are most vable
with compassion dignity and respect we
have an obligation to promote life and
living until the time of death comes
thank you thank you questions seeing
none uh Ellen ederly please and next
will be Mary
fahe
good afternoon chairman Lynn and
committee members my name is Ellen Edy
my home is in Rochester thank you for
the opportunity to provide public
testimony on my opposition to House Bill
1283 I am the mother of four children I
was a caregiver for 23
years to my daughter Sarah when Sarah
was 11 years old she was involved in an
accident which resulted in her
sustaining a brain injury
quadriplegia she was fed through a g
tube she was breathing through a tra for
a period of time and was nonverbal she
was 100% dependent on her care from
others Sarah wanted to live to be
surrounded by the love of her family my
family wanted Sarah to be in our lives
Sarah taught us to be grateful of life
as life is a
blessing let's not put sick and disabled
New Hampshire citizens in a position of
justifying why they do not choose the
state endorsed option of assisted
suicide disabled people's bodily
autonomy is constantly under threat as
they are denied access to home
community-based care institutionalized
against their will receive inadequate
Health Care have limited opportunities
and much
more sadly there are people that believe
that living with the disability is worse
than the fate of death do we want the
state of New Hampshire to decide what
quality of life merits death I certainly
don't
today we have heard a lot about choice
and peace of mind but at what cost by
putting vulnerable people at risk I urge
you to vote against House Bill
1283 thank you for listening to thank
you questions seeing none thank you very
much Mary fahe and next will be uh
Marlene macowski
hello my name is Mary fahe I'm a
resident of nasua and I'm here today to
speak in opposition to hb1 1283 I'd like
to address how this bill undermines
Suicide Prevention efforts and puts
vulnerable individuals at risk for
suicide Elation or attempts I have more
chronic incurable and life-altering
diseases than I can count on one hand I
am also the Survivor of a suicide
attempt and have dealt with strong
suicidal ideation over the increase of
in physical suffering and the loss of my
health as I knew it State sanctioned
suicide creates a scale of value on
human lives deeming some more worthy
than others we are no longer stating
that we should protect all lives from
suicide rather we are stating that some
lives are no longer protected from
suicide that some lives are simply not
worth living and we are making this
judgment on the basis of physical health
we strive to prevent suicide in healthy
individuals because of the knowledge
that their lives have inherent and
immeasurable value it is not our place
to remove that value simply simply
because a life is plagued by illness hb1
1283 sends the message that
intentionally and unnaturally ending
one's life in the face of suffering is a
legitimate option my heart goes out to
those facing death and learning to
accept the time they have left in this
life I've had my share of encounters
with death and I know it can be
terrifying I have sat in a doctor's
office and been told that a quarter of
people with my condition die before the
age of 30 I am blessed to know that my
version of the condition is mild and
very responsive to non-invasive
treatment but I did not always know this
and live for some time with uncertainty
one of the greatest burdens in my health
Journey has not been the illness itself
but reconciling the unavoidable pain
discomfort discomfort and fear with the
goodness of life I still struggle to
accept this but while I can hardly
remember a day without bodily suffering
I also cannot remember a day where I
have not been able to find great meaning
and joy when the proponents of this bill
state that it is not only permissible
but dignified to take one's life when
confronting great illness it undermines
the efforts of all those like myself who
have fought so hard to live in the face
of grave and often silent suffering
thank you for hearing my testimony and I
urge you to please vote itl and H should
be 1283 thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
Marlene macowski and next will be
Stephen Canelo or yeah
Canelo good afternoon my name is Marlin
Makowski I am a nursing home
administrator for New Hampshire Catholic
Charities thank you for allowing me to
speak with you
today
um I cannot support this bill I value
the lives of those that we care for
until the end of their natural life it
has been ingrained in me we take care of
those that are frail and vulnerable but
also these are the people who have given
life supported life and have given us
love I cannot fathom that we are here
today talking about whether or not it is
right for a person to be able to make a
choice to end their life and that the
terminally terminally ill May cost too
much money to prolong their
lives I don't know I struggle with who
is just enough to really measure when a
person is to be brought to
death for the terminal person are we to
say Well they're going to die anyway
Perhaps it is best can we give them
something for their pain and just put
them out of misery but who or what can
really determine that
how can this be justified in our hearts
and then how do we carry this within us
for the rest of our
lives people are put here on Earth for a
certain time people should die their
natural end of life the more we minimize
minimize life the more we continue to
evolve towards this
travesty we should stop the thoughts of
destroying humanity and expelling
morality as we know it if this happens
have we lost our faith our dignity our
traditions in our moral comp
Compass but yet we fight the struggle
each day for the lives of those who are
addicted to drugs we start by providing
Naran we fight and struggle each day for
those born with severe
disabilities to do all that we can to
find their best
days why because we value their
lives nearly four years ago we had a
resident who was in the hospital for
three or 4 weeks prior to that she lived
in Assisted Living we received a phone
call from the hospital saying that she
should be brought back to our building
her home to die we were warned that she
may not make it even through the night
when she came through the stret through
the door on the stretcher I heard her
giving directions to the EMTs to turn to
the hallway instead of the elevator I
was really confused first of all because
she was speaking secondly because she
was giving directions to where her room
was I went over to her and I told her
that we were going to care for her
upstairs now if she would if she would
allow us to do that she looked at me and
said okay that will be good well I guess
it was good because 4 years later she
has filled her time by sharing her
talents as a seamstress shared many
stories of her history visited other
people in the nursing home and provided
much laughter to so many of us through
these years apparently she must have
known that she wasn't ready yet it
wasn't her time I do thank you for your
time and please vote against hb1 1283
thank you thank you uh Stephen
uh canat Canelo I guess that's right and
then next will be Ellen
Leonard Mr Stephen
Canelo all right I don't see Mr Canelo
here Ellen Leonard from uh
Conway she's not here not here all right
um Michael luenberger from
Boa
right Dennis oconnell from
conquered Lisa Bodwin from
conquer
good
afternoon chairman Lynn and honorable
members of the committee it's been a
long day and I appreciate your attention
to this very important matter my name is
Lisa
Bodwin there have been a lot of people
identifying themselves today so I'd like
to let you know that I'm a secular
liberal datadriven Disability Policy
analyst with many years of of work at
the state and National level on
Disability Policy I am a subject matter
expert on the systems of care and
supports and services for people with
disabilities I am writing a book on
ableism physician assisted suicide bills
like HB 1283 quote represent an inherent
harm and danger to people with
disabilities unquote according to the
National Council on disability the
independent Federal agency that reports
directly to the president and Congress
NC's key recommendation on two State
initiatives among their long list of
recommend
recommendations State quote should not
legalize any form of assisted suicide
end quote NCD and all national prominent
disability organizations are
unilaterally opposed to these
initiatives
National level policy analysts who are
driven by research and data are not
mistaken in their
assessment about how dangerous these
movements are they see the dangers are
in part rooted in ableist misconceptions
and stigmas about life with a disability
which are intrinsic to the language used
to pass these slippery slope bills
including imposing a construct that I
have heard all day long about what
constitutes dignity for a very narrow
set of
people a very narrow set of people have
an idea about what constitutes life and
a disability with a uh with a life with
dignity and we have to be really careful
about having a narrow construct of that
because I happen to know plenty of
people with disabilities who are
incontinent who have plenty of dignity
in their life and that should not be one
of the metrics by which someone is
allowed to determine that their life is
no longer worth living as one tiny
example the NCD position remains set
steadfast since 1997 their 2019
publication reaffirms the dangers of
assisted suicide in its comprehensive
70-page well- researched document
detailing the serious limits of supposed
safeguards the lack of oversight in
states with assisted suicide almost zero
investigatory power of mistakes and
abuse the loosening of the rules
phenomenon which has happened in every
single state where medical end in in
Medical Aid and dying or end of life
options or whatever euphemism you prefer
can I tell you ma'am your your over your
time so can I ask you to please sum up
yes proponents of hb1 1283 are
leveraging the feeling of citizens on
the dying process to change the law
rather than demanding to make our Health
Care system in this particular case our
paliative care system more robust given
our extraordinary medical Technologies
intract intractable pain is a failure in
the delivery of treatment and physician
training that failure is why physician
assisted suicide is insidiously becoming
normalized so I I really need to for you
to sum up ma'am please thank
you
it is not a mode of care to put in the
tool box given the Deep Well documented
Health inequities people with
disabilities veterans poor folk
communities of color live with day in
and day out we need to address Health
inequities before we can do anything of
this magnitude thank you questions for
this witness seeing none thank you next
I have Alice matland and next will be
Brent
Richardson Alice
maand let's see Brent
Richardson Mr
Richardson and after that will be uh
Robin
Mau Mr Richardson good evening thank you
for your uh patience today um my name is
Brent Richardson I'm from Chester New
Hampshire I'm a nurse practitioner
specializing in pulmonary critical care
paliative care and a board C ified
medical
ethicist
um I'm going off script here as you
requested I'd like to touch on a couple
of things uh that we've heard repeatedly
for some people I I am first of all uh
strongly in favor of uh House Bill
1283 this bill is not suicide this bill
is not a slippery slope this bill is not
a disabilities bill um and it is a tool
that I need in my toolbox and with very
rare
exceptions um I want to touch on I I I
agree wholeheartedly with a lot of what
some of my uh colleagues uh earlier
Physicians and and uh nurse
practitioners said about how uh
paliative care and hospice care can meet
the need in most cases we're talking
about most cases this is a a bill that
would help in those outlier cases where
symptoms and uh details of an illness
can lead to things that are are not
easily remedied with standard paliative
care and hospice care um without getting
too graphic we heard from uh people
earlier uh and again in pulmonary
medicine you're talking about breathing
you're talking about the airway and when
you have tumors that are malignant and
eroding into blood vessels or
obstructing Airways um you're you're
getting to a point where it is so
unbelievably difficult to uh treat those
uh endof life situations that can be
extremely traumatic as we heard earlier
so a bill like this would uh be able to
address those symptom needs and those
rare exceptions where a person cannot
live out their days uh and have a
natural death with standard hospice care
we need this type of uh care for those
rare exceptions where somebody has such
enormous symptom burden or the potential
for a a horrible end of life uh I would
just like to and
uh I think the answer to whether this
bill should become law lies in the
precedent set forth in the opening
sentence of New Hampshire statute 137 J1
where it states clearly that quote the
state of New Hampshire recognizes that
individual persons have the right
founded in the autonomy and sanctity of
a person to control the decisions
relating to the rendering of their own
Medical Care end
quote uh and as we've heard here already
we don't get to choose what a Affliction
may be visited upon us we are all
patience and waiting any one of us or a
loved one may face a profoundly
debilitating terminal illness robbing us
of the ability to eat breathe and live
in Comfort um in that case many of us
would want the peace of mind and relief
that Medical Aid and dying offers um and
I would like to have this uh available
here in New Hampshire as we do in
Vermont and as my parents have available
to them in Maine thank you for your time
thank you questions seeing none Robin
Mau and next will be Kathy Brooks Robin
Mau I don't see all right Kathy
Brooks Kathy Brooks
Carl uh Paul Drager Paul
Drager
Drager close
enough I believe that a copy my
testimony has already been given to the
clerk all right
good evening and again thank you for
your Indulgence this has been a long day
for all of us chairman Lyn and members
of the Judiciary Committee I appreciate
the opportunity to appear before you
today please note that my comments are
my own and I am not speaking on behalf
of any organization or group that I
belong to my name is Paul Drager I live
in summersworth and my purpose today is
to speak in favor of
1283 at the end of our respective lives
if diagnosed with a terminal illness
with a six-month prognosis will we
merely be a patient until the end the
root word of patient is pator which
means to endure suffering or I am
suffering we all get just one chance to
live and one chance to die this bill
asks a not so simple question will we be
allowed to die in a manner consistent
with the way in which we lived which
respects our personal values spiritual
beliefs cultural background and preser
and preserves our dignity do we get to
write the final chapter of our story or
must we be a patient until the end I've
been involved with end of life matters
and an advocate for paliative care since
1995 serving on hospital and hospice
bioethics committees teaching Physicians
Medical students and other health care
providers I was a member of the 2013
legislative study Commission on
paliative care and Associated qual
quality of life initiatives an
individual's end of Life Choices should
be broad rather than Limited in scope
dying is hard work one's decisions
concerning end of life should be based
on the very values beliefs goals and
life lived in the of the individual
rather than arbitrary and judgment
mental beliefs of strangers who would
impose their values and beliefs on
another what may be right for the
individual patient facing imminent death
may not be right for another in the same
situation this is not a time when one
size fits all rather it is where an
individual's preferences for their
unique POS uh situation should Prevail
limiting end of Life Choices is unfair
and burdensome to such individuals we
have various choices that people may
disagree with but they are available and
end up doing the same thing we have
pallative sedation also known as
terminal sedation we have the right over
here can I just ask you to sum up if you
would please sir okay uh in essence what
I'm trying to say is is that in order to
respect the individual they are entitled
we are entitled to that final choice to
decide how it is that we live and more
importantly how we die I would ask each
and individual here every member here to
take a look at the poem that I have at
the end of my written statements it is
read to the Cadence of the 23rd psalm I
think that pretty much sums up this
entire situation I would encourage you
all to please uh accept uh Bill 1283
thank you thank you questions being none
thank you uh Karen Hill
please Karen
Hill all right uh maranne uh
Jackson Maryann
Jackson I think this is on thank you my
name is Maryann Jackson I'm a retired
OBGYN that practiced from 1984 to 2010
up in Carol County and Coos County and
was involved in the care uh through my
GYN practice of
several uh wives sisters and mothers who
had endstage ovarian endometrial and
cervical
cancer one of the things that struck me
as most painful was when someone with a
bowel obstruction was no longer as
you've heard many times able to be
reached comfortably with paliative and
hospice care that we used re liberally I
believe firmly in hospital in excuse me
hospice and paliative care it's just
that there are limits and when patients
would beg me for something that would
hasten their death I felt extremely
uncomfortable that I had no alternative
and nothing that I could do for them and
it felt that I was now the person
between them and their God this was a
God that They begged to be able to be
with who they trusted and they loved and
they want felt was there to reach out to
them and I was prolonging this life
for them and I want to say to you I do
not think it's conscionable that
Physicians can prescribe terminal coma
paliative sedation to Coma or assist in
the um cessation of eating and drinking
for weeks for a patient but yet not
beable to prescribe for them the
medications that are gives them the
option for the death that is the
inevitable outcome either way and I
believe that we are um missing that
Humane alternative and that this is a
bill with very clear eligibility
criteria it can be followed to the
letter it is not ambiguous it is very
robust in the ways in which the
Physicians have to be be able
to um assess for someone's terminal
illness not disability this is not
suicide
this is relief and I believe strongly in
in support for
1283 thank you questions seeing none
thank you Rebecca Brown please and next
will be uh Betsy
McConnell thank you and thank you for
your perseverance and patience today I
am going to give you my written
testimony which describes uh how I was
sitting as a legislator here when my
husband died which is why I'm doing this
work now my husband who was an Army
veteran who did not have this
option and I would like to offer just
very quickly the four people who had to
leave and um and and submit their
testimony uh first is Kevin lucer MD
from Portsmith 40 years as a surgeon who
is very clearly in favor of this bill
for many of the same reasons that Dr
Jackson just explained BL uh second is a
second surgeon Cynthia barbarat who is
also from the Sea Coast she is a 20year
uh sorry 2002 practitioner
gastrointestinal and bariatric surgeon
who also affirms everything that Dr
Jackson just said about needing this as
part of her toolbox and her Continuum of
Care for end of life
patience the third is Alisa Shapiro who
is a uh on full disability she Ed two
major Strokes 13 years ago lives with a
brain injury and she
says because of my strokes and now
living with brain injuries I have lost
some of my autonomy and some of the
control over my own life I know at this
point I have enough parts of my brain
working that if needed I want to have
control over and the same rights to
determine my end of life if I have a
terminal condition as any non-disabled
person would
and she was exposed to covid so couldn't
be here
today and finally from Bonnie uh Leva
from Portsmith whose husband Frank
suffered from brain cancer actually did
qualify with his first trip to Vermont
for Medical Aid and dying but died
before he was able to uh get back all
the way up to St Johnsbury from
Portsmith for his second who fervently
wanted Medical Aid and Dy and shared his
stories for the year and a half uh after
he contacted our organization the New
Hampshire Alliance for end of life
options of which I'm a director to tell
his story in detail about the kinds of
questions and the the finality of
knowing that even though the option did
exist in Vermont that he'd have to leave
home in order to use it and as Bonnie
says at the end of her testimony let me
just find
this since Frank is no longer here to
tell his story it is up to me medical D
Maiden dying is an urgent issue for many
terminally ill adults who just like
Frank want the option to die peacefully
and avoid suffering please support this
bill you will make a profound difference
for so many people people Frank's words
were I've lived as a free person in New
Hampshire I want the freedom to die as
well and thank you for your listening
today uh we've learned a lot from
testimony we um are eager to work with
you on for instance the pharmacists uh
points that were raised earlier and
anything else that the committee would
like to engage in to make this the best
bill for New Hampshire so thank you
thank you questions for this witness
seeing none uh Betsy McConnell and next
will be Sharon
McGinley I don't know she's
here did you want to give me
those no I don't see her here you've
heard from so many people already I I
fear I may be
redundant um I'm so grateful for your
patience in listening to all of us today
and it occurs to me that we have very
few opportunities to talk about dying
and deal with the reality of death and
we've we've heard a lot of
fear a lot of fear of Social and
cultural
erosion from um devaluing life
and there's been a lot of fear about
that and fear that that if Medical Aid
and dying is available it
will it will make life um less worth
living for categories of
people but the reason this bill is
before you is because of the profound
Agony many people go through at this
point and you've heard many many stories
of
that I have uh practiced as a clinical
social worker for 33 years in
Connecticut New York Washington
Pennsylvania and
Massachusetts and over that time I
observed how challenging this can be for
people to come to terms with we just
have a very deep cultural problem in our
inability to cope with
death I saw this firsthand when my
younger sister was diagnosed with
cervical
cancer she fought the cancer she she AG
aggressively fought the cancer and
believed that she was curable and died
in 2 years with horrible
suffering I believe what this bill can
do is begin a process for opening a
space for people to decide how they
would like to live their death right now
there's a a way in which people are
given a
diagnosis and there's a great deal of
panic and also lack of knowledge of
cancer let's say
and
they're uh often really
uh incapable of coping well with that I
thought a lot about the the term the
sanctity of
life and it's something I believe in as
a good
Episcopalian but I don't think that it's
well represented when a person's only
choice is to pursue every possible
medical intervention ending in hospital
care or voluntarily stopping eating and
drinking at least 10 years ago there was
an article in the New York Times about
how doctors die
differently and it said that a lot of
medical doctors when given a um a
diagnosis did not pursue treatment
because they knew what treatment
involved can I just ask you to you're
kind of over your time if you could just
finish up please thank you
um
okay many people are afraid of death and
struggle with being mortal when terminal
illness comes it can be overwhelming to
consider what to do can you imagine for
yourself what it would be like and what
you might want passing this bill would
help people consider their options and
Empower them to make a choice when their
lives are filled with unmanageable pain
and even hospice Aid is limited thank
you for considering this legislation
thank you questions from for this
witness seeing none Shannon
McGinley Shannon
McGinley right Richard
perrow chairman Lynn committee members
thank you for having me here um I
submitted um part of my testimony here
of which the first paragraph is going to
be put in here but I did have some other
issues uh with the bill that I think
need to be
addressed and it covers a number of
different
topics um I I find it
um a little bit um almost every
responsible how how will this bill be
monitored and how does it deal with
Medicare and Medicaid and the place I'm
coming from is you've got people who are
marginalized um uh veterans homeless
people immigrants verbally challenged
linguistically challenged people who
have no access or how to go about
accessing this type of legislation if
you choose to pass this
through uh we all know this is a
committee goes to the house goes to the
Senate goes above and beyond this bill
will look nothing like it does right
now um I I have
a
I I've seen some things going through my
my mom had pocket in for years aspirated
and and died in a coma I had a brother
had colon cancer went through all this
stuff uh some everybody has their own
thing my mom suffered for
years and you know um she was a very
religious person but you know she said
she just wanted to to go but my brother
was completely the opposite
so everybody's the same and my feeling
is that looking at what's been going on
in this around us in this different
atmosphere that we have going on in the
country um I'm kind of remissed to give
up um a
choice to the government as
to how I should number one make a choice
depending on what the government is
going to support and I don't see where
anything in this bill says where the
support's going to come from Medicare
Medicaid for these people especially
those
marginally um on the edges I mean I'm a
veteran a couple times over I was a
flight medic I you I was trained as a a
bio
Anthropologist so um life is different
for everybody not everybody's the same
and I think we have to take into
consideration how these people going to
access
any of this stuff in whatever form it
ends up coming
before the vote here to pass it on the
Senate and at the next stage I I don't
want to see this open up as a as a a
will with all to end with all all right
questions for this witness seeing none
thank you very much sir you welcome
Robert
tangway
I still have some life in me um my name
is Robert tangue I I spoke earlier um I
think that these I'm a I'm for this bill
um this bill is already in law when you
read article two of the New Hampshire
Constitution which is the supreme law we
have a right to our Liberty to live and
also to Aid others these are rights and
our property and you'll find that when a
lot of people are opposed to this bill
you're going to see that the reason why
they're opposed to it is because of
Technology they make money off of it
keeping people alive suffering we have a
choice in our life in our
children God gave us these
rights not the Constitution not our
humble servants which I respect you all
gave us these rights to live our life
and to end our lives
if we need be this is this bill right
here is about uh specifically people who
are going to die there is also a choice
with the doctors to not approve this
they we all have free will we all have
free will to make any decision a police
officer can be ordered to arrest someone
they can choose not to and so that's how
that works I also wanted to bring up so
article two of the New Hampshire cons
stitution and then
also uh the dignity that this allows
people to choose to go in there own way
with dignity with their family at a time
that they choose to at a time not
suffering
suffocating it death can be very scary
um I'd also like to bring up Eugenics
and please let me know if I start to go
over my time you're got you're very
close you're about to go over Eugenics
is the four step ization it was passed
into law in New Hampshire and 32 states
the last Eugenics
law this is forced
sterilization was in 2014 was removed
from the books all
right the Constitution protects us from
the government from intruding upon our
decisions as free citizens that's why
it's already in law and I would
appreciate if you guys would move this
forward
to codify
A system that is clear for someone to
take care of their own matters all right
thank you questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much I have
no more pink cards is there anyone yes
sir did you fill out a pink
card great all right come on
up if you just give the card to
representative staple appreciate that
thank you Mr chair and thank you to all
of the committee members who
uh have stuck it through uh this has
been a very long day even with the
intermission my name is Mary Smith I'm
from Manchester New
Hampshire and I'm here uh to testify in
support of this
bill um
I uh also want to thank uh you
representative Lynn and you
representative Smith for being sponsors
on this
bill um I don't know if you had already
testified uh Mr Lynn but uh if you
haven't testified on this bill I'm sure
there are interesting things and
relevant things that you would be able
to say about uh how the case law in New
Hampshire if it at all um interacts with
um the contents of this bill um but as
to uh myself and my personal testimony
well I don't normally like uh testifying
on bills that have huge
crowds because I find that it isn't uh
hugely useful usually if a large crowd
comes out all of the representatives
have decided how they're going to uh
recommend uh the bill to go
um but uh I did want to use this
opportunity to touch on points that um I
thought were not addressed or that I did
not hear uh earlier which includes that
um
the way that these sorts of cases have
been handled
historically um hasn't been a
perspective that I've heard yet where
uh we live in extremely privileged times
um to be able to access uh the
treatments that we can and that in the
past um when individuals uh made this
made these sorts of decisions for
themselves uh and decided it was the
time to go that um their Physicians if
they had Physicians uh would sometimes
uh give them more more medicine than uh
is necessary for treating in onless or
that their um loved ones would in acting
with their best wishes um remove uh or
or or withhold um any uh medications for
conditions that they have in order to
assist them in this and uh that I mean
that is the reality of the world we live
in in many different countries uh not
this one um because people overwhelming
have the opportunity to pursue different
means um and they do uh unfortunately
and hopefully with this bill passing um
they will have means that are um more
Humane than we have had uh in the past
um and uh one other thing before I go
over time you've been very generous to
everybody who's uh been up here and I
really appreciate it um and I don't know
if your uh fellow committee members will
appreciate it as much that you have been
able to give a little more lenience on
the two-minute rule but uh I also wanted
to mention that there are people who are
interested in dying um and who would be
interested in the options as you've
supported in this bill um for reasons
not including to end their life that
they want to
pursue the methods as outlined in this
bill so that they may be cryogenically
frozen and resuscitated later where
there are um Technologies available to
deal with whatever U medical issues that
they are that are currently
intractable and so it's just another
unusual uh aspect that interacts with
this bill that I didn't hear people
comment on uh thank you very much for
your patience questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much sir is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on hb1
1283 I'm Sorry Miss McGinley I called
that name she miss
McGinley just like we I assumed you
weren't even gonna call me so no we did
great okay thank you so much I
appreciate you uh taking the time to
listen to me I am Shannon McGinley I'm
the executive director of Cornerstone
action here in New Hampshire and I'm
here to ask you to please vote itl on
hb1
1283 we believe that caring and not
killing is the right approach when ever
faced with illness or disability whether
terminal or not whether acute or chronic
this bill tries to lead public policy in
the wrong direction by fostering the
legalization of suicide the sponsors of
the bill avoid saying suicide choosing
instead words like like death With
Dignity patient directed care autonomy
and end of life decisions no matter how
they mince the words the bill clearly
authorizes State sanctioned suicide with
lethal drug prescriptions and defines it
as typical Medical Care this is not
authentic compassion for anyone
suffering from terminal illness
furthermore a pro suicide agenda will
affect everyone in New Hampshire and I
know that you've probably heard much of
this before I'm not going to read
everything that I wanted to say I did
give you my my testimony earlier um
hopefully representative Delorenzo
passed it around but just quickly that a
suicide assed suicide exploits medically
vulnerable
individuals uh it will undermine Suicide
Prevention efforts it uh an assisted
suicide law no matter how narrowly drawn
opens the door to broader
availability and
um and that we see other examples of how
it's being abused in countries like
Canada Scandinavia
uh Scandinavian countries and as well as
Oregon and um I think I'm just going to
end there because I know that it's a
really long day and everybody's probably
really hungry too so does anybody have
any questions of me questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
Miss McGinley thank you so much is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
House Bill
1283 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
1283 yes
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
say it's was very nice to see the
consideration and thoughtfulness of all
the testimony that we all received
voluminous emails and actual handwritten
letters in EM mailboxes uh it was very
refreshing considering the gravity of
the subject matter and we on the
committee greatly appreciate that and I
want to thank the members that stuck in
until the end saying with us we really
appreciate it we know who does all the
heavy lifting on the committee and my
thanks go out to you folks thank you
thank thank thank you thank you all uh
for for being here I I I completely Echo
representative Wallace's comments um you
know just for um members of the
committee and I know not everyone is
here um as you know we I I put out a a
notice of our
executing uh a number of bills uh next
Thursday morning not uh not tomorrow but
next Thursday morning just so you know I
understand that there may be some of
those bills
that we will not be ready to exact that
people will not be ready to vote on that
you want to have you want to spend more
time or whatever and that's fine if
there's it's not my intention to rush
anybody but I do believe that there
probably will be a number of them that
we will be able to vote on and it'll be
those that we'll vote on so if somebody
says you know next Thursday look we need
uh I want to think about this some more
we need to spend more time on it that's
fine that's what that's what we'll do
but uh I think there will be a number
that we can that we can uh uh exact next
Thursday and that's what my intention
will be again thank you all for hanging
in there I really appreciate it this has
been uh this has been uh a marathon
session for sure and thank you to the
members of the public thank
you